AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH OUR
HEARING.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THIS IS OUR FIRST.
FIRST FIRST HEARING OF THE YEAR
OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WERE WE WE ARE HEARING BILLS.
HAVE NINE BILLS BEFORE US TODAY.
WE DO HAVE SOME TIME LIMITS --
WE WILL BE HERE TO WITNESSES PER
SIDE WITH A TIME LIMIT OF THREE
MINUTES EACH.%
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
ASKED TO STATE ONLY YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION FOR THE RECORD
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE A POSITION
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE OR HAVE NO POSITION
BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH OF OUR
AGENDA PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION VERY BRIEFLY
EXPLAIN YOUR POSITION.
THERE ARE NO BILL SCHEDULE FOR
CONSENT TODAY.
WE HAVE A SUBSTITUTE MEMBER
MISTER KANSEN CHU IS JOINING US
TDAY INTEREST RESPECT REPLACE --
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ONLY.
THEIR PRIDE LIKE TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR HELPING US TO BE. TO BE ONE
OF THE FIRST POLICY COMMUNITY
COMMITTEES TO GO PAPERLESS.
AND TO AT TO EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN
USING THE APPLICANT PORTAL TO
SUBMIT POSITION LETTERS --
AT THIS POINT --
WE WE DO NOT HAVE A CORE WE'LL
BE OPERATE AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
AND AS A CUSTOMER THE COMMITTEE --
BILLS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
BE HEARD AT THE END OF COMMITTEE.
SO THE FIRST BILL BEFORE US IT
WILL BE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWO
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT EIGHTY TWO
SIXTY TWO TODAY.
FIRST OFF I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING OTHER THREE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE SIX
OF THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS WITH
APPRECIATION TO STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL --
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
HAVE A MOCK UP OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS BEFORE YOU --
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SAN DIEGO
EXPERIENCE ONE OF THE DEADLIEST
OUTBREAK OF HEPATITIS A VIRUS --
SINCE THE VACCINE FOR THE
DISEASE BECAME AVAILABLE IN THE
YEAR.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX THE
OTHERWISE ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE
DISEASE BEGAN TO SPREAD IT DID
SO AT AN UNBELIEVABLE RATE.
REACHES FAR AS ORANGE LOS
ANGELES AND ACTUALLY SANTA CRUZ
COUNTIES.
STATE INTERVENTION BECAME
DESPERATELY NEEDED AS A RESULT
OF THE H. B. H. A. B. C..
OUTBREAK ORIGINATING IN SAN
DIEGO THE PROCLAMATION OCTOBER
THIRTEENTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS OF APRIL
ELEVENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REPORTED SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FOUR CASES OF HEPATITIS A BY
VIRUS.
BORN IN SIXTY ONE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND TWENTY ONE
DEATHS RELATED TO THIS OUTBREAK.
FOLLOWING THE CONTAINMENT OF THE
OUTBREAK I REQUESTED THAT OUR
STATE AUDITOR REVIEW THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE H. A. B. C. H.
A. V. OUTBREAK.
SHE PROVIDED A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ALL THE
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES INVOLVED IN
THIS BILL IS A DIRECT PRODUCT OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AB TWO SIXTY TWO MAKES CLEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
AGAINST FUTURE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE OUTBREAKS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS ONE IT CLARIFIES A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE ORDERS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN RESPONSE TO A
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE DISEASE
OUTBREAK.
AND SECONDLY IT REQUIRES A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER TO MAKE RELEVANT
INFORMATION SPECIFICALLY THE
LOCATIONS IN CONCENTRATIONS OF
CASES RELATED TO COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE OUTBREAKS AVAILABLE TO
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITHIN
THE COUNTY.
WHEN THIS IS WITH ME TODAY ARE
JONATHAN CLAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WEBER TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO?
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE WOULD
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
HER ABOUT THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA SPONSORING.
EIGHTY TWO SIX TWO AB TWO TWO
SIX TWO SIX TO CLARIFY AND
STRENGTHEN LOCAL HELP OFFICERS A
TORY SPECIFICALLY RELATED.
TO SHARING PERSON INFORMATION
WITH OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES RELATING TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES THAT MAY
AFFECT THEM.
AND TO STRENGTHEN THE ABILITY OF
A HEALTH OFFICER TO ORDER ACTION
OF AN AFFECTED LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IT TO CONTROL THE SPREAD OF THE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE.
IN SHORT THE COUNTY BELIEVES OF
THESE ACTIONS THESE AUTHORITIES
WERE -- IN
PLACE TWO YEARS AGO BUT THAT
ALSO INCLUDE MY TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO WHICH
YOU'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THE CITY WITH AT THE TIP OF
THE SPEAR OF THE HAPPY CRISIS --
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO I WE WERE
CATAPULTED INTO ACTION --
VERY QUICKLY AND AND IT WAS --
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT TIME FOR
THE CITY --
WE WE LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS
HOWEVER THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF OF THE
AUDIT THAT WAS THAT TOOK PLACE
AND AND MISTER GLORIOUS BILL
HERE -- WILL
HELP IMPLEMENT AND HOPEFULLY
HELP OTHER CITIES THAT OTHER
THAT ALSO FACE --
THE SAME SITUATION WE DID A YEAR
AND A HALF AGO SO WITH THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH AT THIS POINT WAS STOP
AND TAKE --
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO I SAID MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
WHAT I HEAR [inaudible]
MAYES.
I HURRY YEAH.
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BURKE CARRILLO.
FLORA [inaudible]
MON [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible] TWO SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
SO WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE A QUORUM
SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AT THIS POINT --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
PLEASE.
A ONE OF OKAY.
SEEING NO --
ONE IS THERE ARE --
OPPOSITION TESTIFY.
THIS IS THE FOURTH ONE SORRY
THIS.
THIS ARE SO IS THERE SUPPORT I'M
SORRY DID.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF ALL
USERS A LINE OUTSIDE ALL OF IRAQ
RIGHT CALIFORNIA LIKE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OKAY OPPOSITION SO WITH THREE
MINUTES EACH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIMEMY NAME
IS NICHOLAS JOHNSON AND I'M HERE
ARMED SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSES THAT.
WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
AGENCIES FAILED TO DO THEIR JOB.
AND NOW WE'RE ASKING TO GIVE
THEM UNLIMITED POWER.
DURING THE PRESS CONFERENCE.
THERE WAS INTRODUCED WHILE THIS
BILL WAS COMING OUT.
SUPERVISOR FLETCHER MENTIONED
THAT DURING THE H. ONE N. ONE
SITUATION.
THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO MASS VACCINATE
[inaudible]
SCHOOL CHILDREN [inaudible]
NOW.
THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS HERE
BUT IN THAT SAME PRESS
CONFERENCE.
ARE REPRESENTATIVE GLORIA.
ALSO MENTION HE WANTED TO HEAR
THE VOICES OF THE PEOPLE.
I HOPE YOU IN YOUR MIND TODAY.
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS HAVE BEEN
TO THIS CAPITAL. TO SPEAK WHEN
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN CAME UP AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
ADDRESSED WAS THE CDC
WHISTLEBLOWER WILLIAM THOMPSON.
WHO CAME OUT AND SAID THAT IN
THE CDC THEY HAVE BEEN
COMMITTING FRAUD IN TERMS OF OUR
VACCINATION PROGRAM?
OUR CONCERN OF THOR TARIAN THIS.
AND I HOPE THAT THIS MEASURE IS
RELEASED TAILORED TO MEET THAT
SPECIFIC NEEDS DURING THE AUDIT
FOR EXAMPLE.
ARE IT WAS MENTIONED THAT.
SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS WERE
THAT YOU CAN USE HAND WASHING
STATIONS ACCESS TO RUSH ROOMS.
THAT STREET CLEANING THESE WERE
MEASURES THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE HOMELESS CAMPS ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND THE SITUATIONS
ARE ABSOLUTELY A DIRE TRUTH THAT
THIS IS A SITUATION THAT COULD
CAUSE A PLAGUE.
WE HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF WHY DO
WE HAVE SUCH A HOMELESS EPIDEMIC
IN THISCOUNTRY.
AND I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT
ONE OF THE BIG THINGS IS WE ARE
OVERLY TAXED.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST COST OF
LIVING INSIDE OF THE UNITED
STATES AND WE HAVE TO REALLY
ADDRESS THIS I'M WITH YOU IN
FULL SUPPORT THAT WE NEED TO
TREAT THESE PEOPLE NOT AS RATS
IN THE STREETS THESE ARE HUMAN
BEINGS.
SO WHAT I'M ASKING IS SIMPLY
THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO MOVING FORWARD THAT.
SENATOR PHIL I'M SORRY
REPRESENTATIVE FLETCHER AT MY TO
COMMENT ALSO THAT THIS WAS --
HUMANITY ISSUE AND I AGREE WITH
THAT STATEMENT FOR FOR A FULL
FULL HEARTEDLY THIS IS A
HUMANITY ISSUE.
THAT REQUIRES A HUMANE APPROACH
DOES NOT REQUIRE
AUTHORITARIANISM NOW I WOULD
ALSO JUST US THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH THESE LEGISLATIVE BILLS
THAT AFFECTS SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
YOU MENTIONED CENTER ARE
REPRESENTED GLORIA THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO HEAR THE
VOICE OF THE PEOPLE I WOULD ASK
THAT WE ALSO INTRODUCE
LEGISLATION THAT GIVES US MORE
THAN THREE MINUTES TO SPEAK ON
SUCH MATTERS THAT AFFECTS SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS EVERY SINGLE
DAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
BEFORE WE GO AHEAD IT IS THE
CUSTOM OF THIS HOUSE THAT WE DO
NOT ALLOW REPLIES OR
DEMONSTRATIONS OF OF ANYTHING.
UNLESS YOU WANT TO WEIGH YOUR
FINGERS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BUT PLEASE NO APPLAUSE NO
JEERING NO CAT CALLS NOTHING
PLEASE THAT'S THE CUSTOM OF OUR
HOUSE AND WE ASK THAT YOU
RESPECT THAT WHEN YOU'RE IN OUR
HOUSE.
WILL OUT HERE A SECOND WITNESS
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU AMEND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WITHIN THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF ADDRESS ADVOCACY I'M I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DORIES OFFICE
FOR BEING OPEN TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE REQUESTED I DID SEND
ALL OF THOSE TO EACH OF YOUR
OFFICES AS WELL.
MY WE AGREE WITH THE INTENTION
OF THIS BILL WHICH IS TO A LOT
PUBLIC OF COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
AND ENSURE THAT IT'S DRESSED
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY IS
CURRENTLY WORDED --
THIS BILL IS OVERLY BROAD AND
COULD RESULT IN THE ABUSE OF
POWER.
I GIVES YOU NATURAL BLANKET
AUTHORITY TO THE HEALTH OFFICER
TISSUE QUOTE UNQUOTE DIRECTIVES
TO OTHER GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
WITHIN THAT JURISDICTION TO TAKE
ANY ACTION.
THE HEALTH OFFICER DEEMS
NECESSARY IT'S THAT WOULD ANY
THAT WE HAVE A ISSUE.
WITH -- IT
ALSO IN THE AMENDMENTS MAKE IT
EVEN MORE BROAD THAT SAY THAT
DURING AN OUTBREAK OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OR UPON
IMMINENT AND PROXIMATE THREAT OF
A COMMUNICABLE DISEASE --
THE THE BACK ACTION SHOULD BE
TAKEN.
ON AN OUTBREAK IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACCORDING TO THE CDC IS THREE
PEOPLE AN EPIDEMIC IS SEVEN
PEOPLE SO LET'S JUST BE CLEAR
WHEN WE SAY OUTBREAK IT'S NOT
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT FOR THREE PEOPLE --
YOUR AS LEGISLATORS TOSSED WITH
MAKING LAWS THAT A NARROWLY
TAILORED AND SPECIFIC THIS BILL
IS NOT.
BOTH FROM THE ACTION OF THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICE CAN DIMOND
AND ALSO FROM A FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY SO THIS ALLOWS A
HEALTH OFFICER TO TAKE ANY
ACTION REGARDLESS OF COST --
YOU BROUGHT THIS BILL FORWARD IN
RESPONSE TO THE HEPATITIS A
OUTBREAK IN SAN DIEGO HOWEVER
THE AUDIT REPORT MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT THIS ISSUE IS NOT WHAT
ACTION WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENED BUT
HOW QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY THAT
ACTION WAS TAKEN.
THIS BILL DOESN'T FULLY ADDRESS
THAT AND INSTEAD GIVES THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER JUST MORE POLICE
POWERS.
WHILE WE MAY BELIEVE THAT
TODAY'S HEALTH OFFICES WOULD DO
THE RIGHT THING WE'VE ALL LIVED
IN A TIME WHERE WE DON'T AGREE
WITH THE FED OFFICIALS IN POWER.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG HIS
BRECHER OF MEDICAL ABUSE ON ITS
PEOPLE SO WHAT COULD THIS BILL
LEAD TO THE SEPARATION OF
CHILDREN AND PARENTS IF THEY
REFUSE MEDICAL TREATMENT
QUARANTINE OF EVERY MEMBER IN A
SUDDEN ZIP CODE.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF IF AN
OFFICIAL WHO DECIDED THAT THE
NAME OF COMMON GOOD IN
PROTECTING OTHERS THAT THEY
COULD MARRY METAPHORICALLY
INVADE OUR BEDROOMS AND MANDATE
THAT EVERYONE HAD PROTECTED SEX
SO IT'S NICE TO DE EPIDEMIC
DOESN'T SPREAD?
THE LEGISLATURE IS TOSSED IT
DRAWING LINES THIS BILL DOES NOT
DRAW A LINE TO GIVE A SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE IN THE UNITED KINGDOM
WHERE I GREW UP THERE WAS A
SWINE FLU OUTBREAK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE ON THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THAT WE
HAVEN'T SO THE SOLUTION WAS TO
SIMPLY.
VACCINATE SIX MILLION PEOPLE RAM
UNPRECEDENTED FOR IT SCOTT SCALE
AND ITS SIZE IT TURNS OUT BUT
ONE IN EVERY FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO WERE GIVEN THAT
VACCINE.
IT CAUSED AN IMMUNE SYSTEM TO
ATTACK THE WHOLE CLASSED AS A
VENUE RUNS IN THEIR BRAIN.
PEOPLE GENETICALLY PREDISPOSED
THE VACCINE ACTUALLY TRIGGERS
THEIR OWN BODIES TO GIVE THEIR
BRAINS A PARTIAL LOBOTOMY.
NOW THE BEST SCIENTIST IN THE U.
K. STUDIED THIS FOR SIX YEARS
AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT AGAIN
OFFICIALLY ACKNOWLEDGE PUBLICLY.
BUT IT WAS TRUE AND THAT THEY
EXPECT TO BE PAYING HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT SUMS NOT SUFFICIENT TO
COMPENSATE WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
PEOPLE THAT HAD THAT EFFECT.
THIS BILL MAY BE MORE
RESTRICTIVE STE THIS BILL HAS TO
BE MORE RESTRICTIVE SO THAT LESS
INTRUSIVE BUT EFFECTIVE AND
QUICKLY ACTIONABLE POLICIES A
TAKEN.
BEFORE THE MOST RESTRICTIVE
INVASIVE --
OUT ONES ARE --
AND THAT IT DOESN'T INFRINGE ON
A PERSON'S FUNDAMENTAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS WHEN
DEALING WITH SOMEONE AS
SOMETHING AS PRECIOUS OCCUR AS
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT IT REQUIRES
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE MINDFUL.
OF AN EQUAL ANCIENT CONCEPT OF
HUBRIS THANK YOU.
I HAVE ONE MORE PART OF WE ALSO
BELIEVE WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AN
AMENDMENT THAT.
ENSURE IS THAT AFTER A PUBLIC
HEALTH WHICH TO THE ORDER THAT
WAS DONE SAID THAT.
THE PLAN FOR RESPONSE --
SHOULD BE AMENDED IN THE FUTURE
I'M I WOULD CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE WITH HIS OFFICE I'M
STAND THIS BILL WILL BE VOTED
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE BUT WE
ALSO THAT YOU'RE REQUIRE THE
WHAT ANY BE STEPS.
TO TEN SUBSTITUTED FOR SOMETHING
MORE NARROWLY TAILORED PRIOR TO
PASSING IT OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
AND THAT THE HEALTH OFFICER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR POST OUTBREAK
ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU UP.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
YOUR YOU ARE ALLOWED --
YOU'RE JUST ALLOWED TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND POSITION THERE'S
NO FURTHER TESTIMONY
[inaudible]
THANK.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. TO JUST YOUR NAME.
YOUR NAME IN YOUR POSITION IF
YOU REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION
THE TITLE OF THE ORGANIZATION SO.
NO DON'T TESTIMONY OTHER THAN
THAT [inaudible]
NOW.
HI -- MY
NAME'S DR PAUL CAN GUESS AND I
AM OPPOSED TO THE LEGISLATION --
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE CAREFULLY USE
YOUR NAME FROM AND YOUR AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE FORD WITH THE VACCINE
INJURY AWARENESS LEAGUE BASED IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA AND WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
KARNATAKA STEEL MOTHER OF SEVEN
FOR VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN --
PLASTER COUNTY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JESSICA VAN HILL
HEART IN HERE FROM MODESTO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WHITNEY MELLOW FROM LINKING
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GINA SALMON FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I POSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
TERRACE MUNOZ SMITH FROM FREMONT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THINKING.
MY NAME IS SANDY OLSEN I'M FROM
TURLOCK CALIFORNIA I'M AN
EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CASE TAYLOR MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG
FROM PLACERVILLE CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL STRONGLY
THANK YOU.
RACHEL SIZE INJURE FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
STRONGLY.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE I AM DAWN
I'M FROM SAN JOSE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RACHEL WILLIAMS I'M
FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RON KENNEDY PHYSICIANS ARE ROSA
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THIS BILL IN
ITS PRESENT FORM.
LARA NOR SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
I'M JONATHAN NORRIS --
NAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND CECILIA DEVIN FROM NEWCASTLE
CALIFORNIAN AYE POSES VIA THANK
YOU.
SORRY HEART MODESTO CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL STRONG.
MILEY CYRUS GO FAR FROM OF THIS
THOUGH AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
TRAVIS MENDOZA FROM HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TWENTY
PELLEGRINI FOR RUN APART
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS HERE AT AB A TWELVE
YEAR OLD STUDENT AND MY BODY MY
RIGHT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KENDALL FONG I'M FROM
THE ROSE VAL I OPPOSE THIS BILL
I HAVE MEDICAL.
FROM THE BEGINNING MY SON WAS
INJURED AND HE'S DEALING WITH
DOCTORS SO I TOTALLY OPPOSE
SYSTEM.
I'M SENTE RISER DEVIN'S FROM
WILLITS CALIFORNIA.
I A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
FIRST DO NO HARM.
MY NAME IS NOT ON MADISON I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BUILT.
MY NAME IS HANNAH SMITH I'M A
PEDIATRIC NURSE FROM LOS GATOS
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THE
INCREDIBLY VAGUE STIPULATIONS OF
THIS BILL.
STEPHEN REFRAINING FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THIS BILL.
POPPY DARBY FROM SONORA
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ALTHOUGH CRAFT CHECK MOTHER OF
ONE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARINA CISCO --
FROM SISTERS CITRUS HEIGHTS AND
I POSSIBLE.
MY NAME IS DEAR GERMICIDAL I'M
FROM AUBURN CALIFORNIA MY
DAUGHTER AND I BOTH HAVE THE
GENETIC COMPONENTS MENTIONED AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CLEAN ALLEN AND I'M FROM
CINEMA I HAVE ONE VACCINE
INJURED KID AND I HAVE ONE
THAT'S NEVER BEEN VACCINATED.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JASON ALLEN FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER LOLLY FROM MENDOCINO
COUNTY I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MERRIAM ON FAR SOME
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S COURTNEY THE YOUNGEST
IN CITRUS HEIGHTS TWIN BOYS
VACCINE DAMAGE AND I SEVERELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL SO VALVE FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
THREE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
JOHN MAGINNIS FROM POTTER VALLEY
CALIFORNIA I PPOSE THIS BILL IN
ITS CURRENT FORM THANK YOU.
HEATHER FERRIS --
GONNA BE CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER MOTHER OF FOUR
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE WAY TO CATCH A MOTHER OF
FIVE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA.
MY KNEES YOU NEVER LAW COME FROM
CAL PARK CALIFORNIA MOTHER FIVE
IN IT ONE IS SEVERELY INJURED.
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSES.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMANDA BELKNAP I'M
FROM RIO AND THE CALIFORNIA I
HAVE A VACCINE INJURED SIGN.
AND I A SEVERELY I DO OPPOSE
THIS FAIL THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JOY JOHNSON MOTHERED TWO
MILITARY SPOUSE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS GINA GROOM I'M
FROM A HOTEL I'M A MOTHER FOR IN
A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MONIQUE PAN OUT SHE MOTHER OF
FOUR CNA IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
RACHEL PICARDO SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
CLOUT ECHO CAN OUR MIDWIFE BACK
AVAIL STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
GABRIEL BIRD AT PETALUMA
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ZACHARY BIRD FROM PETALUMA
CALIFORNIA HAD I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S KATHLEEN CLIFFORD I
HAVE SIX CHILDREN I LIVE IN
AUBURN CALIFORNIA --
DISTRICT SIX AND I HAVE A MY
OLDEST IS.
VACCINE INJURED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S KATIE HAD TO AND I'M
IN DISTRICT ONE OF APPLEGATE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THERE A HOSKING I'M
FROM PLACERVILLE CALIFORNIA I
HAVE TWO CHILDREN ONE IS VACCINE
INJURED AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING.
HI I'M JENNIFER GILBRETH I HAVE
THREE LITTLE GIRLS IN MY MIDDLE
CHILD IS VACCINATED INJURY.
MY NAME IS NAOMI HARRISON I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMY WILDE I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIM BURNER I'M
AN EDUCATOR AND A MOTHER OF A
VACCINE INJURED CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM SEVERE PELLEGRINI FROM
RUNNER PARK.
IN A OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AMANDA CARRILLO
I'M FROM FRANK BIGELOW THOSE
DISTRICT FOR I OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE A CONSENSUS AND ALSO
VERY VAGUE IT DOESN'T SAY WHAT
YOU [inaudible]
MY NAME.
MY NAME IS SCARLET LANE.
I LIVE IN DISTRICT SEVEN I KNOW.
MY NAME'S QUINCY A PENGUIN AND I
LIVE IN DISTRICT SEVEN I HAVE
THREE CHILDREN AND I VOTE NO FOR
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GREG GLAZER ON A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER AND HEALTH
CARE LAWYER THIS BILL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
MY NAME'S MARIE CEELO NAME LIVE
IN ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA FIVE
KIDDOS MYSELF AND WORK AND
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULIE I'M AGAIN S. I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ADRIANA MOSES I'M A
MOTHER OF FIVE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA WAS GONE
FOR MONTEREY COUNTY I HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI THIS IS STEPHANIE PER
HOMEOWNER FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I HAVE THREE KIDS NIGHT
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN YOUNG I'M
FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CASEY ONE SHOT FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NICOLE COLLINS FROM
SACRAMENTO I WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES AND
THE MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TERRY ROBINSON FROM
CITRUS HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA
CHEMICALLY SENSITIVE BEING AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S JULIA CAN'T TELL FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA FATHER THIS
BEAUTIFUL GIRL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I AM JUST A CANTALOUPE FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S LISA JENKINS I FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I WITH
PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MEGAN FROM
SEVASTOPOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES THOUGH I AM PREGNANT
WITH MY SECOND CHILD AND I URGE
YOU TO REALLY LOOK INTO THAT
THIS DECISION YOU GUYS ARE GOING
TO MAKE THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MANY MILLER I'M ALSO
FROM CINEMA COUNTY AND I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS CARISSA CO
AND I'M FROM CORONA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DELIVER TEEN I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SKYLER MOSER AND I'M
FROM WOODLAND CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TELEGRAPH I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JENNA BACKER IT FROM
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE HOW OTHER
STUDENTS TAX DATE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SAMANTHA SAROYAN MOTHER FOR AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
HELLO [inaudible]
MY LONDON SAROYAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M FROM
VALLEJO AND A VACCINE GENDER
INJURED ME.
JUSTIN THEROUX ENVELOPE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS CANYON ONE S. I AM
FROM AMERICAN CANYON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CAMMIE ONE IS FROM AMERICAN
CANYON A MOTHER OF A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL --
ERIC ONENESS EDUCATOR FROM
AMERICAN CANYON STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SOPHIA GOLLY ARDEN
AND FROM WITH THE IN CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
MY AND NICHOLS FROM CINEMA
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
BUT IF THEY'RE MOTORMAN ARTIST
FROM RUN APART CALIFORNIA I'VE
THREE HEALTHY CHILDREN WANTED TO
STAY THAT WAY I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
CHRIS CANTON CITY OF ROSEVILLE
THIRTY YEARS FIRE SERVICE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM PLEASE
MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH MORALIS MOTHER OF FOUR
THREE VACCINE INJURED.
FROM LINK IN CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HERALD TANGLING IN FROM ELK
GROVE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
WOULD YOU PRICE FROM SAN JOSE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. TO ANYONE ELSE.
CASEY KNOWN BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YEAH I MISSED THE FIRST PART OF
OF THE TESTIMONY.
AND JUST HEARING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT --
AND I'M A LITTLE BIT.
CONFUSED ABOUT BECAUSE AS I'M
READING THE BILL TAX THE
LANGUAGE HERE --
I'M NOT SURE THAT I THAT I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS AN ANTI VAX
TYPE OF A OF A BILL AND SOME I'M
WONDERING.
IF YOU CAN PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
OF OF OF CLARIFICATION AND
WHAT'S THE AND IN THE IN THE
REAL INTENT OF OF THE BILL I
JUST READING THIS SOME I DON'T
KNOW.
THE COMMENTS THAT I HEARD I
DON'T SEE THAT ANY ANYWHERE HERE --
BUT WHERE YOU ARE A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO OR I WAS WHERE YOU ARE NOW A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO --
THE ORIGIN OF THIS BILLS THE
STATE AUDIT IN RESPONSE THE
APPETITE IS A CRISIS IT WAS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY THIS BUDGET TO
BE AT A COUNTIES.
AND KILLED OVER.
OVER TWENTY PEOPLE IN OUR STATE --
ATION HAVE TO DO --
WITH THE FIRST PORTION OF THIS
TWO PART BILL WHICH IS PROVIDING
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS AND
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE ORDERS TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS RESPONSE TO
A COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OUTBREAK.
HOW THAT WORKED IN SAN DIEGO WAS
THAT THERE WAS A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER WHO WANT CERTAIN STEPS
TAKEN TO CONTAIN THE SPREAD OF
THE?
DISEASE --
THAT WAS GENERALLY POWER WASHING
OF SIDEWALKS HAND WASHING
STATIONS.
SANITARY CONDITIONS AS WELL AS
VACCINATIONS AND THAT DELAY --
THAT IT ABILITY TO PROVIDE THAT
DIRECTION RESULTED IN --
THE NOTICING OF THE HEPATITIS
OUTBREAK STARTED IN FEBRUARY OR
MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUT NO
DECLARATION OR FROM HAVE ACTIONS
BEING TAKEN TO AUGUST OR
SEPTEMBER.
OF THAT SAME YEAR IN THAT LINK
THE TIME HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
BECAME SICK AND MANY DIED AND SO --
THE THE BECAUSE OF THAT
VAGUENESS THAT THE AUDITOR
DISCOVERED IN TERMS OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS SAN DIEGO
FEELING AS THOUGH SHE DID NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SAY TO THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO THIS ACCOUNT
EMPLOY.
TALKING TO THE CITY TO SAY YOU
MAY DO THIS ARE YOU MUST DO THIS --
RESULTED IN A SLOW RESPONSE THAT
WE THINK SEAN FACTIONS SO --
WITH REGARD TO THE SPECIFIC
ISSUE OF VACCINATIONS BECAUSE
THIS OF COURSE IS ALWAYS A
HIGHLY CHARGED ISSUE.
I WANT TO JUST BE VERY CLEAR
THERE'S NOTHING IN EIGHTY TWO
SIXTY TWO THE PROVIDES FOR THE
AUTHORITY FOR COMPULSORY
VACCINATION.
IN FACT RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
EXPRESS AT THE FORTY FOUR
COMPULSORY VACCINATIONS ABSENT A
COURT ORDER OR DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY.
CALIFORNIA HAS EVEN GONE SO FAR
MR MAYES AS NOT ADOPTING THE
MODEL STATE HEALTH EMERGENCY
POWERS ACT THE WAY THAT MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE WHICH
AUTHORIZES COMPULSORY
VACCINATION DURING STATES A
PUBLIC EMERGENCY WHICH IS NOW
SETTLED LAW.
CALIFORNIA HAS SAID THAT THE
CONSTITUTION IS CLEAR TO
PROJECTS PROTECTION AFFORD CIVIL
LIBERTIES TO ALL OF ITS
RESIDENTS THIS BILL NO WAY
CHANGES THAT TO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO ALLOW
THE GOVERNMENT TO FORCE
VACCINATIONS NO SIR.
THANK YOU.
EXCUSE ME A NOTE PLEASE PLEASE.
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR ME.
MEMBERS NOT ACTUALLY A NOT
UNLESS THE MEMBER ASKS DIRECTLY
SO.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER TESTIMONY AND
QUESTIONS FROM.
LAST.
ASK FOR EXTRA SKEWS ME --
THE TESTIMONIES OVER THIS A
QUESTIONS BETWEEN THE MEMBERS.
AND THEN WE WILL AND WE WILL
TAKE A VOTE SO THANK YOU THAT'S
A WHERE PROCESS WORKS HERE.
MR FLOOR.
THAT SINCE I DID COME IN LATE I
WOULD ACTUALLY WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT IF YOU
EVERYTHING THAT PLEASE.
THANK YOU IT WAS PART OF MIND OR
INTENT PART OF MY TESTIMONY SO
OUR CONCERN IS THE WORD ANY --
THE ACTION IT'S IT STATES THE
LOCAL HEALTH AUTHORITY CAN OR
THE OFFICER CAN TAKE ANY ACTION --
WHILE CALIFORNIA IT IS CORRECT
DOESN'T --
VACCINATIONS COULD BE MANDATED
SO DURING AN OUTBREAK OR FORCED
SO TO SPEAK --
AND SO OUR CONCERN IS OUR OUR
REQUEST IS TO HAVE THE THE
WEDDING CHANGED SO IT'S MORE
NARROWLY TAILORED SAID FOR
EXAMPLE THAT IT IS.
THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND LEAST
INVASIVE ACTION --
AND SO WHILE VACCINATION ISN'T.
YOU KNOW FOR THINGS LIKE
HEPATITIS A THE MEASLES OUTBREAK
ACROSS THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW IS
FORCING YOU KNOW MEASLES
VACCINATIONS OR OR PUTTING THAT.
OUT THERE --
AND SO I THINK THAT'S THE
CONCERN OF MANY OF THESE --
CONSTITUENTS THAT HAVE COME
TODAY -- IS
THAT IT IT IS A POSSIBILITY THIS
BILL DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY SAY
THAT VACCINATIONS WOULD HAPPEN
BUT FOR ANYTHING THAT IS.
BACK SCENE HAS A VACCINE FOR IT
IS LIKELY THAT THAT VACCINE
WOULD BE PUSHED.
AND THAT'S THE CONCERN.
SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO
THAT.
SHORT I..
I THINK I THINK THAT THIS IS A
POINT OF OF OF AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN THE PARTS OF THIS BILL
MYSELF --
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
PRESCRIBE COMPULSORY BACK.
IN THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION --
THAT THE BILL SPEAKS --
TO IN TERMS OF THE AUTHORITY
THAT'S GIVEN I MEAN WE'RE WITH
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
AND WE'RE HAVING ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE IN SOME CASES THIS IS TAYLOR --
OUTBREAKS LIKE LIGHTS WOULD NOT
REQUIRE THIS KIND OF
INTERVENTION RIGHT --
BUT IN TERMS OF THE THE THE MOST
SUITED INTERVENTIONS --
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOT
CONTINUE TO TO VACCINATIONS BUT
VERY MUCH WHAT THE OPPONENTS ARE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER TO TELL
THE CITY AS THEY DID TO MINE --
THAT YOU NEED TO START PUTTING --
PORTA POTTIES --
IN IN HIGHLY CONCENTRATED
HOMELESS IS THERE XIN THAT WE
WERE SEEN AND ACTUALLY SPREAD
THIS DISEASE THAT'S WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TENS OF ANY TERMS
OF PROVIDING THAT ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY AND TAILORING AND I
THINK RISKS THE ABILITY OF BEING
SO PRESCRIPTIVE THE POINT THE
BILL DOES IT MAKE.
DOES NOT ALLOW THE KINDS
INTERVENTIONS WERE TALKING OUT
WE'RE TALKING A HEPATITIS IN
THIS CASE IT COULD BE ANOTHER
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE --
AND SO THIS PROVIDES THE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE INVOLVED --
THE LATITUDE THAT THEY NEED TO
BE EFFECTIVE --
A SPEAKING WITH THE
PROFESSIONALS WHO DO THIS WORK
NONE OF THEM ARE INTERESTED IN
REACHING THE CONSTITUTION OR IN
DOING.
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
BEYOND THEIR SCOPE IF ANYTHING
THAT EXPRESSED TO MEDIA STREAM
RETICENCE ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
BUT ALL OF THEM AGREE THAT NO
WHERE IN THIS BILL DOES IT
CONTAIN COMPULSORY VACCINATION
REQUIREMENTS.
MOVE THE BILL.
BUSH'S SECOND ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE MOTION SECOND MISTER GLORY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST FOR
THE RECORD MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME OF YOUR COMMITTEE AND FOR
YOUR MEMBERS I LIKE TO GIVE
THANKS TO THE HELP OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH OF THESE GROUPS
HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING MYSELF AND MY STAFF A TO
GET FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET INTO A
CONDITION.
THAT THE MEMBERS INVOLVED VERY
TO PROFESSIONALS WERE TALKING
ABOUT CAN ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT
THIS LEGISLATION I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE DIALOGUE WITH
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AS OTHERS AS
THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IBM.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONCERN FOR THE HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS --
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THEM THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH THAT AS A LAST MINUTE SO IF
YOU DID YOU HAVE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
WHAT I'D WHAT I'D MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY?
ANGER CURRY I BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA NOT LOADING
FLOOR NOT LOADING [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS I TO TO AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING.
WE HAVE SIX VOTES WE NEED TWENTY
TWO MORE WE STILL HAVE A A
NUMBER MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT HERE
AT THE DIED SO --
FOR LEAVE THE OF WILL COME BACK
WE HAVE OUR MEMBERS.
BIGGEST CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THAT WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
BILL.
ITEM SIX THIS WAS RUBIO HERE.
THIS.
IS ON THE COMMITTEE SO.
WELL WAIT WILL WAIT A MOMENT IN
CASE PEOPLE ARE PLANNING TO
LEAVE SO.
WITH THIS LIST GO AHEAD PER
SECOND WAIT FOR A MINUTE
.
TOOK A TURN.
SWEET JESUS OR
DO YOU ARE YOU
YOU HAVE YOUR WITNESSES RIO.
IF YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THANK YOU
MISTER CHURCH MEMBERS OF FOR SO
FAR WILL THE THINK THE THE YOUR
COMEY HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL.
AND I WILL HAPPILY OF SAP TO YOU
COMMITMENT AMENDMENT. TO DEFINE
THE TYPES OF MANAGED CARE PLAN
THAT THIS BILL APPLIES.
TO AB THREE EIGHTEEN INSURED
READABILITY.
ACCURACY AND CULTURAL
APPROPRIATENESS OF MEDICARE
DOCUMENTS SO THEIR MEDICARE
RECEIVE HIM HAVE A FEAR **** TO
THEIR BENEFIT.
AT LEAST ONE IN THREE MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT
A NATIVE.
ENGLISH SPEAKER AS AN IMMIGRANT
MYSELF I UNDERSTAND THE LANGUAGE.
AREAS THAT EXISTS FOR MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
THERE IS --
THE TRANSLATED MATERIAL DE MEDIC
ARE OFTEN WRITTEN AT TOO HIGH OF
A LEVEL --
BUT READABILITY.
AND AND USE CONFUSION WORDS
CHOICES AND THERE ARE NOT
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE TO THE AT
AT AND THIS IS TO USE AND DRUG
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE MEDICARE.
POPULATION AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL.
IS ESTABLISH A GOOD READABILITY
WORKSHOPS.
AND DESIGNATE A READABILITY
AXFORD TO REVIEW AND REVISE AT
LEAST TEN KEY YOU MEDI CAL
DOCUMENT. FIVE ALL THOSE
DOCUMENTS ARE EXPLICITLY SPECIFY
IN THIS BILL IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT
DOCUMENTS ARE INCLUDED.
ENSURING THAT THE TRANSLATED
DOCUMENTS ARE WRITTEN IN PLAIN
SIMPLE AND CULTURALLY.
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE IS
IMPERATIVE TO IMPROVING HEALTH
**** TO ALL MEDICARE.
MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS THANK YOU --
TODAY WAS ME --
TESTIFYING SUPPORT A JAM FLORI
WAS THE WESTERN CENTER OF LAW
IMPROPER D..
M. MARCUS OF THIS COUNTRY JOHN.
IT WAS THE A CALIFORNIA I'M.
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN FOR ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY --
I HAD BROUGHT SOME EXAMPLE
TRANSLATIONS WITH ME TO SHOW YOU
BUT I'VE BEEN TOLD WERE NOT
SUPPOSED TO PASS THINGS OUT SO
YOU HAVE TO BEAR WITH ME AND
I'LL WALK YOU THROUGH --
WESTERN CENTER NO LEGAL SERVICES
PARTNERS HAVE COME ACROSS MANY
EXAMPLES OF TRANSLATED MATERIALS
THAT JUST AREN'T ACCESSIBLE FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE IS
SOME TRANSLATED MATERIAL SO
WE'VE CERTAIN TERMS IN ENGLISH
USUALLY PROPER NOUNS OFTEN
ACRONYMS --
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE SOMEBODY WILL
BE READING SOMETHING AND IT WILL
SAY A WHOLE BUNCH OF WORDS IN
THEIR LANGUAGE AND THEN ALL THE
SENATE SWITCHES TO ENGLISH AND
THEN IT GOES BACK TO THEIR
LANGUAGE --
WHEN I WAS AT A GROUP?
REPRESENTING CLIENTS DIRECTLY I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS MEANS --
MANY OF OUR LOCAL LEGAL SERVICES
ACTUALLY HELP PEOPLE OVER THE
PHONE SO THEN IT'S A BIGGER
PROBLEM BECAUSE THE CLIENT IS
SAYING I HAVE THIS NOTICE I
DON'T WANT TO KNOW WHAT IT MEANS
AND I CAN'T READ IT TO YOU
BECAUSE IT'S IN.
YOU KNOW PARTIALLY THEIR
LANGUAGE AND PARTIALLY ENGLISH --
MOST OF THIS COMES FROM JUST
CONVICTIONS OF DECIDING THAT
PROPER NOUNS DON'T NEED TO BE
TRANSLATED OR THE ACRONYM SHOULD
BE USED --
LOOKING IN THIS FURTHER WE
REALIZED THAT THE PROBLEM IS
OFTEN THE BASE ENGLISH DOCUMENT
THAT THE ENGLISH DOCUMENTS ARE
UNDERSTANDABLE BY OUR CLIENTS
EITHER -- SO
AB THREE ONE EIGHT WOULD DEAL
WITH BOTH FIELD TESTING
TRANSLATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND
THEM AS WELL AS MAKE HE MEDI CAL
DOCUMENTS MORE UNDERSTANDABLE TO
BEGIN WITH.
SOME OF THE OTHER PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEN WITH
TRANSLATIONS THAT WOULD BE HELP
I FEEL TESTING IS SOME
TRANSLATED MATERIALS ARE WRITTEN
IN THE DIALECT OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S NOT SPOKEN BY THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS --
SOME CONSUMERS ARE REPORTING
RECEIVING MATERIALS THAT ARE TOO
FORMAL THEY STILL HAVE TECHNICAL
TERMS IN THEM THAT CONSUMERS
DON'T UNDERSTAND --
JUST AS READERS OF ENGLISH DON'T
UNDERSTAND MATERIALS WRITTEN IN
LEGALESE ARE LOTS OF TECHNICAL
HEALTH INDUSTRY.
LANGUAGE NEITHER DO READERS OF
OTHER LANGUAGES TOO OFTEN MEDI
CAL DOCUMENTS SEEK TO TEACH THE
CONSUMERS ABOUT NEW TERMS THAT
THEY SHOULD KNOW RATHER THAN
USING PLAIN ENGLISH THAT THEY
ALREADY KNOW. FOR EXAMPLE IF A
CONSUMER WANTS TO KNOW ABOUT
GETTING A RIDE TO THE DOCTOR
THEY NEED TO LEARN ABOUT AND M.
T. AND ANY M. T. WHY CAN'T WE
JUST TALK ABOUT A RIDE TO THE
DOCTOR OR RIGHT TO THE DOCTOR IF
YOU NEED SPECIAL ACCOMMODATIONS.
AND IN SOME TRANSLATIONS ARE TOO
LITERAL BUT NOT UNDERSTANDABLE
FOR EXAMPLE ONE TO HEALTH PLANS
LANGUAGE ACCESS SHE GIVES A
PHONE NUMBER TO CALL IN EACH
LANGUAGE AND IT TELLS THE
ENROLLEE SAID THEY SPEAK
TRADITIONAL CHINESE.
THEY CAN GET LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE
I WILL TRANSFER LANGUAGE AS
THESE.
SOME OF THESE TRANSLATION PROMPT --
PROBLEMS STEM FROM THE FACT THAT
THE ORIGINAL DOCUMENT AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE IT'S TOO HARD
TO UNDERSTAND EVEN IN ENGLISH SO
WHEN WE WENT BACK AND LOOKED AT
THIS BILL WE THOUGHT A GREAT
THING TO DO WOULD BE TO GET THE
KEY MEDI CAL DOCUMENTS.
TAKE THEM TO AN OUTSIDE
READABILITY EXPERT AND ACTUALLY
HAVE THEM PUT INTO PLAIN ENGLISH
WHERE WE'RE NOT USING JARGON AND
THINGS THAT PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
AND WITH THAT I'D JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'M GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE.
MARKETS CUSTER.
WELL MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARKETS GOT
THROWN THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK --
ALSO A PRODUCT --
SPONSOR OF AB --
THREE ONE EIGHT A C. PEN IS A
STATE WIDE MULTICULTURAL HEALTH
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT SEEKS
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AND ELIMINATE HEALTH DISPARITIES --
BY ADVOCATING FOR PUBLIC
POLICIES AND RESOURCES --
TO ADDRESS HEALTH NEEDS OF
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR --
ONE AREA FOCUS RECEIVE TEN HAS
BEEN LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
RECENTLY OUR COMMUNITY --
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN VOICING FRESH
ALL DOCUMENTS AS IT IS.
WE RECENTLY SPOKE WITH A
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER --
AND DAY DETAILED THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH THE MEDICAL
PROGRESS PROGRAM.
THEY WERE OF REPRESENTATIVE OF A
HEALTH CLINIC IN OAKLAND AND
THEY HAVE A CONSUMER BASE OF
WHERE 90% OF THEIR PATIENTS.
ARE LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
THEY EXPLAIN THAT THEIR
ELIGIBILITY STUFF.
DO THEIR BEST TO WALK NEW
PATIENTS THROUGH.
THE PROCESS OF ENROLLMENT IN THE
SCOPE OF BENEFITS THAT THEY ARE
ENTITLED.
TO BUT SMALLER CLINICS DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SPEND THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES TO FULLY
EXPLAIN --
THE NUANCES OF MEDI CAL --
SO THE OTHER OPTION THESE
CLINICS HAVE IS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION MATERIAL TO THE
BENEFICIARIES.
HOWEVER BECAUSE THOSE TRANSLATE
DOCUMENTS --
THAT ARE AVAILABLE ARE NOT THAT
ADEQUATE THOSE TO UNDERSTAND
COMPLETELY THE SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM --
THE REPRESENT ALSO NOTED THAT
WHILE LANGUAGE ACCESS IT YOU'RE
VERY FOR MANY OF THEIR PATIENTS --
IT.
PEOPLE THAT SPEAK ENGLISH AS A
PRIMARY LANGUAGE ALSO HAVE
TROUBLE UNDERSTANDING THE
DOCUMENTS THEMSELVES AS THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S USED IN ON
AREN'T REALLY FRIENDLY TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE HEALTH LITERATE --
I NOTICED BECAUSE IT THIS --
RECENT REPORT FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR NOTED THAT --
MILLIONSOF CHILDREN MEDI CAL OR
NOT RECEIVING PREVENTATIVE
HEALTH SERVICES AND ONE OF THE
KEY RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT
CAME -- THAT
CAME OUT THAT REPORT WAS A D.
SHE HAS SHOULD ENSURE THAT PLANS
ARE EFFECTIVELY MITIGATING.
CHILD --
HEALTH DISPARITIES RELATED TO
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC NEEDS
AND THAT THE ISSUE HAS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION. TO PLANTS
PROVIDERS AND BENEFICIARIES
ABOUT THE SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT EXPECTS CHILDREN TO
RECEIVE.
THE REPORT NOTED THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS --
CURRENT --
INFORMATION MATERIALS --
THAT THEY SENT TO BENEFICIARIES
ARE -- WE
LOOK TO SOLVE THOSE READABILITY
ISSUES THROUGH THIS BILL AND FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE PRACTICAL
SPONSOR AND WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
AND REQUEST AN IDOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRS AT
RECORD OVER THE CALIFORNIA DOWN
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE THE
ANALYSIS NOTING.
THE POSSIBLE EXPANSION INTO THE
MEDI CAL DENTAL PROGRAM WE WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE LOOKING INTO
THAT THANK YOU THINK. TO JUST
JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
THANK YOU.
JUST CAM RANH HOW TO ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MENDOZA
WITH US HERE YOU CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEEPENED AGONIES
OVER THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
SEE NO ONE IS THE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
JENNIFER ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS REPRESENTING FORTY SIX
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT COLLECTIVELY PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE TO MORE THAN
TWENTY SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
I'M CAPS MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS --
CURRENTLY PROVIDE HEALTH PLAN
MATERIALS INTO READABILITY
FORMAT THAT MEANS THE DOCUMENTS
ARE WRITTEN OUT OF SIX AT A
WRITTEN APPLE AT OR BELOW A
SIXTH GRADE READING LEVEL.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE CONTAINED
IN ALL PLAN LETTER AND IN
CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE HEALTH
PLANS IN THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
BETWEEN THE CURRENT APL AND THEN
THE AND THE CONTRACT WITH DH CS
BOTH HEALTH EDUCATION MATERIALS
AND INFORMING MATERIALS ARE TO
BE AT OR BELOW THE SIX GRADE
READING LEVEL --
CAP HAS TAKEN AN OPPOSED HIS
CLEATS UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
STEPS FOR DOCUMENTS ALREADY
TRANSLATED BY HEALTH PLANS --
EXISTING --
ALL PLAN LETTERS ALSO INCLUDE
TRANSLATION REQUIREMENTS AT MY
MEMBERS ARE REQUIRED TO ADHERE --
TO THE BILL'S REQUIREMENT FOR
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO CONDUCT A
ONE TIME TARGETED FIELD TESTING
WITH A NATIVE SPEAKER OF HEALTH
EDUCATION AND FOR ME MATERIALS
IN ENGLISH AND IN EACH LANGUAGE
IS EXTENSIVE.
AND REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
EXPENDITURE OF TIME AND
RESOURCES FOR MATERIALS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN TRANSLATED.
OVERALL THIS BILL ADDS
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL STATE IN MANAGED CARE
PLAN RESOURCES AND OFFERS NO
ASSURANCE THAT THE COMMUNITY
REVIEWED MATERIALS WOULD BE MORE.
EFFECTIVE FOR MEDI CAL MEMBERS
AND THE MATERIALS CURRENTLY
PRODUCED.
THANK YOU I'M TELL A FRIEND
QUESTION GREAT THANK YOU --
MEMBERS KATHY MUST WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS THE SIXTEEN
NONPROFIT LOCAL HEALTH PLANS --
IN MANY OF YOUR COMMUNITIES I
WOULD SAY WE REGRETFULLY OUR
POST TODAY THIS IS SIMILAR TO
BILL WE HAD WORKED ON LAST YEAR --
WE HAVE TOLD THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND STAFF AS WELL AS THE
SPONSORS WE DO WANT TO WORK WITH
THEM ON THIS OUR ISSUE IS
REGARDING THE FIELD TESTING.
A LOT OF THE DOCUMENTS WE WOULD
HAVE TO PUT OUT TO FIELD TEST OR
DOCUMENTS WE GET FROM DH CS SO
WE WOULD HAVE A DIFFICULT WE
COULDN'T CHANGE THOSE.
SO I THINK IN ADDITION TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH GET CAP WE
DO HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THE TIME IT WOULD TAKE AND THE
EXTENSIVE NATURE IT WOULD TAKE
TO PRESS TO CHANGE THESE
DOCUMENTS BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT.
WANT TO JUST REITERATE MANY OF
THESE WE CANNOT CHANGE BECAUSE
THEY ARE DH CS DOCUMENTS WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND SECTION
THREE OF THE BILL AND HAVING THE
DEPARTMENT LOOK AT A NUMBER OF
THEIR OF THEIR MATERIALS AND
TRYING TO GET THOSE.
IN A READABLE FORM FOR FOLKS AND
WOULD SUPPORT THAT PIECE IT
REALLY IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE WOULD FIELD TEST THIS
EXTENSIVELY SO AGAIN WE REMAIN
OPPOSED BUT HOPE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR AND AND THE SPONSORS
ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SIR ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER MAYES --
MISS YOU I BUT THINK THIS --
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS RIGHT --
AND I WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF IT
BUT SEEMS LIKE MAYBE OF THE
OPPONENTS OF IT HAVE SOME GOOD
POINTS THAT SOUNDS LIKE MAYBE.
THIS IS DUPLICATING --
SOME SOME REGULATIONS WE ALREADY
HAVE IN PLACE --
AND SO IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T
NEED TO BE MORE.
IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
I DO BELIEVE THERE IS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND I LIKE --
TO ALSO IN INCLUDE MORE
DOCUMENTS TO BE TRANSLATED.
THEN I'LL BE SUPPORTIVE OF IT
TODAY KNOWING THAT IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO THEN IT HAS NOT.
SO WE WERE MOTION. TO HAVE A
SECOND.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND --
MR CHIU WHICH I CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB THREE
EIGHTEEN PROMOS FOR YEAR L.
HEALTH ACCESS TO POSITIVE HELL'S
ALL COME.
VERY BREAKING UP DOWN LANGUAGE
BERIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHIU
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD AND THANK YOU TO YOUR
WITNESSES --
THE BILL ENJOYS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
A RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND WILL HAVE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
WHAT I WHAT I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA.
FLORA NO LOW MOAN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS RAMOS I TO TO
AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
IF SEVEN VOTES WE YOUR ONE SHY
THAT -- WE
HAVE MANY MEMBERS MISSING --
SO WE'LL LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MISS RUBIO.
AB
.
THREE NINETEEN GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIR TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL --
THREE NINETEEN A BILL WHICH
EXPANDS MEDICATION TREATMENT
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO PROVIDERS --
TREATING SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE RECOMMENDED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTENING
COMMENT SIX OF THE ANALYSIS AND
BY THINKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL OF THE WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THE BILL THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO THANK YOU.
WELL THAT IS USUALLY A SIGNALED
ME CUTTING IT SHORTER AS YOU
WISH MATTER YES MA'AM.
YES MISTER CHAIR AB THREE
NINETEEN WILL HAVE TO HELP
TACKLE --
BUTTE ADDICTION WE ALL KNOW THAT
IT'S AN EPIDEMIC CURRENTLY AND
WE'RE TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE IN THIS --
BILL WILL HELP PROVIDE A
WRAPAROUND SERVICES --
ALONG WITH THE DRUG TREATMENT --
PROGRAMS HERE WITH ME IS MICHAEL
AND IS IT IS A BIPARTISAN BILL.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES MISS WALDRON WELL I'LL
JUST BE BRIEF --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
MOTION AND SECOND AND BASICALLY
THIS BILL DIRECTS DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO CREATE
THE BUNDLE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AND BILLING CODES. TO REIMBURSE
NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAM
PROVIDERS FOR SERVICES THAT ARE
SO NEEDED FOR OUR NON CONTROLLED
MATT PROGRAMS TO SUCCEED FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF
MY BOOK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER OTHER SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN
VALENCIA REPRESENTING ALL
COMMITTEES MAKER OF THE LONG
ACTING INJECTABLE THAT IS THE
TOPIC OF THE MEASURE WE
APPRECIATE STAFF WORK ON THE
MEASURE AND ASK YOUR FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
STRUCTURE MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HAULING MICHON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WITH AMENDMENTS.
AND WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING THE
AMENDMENTS WITH THE SPONSORS AND
WITH THE AUTHOR AND WE HOPE TO
HAVE IT ALL RESOLVED BY THE TIME
THE BILL GETS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS ALL OVER OCTROI
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND HERE.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
CODY BOILS AND WE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM DDICTION
PROGRAMS PROFESSIONALS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M DOCTOR EVELYN LIAM INTERNAL
MEDICINE AND A CARDIOLOGISTS AND
I'M OPPOSE.
OKAY -- WELL.
IS THERE TO HAVE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
ANYONE DISAPPEAR WHEN WISHING TO
SPEAK UP AT THE AT THE DICE AND
TO KNOW WHAT IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE SUPPOSED TO THE BILL.
SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS A MOTION AND A SECOND
QUESTIONS ANYONE.
SEEING NONE WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BOTH OF
YOU TO BOTH YOU FOR BRING SECOND
IT DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION DEEP IT'S DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WELL SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
I FLORA FLOOR I'LL MOANED.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS RAMOS I TO TO
AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
YOU HAVE NINE VOTES YOU HAVE THE
HONOR OF THE FIRST BILL BELIEVE
THE COMMITTEE THIS YEAR.
SO WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS SEGMENT YOU HAVE TO
BILLS BEFORE US.
AB.
THREE SIXTY TWO I RECOGNIZE YOUR
WITNESS [inaudible]
YOU HAVE.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS --
I AM BACK HERE ON A ON AN ISSUE
THAT WILL BE FAMILIAR TO MOST OF
YOU -- AND I
THANK YOU.
AND I FROM THE LAST BILL I JUST
WENT THROUGH WE HAVE A CLEAR
INDICATION THAT WE DON'T.
THERE'S NOT ONE A PANACEA THERE
IS NOT ONE FIX OFFER ADDICTION --
AND WE NEED TO HAVE A FULL RANGE
OF OPTIONS TO KEEP PEOPLE LIVE
LONG ENOUGH. TO GET THEM CLEAN
AND TO GET BACK ON TRACK IN
THEIR LIVES --
THIS BILL.
WILL ALLOW THIS YEAR TO SCALE
DOWN FROM SOMETHING THAT YOU
VOTED ON BEFORE.
THIS BILL WILL JUST ALLOW SAN
FRANCISCO TO OVERDOSE.
PREVENTION PROGRAM PILOT SO
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAM
AGAIN THIS IS THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO STOP PEOPLE FROM OVER
DOSING. TO GIVE THEM ACCESS TO
TREATMENT.
SO THAT THEY CAN GET THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER --
PROGRAMS UNDER THIS BY IT'S TO
CONSUME CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE IN
A CLINICAL SETTING WHERE THEY
WERE WERE THEY ARE MEDICALLY
SUPERVISED.
WE KNOW FROM OVER A HUNDRED
PROGRAMS AROUND THE WORLD THAT
THIS IS AFFECTED IN REDUCING
OVERDOSES.
IN REDUCING RATES OF HIV.
IN REDUCING H. RATES OF
HEPATITIS C. IN REDUCING RATES
OF NEEDLES BEING AND PARKS AND
PLAYGROUNDS AND SCHOOL YARDS.
I'M SURE EVERYONE OF YOU IN YOUR
DISTRICTS HAVE HAD AREAS WHERE
THE POLICE HAVE TO GO IN AND DO
SWEEPS TO CLEAR OUT WE'RE HOMES
ARE CONGREGATING AND WHERE.
PEOPLE ARE PUBLICLY USING AND
ONE OF THEBIGGEST AFTER EFFECTS
IS THE AMOUNT OF NEEDLES THAT
ARE FOUND IN PARKS AND PUBLIC
SPACES AFTERWARDS WHERE CHILDREN
HAVE ACCESS TO THEM.
AND WHERE DISEASE CONTINUES TO
SPREAD.
THIS BILL HAS A SIX YEAR SUNSET
WHICH REQUIRES ANNUAL REPORTING
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT ABOUT
THE IMPACTS.
ON THE NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE PROGRAM WHO'S USING THE
PROGRAM AND HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
GETTING REFERRED TO TREATMENT SO
WE CAN ACTUALLY.
DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS IS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET PEOPLE INTO
TREATMENT --
AS YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BASICALLY LIVING IN USING ON THE
STEEP STREETS HAVE A LOT OF
MEDICAL ISSUES THAT GO ALONG
WITH THAT OFTEN TIMES --
ISSUES AROUND INFECTIONS ISSUES
AROUND AGAIN TRANSMITTABLE
DISEASES --
SWELLING OFTENTIMES PEOPLE GET
ABSCESSES --
WHICH WHICH CAN RESULT IN LOSS
OF WE KNOW OUR NINE ONE ONE OF
FOLKS ARE OVERWHELMED WITH
RESPONDING TO PEOPLE OVERDOSING
WE KNOW OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE
OVERWHELMED WITH PEOPLE COMING
IN.
WITH THESE KINDS OF ISSUES SO
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE OF
RESEARCH INFORMED INTERVENTION
THAT WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO TRY
HERE IN IN --
THIS DID UNITED STATES BUT WE
HOPE THIS WILL BE THE FIRST ONE
A PILOT AGAIN WE DON'T WE DON'T
SAY IT'S THE ANSWER TO
EVERYTHING BUT WE SAY IT'S THE
ANSWER TO FOR SOME --
AS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN ON THIS
JOURNEY FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOW
FIRMLY BELIEVING IN HARM
REDUCTION FIRMLY BELIEVING IN
THAT EVERY LIFE MATTERS AND THAT
IS MUCH AS WE CAN EXPAND ACCESS
TO TO DIGNITY.
AS MUCH AS WE CAN EXPAND ACCESS
TO TREATMENT AS MUCH AS WE CAN
ASK OF A TO TO TO BE ABLE TO
TELL PEOPLE WE CARE ABOUT THEM
BECOMING WITH A BLACK EYE.
YOU MIGHT GET ASKED ABOUT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE YOU COMING
CLEARLY HAVING NEEDING A SHOWER
THAT MIGHT ALSO BE PROVIDED AS
SOMEBODY WHO WORKED IN SOCIAL
WORK IN A LONG TIME AND
ADDICTIONS FOR A LONG TIME.
I CAN TELL YOU THE NUMBER ONE
THING THAT I WOULD TEACH
STUDENTS AND I WOULD WORK WITH
CLIENTS ON HIS IF YOU DON'T HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP THEN IT'S REALLY
HARD TO GET ANYBODY TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT YOURSELVES
CHANGING ANY BEHAVIOR IS THE ONE
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT THINGS SO
THAT THAT EMPATHY THAT
RELATIONSHIP THAT PEOPLE CAN
ESTABLISH WHEN THEY'RE GOING
INTO A MEDICALLY SUPERVISED
SETTING --
WE THINK IS THE BEST WAY AGAIN
TO EXPRESS DIGNITY TO EXPRESSED
EVERY LIFE MATTERS AND FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO
TREATMENT --
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
SERVED ON LOCAL.
ELECTED OFFICE THIS IS THE THE
HEIGHT OF OF LOCAL CONTROL WE
ARE TELLING.
THIS THIS CITY THAT IF THEY FEEL
LIKE OUR ARE OKAY TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE AT THE
TABLE.
AND SO THE D. A. THE MAYOR THE
DEPUTY THE SHERIFF EVERYBODY
WILL HAVE TO BE AT THE TABLE --
TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE IF THIS IS
GONNA GO FORWARD OR NOT SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES THIS
YEAR --
NOTHING IN THIS BILL SAYS THAT
IT TO USE DRUGS IS OKAY BUT WE
HAVE CERTAINLY LEARNED THAT JUST
TELLING PEOPLE TO JUST SAY NOW.
HAS NOT WORKED OUR APP DIMMICK
IN TEN YEARS TO GROW AND IT
FEELS LIKE IT'S TIME FOR US TO
JUST AT LEAST TRY THIS APPROACH
AS WELL AS EVERY OTHER APPROACH
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR TOOLBOX.
WITH ME TODAY ARE --
WITNESSES DOCTOR DAVID KAHN AND
THE CAT HE SOON.
AND ALSO LARA THOMAS FROM DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE THANK YOU SO AS
OUR CUSTOM HAVE TWO WITNESSES IF
YOU WANT ALL THREE SPEAK YOU CAN.
JUST DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE'S HERE
FOR ANY KIND OF TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH DR.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND MEMBER
MY NAME'S DOCTOR DAVID KAHN AND
I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE.
SEE SAM FOR SHORT REPRESENTS
OVER FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
PHYSICIANS AND ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WE ARE THE VOICE
OF ADDICTION TREATMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALSO CO SPONSORS OF THIS
VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. ONE
OF THE THINGS I'VE LEARNED THE
PHYSICIANS THAT CHANGE TAKES
TIME.
AND IN ORDER TO MAKE CHANGE YOU
NEED TO HAVE ENGAGEMENT WITH
PEOPLE WHO CAN HELP YOU.
WE NEED TO MATCH AVAILABILITY OF
TREATMENT SERVICES WITH THE MAN.
I'VE SAID ONCE BEFORE THAT I
WORRY MUCH MORE ABOUT THE
PATIENT THAT I DON'T SEE THAN
THE ONE THAT I DO SEE.
BECAUSE THE ONE THAT I DON'T SEE
WE LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMUNICATE TO IDENTIFY GOALS
AND MAKE CHANGES IN THEIR LIVES.
AND THIS UP OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAM REPRESENTS A PART OF THE
SPECTRUM OF CARE.
AND CRITICALLY A PART OF THE
SPECTRUM OF CARE OF THE PATIENTS
THAT WE MISS THE ONES WHO ARE AT
HIGHEST RATE FOR OVERDOSED.
THE ONES WHO ARE MOST LIKELY TO
SUFFER AS A RESULT OF THEIR
ILLNESS.
I PERSONALLY VISITED THE
ENCYCLOPEDIA VANCOUVER WERE MUCH
OF THE RESEARCH IS DERIVED IN IN
THAT CLINIC I SAW A CLINIC THAT
REMINDED ME OF MY SAN FRANCISCO.
BE A METHADONE PROGRAM IT WAS A
COMMUNITY WHERE PEOPLE CARED
ABOUT IT.
AND IT WAS IN THE INTEREST OF
THE PATIENT STEP PARTICIPATED.
IN ORDER TO GET THEM TO THEIR
OPTIMAL OUR STATE IS VERY CLEAR
WITH OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS IT REDUCES OVERALL DRUG
USE DISCARDED SYRINGES HIV AND
HEPATITIS C. INFECTIONS.
OVERDOSE DEATHS AND PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OVERDOSE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS ARE MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO ENTER TREATMENT
IF SOMEBODY PARTICIPATES WITH IN
SUCH A PROGRAM.
THEY HAVE ENCOUNTER WITH A
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL WHO
CARES ABOUT THEM AS A PERSON.
WE OFFER THE IDEA OF TREATMENT
THEY'RE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
LISTEN.
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAMS IS
TREATMENT.
THERE'S NO CONFLICT BETWEEN
SUPERVISE USE AND STOPPING DRUGS
IT'S PART OF THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT HARM
REDUCTION BECAUSE WE THINK OF
ABSTINENCE AS PART OF A HARM
REDUCTION IT IS.
BUT IT HAPPENS TO BE THE HARDEST
WAY TO ACHIEVE IT WHEN YOU GET
PEOPLE ENGAGE WITH AN OVERDOSE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS YOUR
OFFERING THEM TREATMENT.
BOTH FOR THE ADDICTION ITSELF
AND THE CO MORBID MEDICAL
CONDITIONS THAT OCCUR AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN RIP
REFERENCED ABSCESSES
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
AND SO IN SUMMARY I WOULD SAY
THAT OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS DO ALL OF THE ABOVE.
IT ENGAGES PEOPLE IT GIVES THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY CHANGE AND ROUTE
AND SEAMLESSLY GETS THEM INTO
THE TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED AT
THE LEVEL THAT THE READY FOR
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
LISTEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VICTOR
EYES IN AND I AM THE S. C. E. O.
FOR HEALTH RIGHT THREE SIXTY
WE'RE ONE OF THE LARGEST --
COMMUNITY BASED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROVIDER
ORGANIZATION SERVING THE MEDICAL
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA WE
OPERATE PROGRAMS IN SOME OF YOUR
DISTRICTS --
BUT WE ARE OUR HOME BASE IS SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE BEEN VERY ACTIVE
IN IN THIS CONVERSATION.
I'M ALSO REPRESENTING I CAN'T BE
WHICH IS THE STATE ASSOCIATION
OF TRIGGER PROVIDERS BOTH HEALTH
RIGHT THREE SIXTY AND CAT PEE
ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS AND
SPONSORS.
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
I ALSO SPEAK HEROIN USER --
AND I BRING THAT TO BEAR AND ALL
OF MY THINKING ABOUT THE WORK
THAT I DO EVERY DAY AND HAVE
BEEN DOING FOR THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS.
I THINK YOU'RE WELL AWARE CAN
OPEN NEWSPAPER TODAY AND NOT
READ ABOUT THE OPIOID --
OVERDOSE CRISIS IN OUR COUNTRY
THAT CRISIS HAS NOT SKIP
CALIFORNIA --
NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE DIED
OF AN OVERDOSE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH IS WHERE WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSING THIS PILOT --
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
DIED IN THE SAME YEAR.
SO -- IN
THIS PROJECT WERE REALLY
THINKING ABOUT REACHING THE
HARDEST TO REACH PEOPLE THAT
THERE ARE TO REACH WE SERVE LOTS
OF PEOPLE IN TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
WE DO A GOOD JOB WE'RE VERY
INVESTED IN CONTINUING THAT AND
YET THERE ARE STILL A POPULATION
OF PEOPLE FOR WHOM WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO REACH AND WE SEE THIS IS
THE AVENUE.
AS DOCTOR CONCERT WE SEE THIS IS
THE AVENUE TO HELP REACH THOSE
PEOPLE I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE MYTHS.
AROUND THE OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS THAT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
ABOUT OR THAT YOU MAY EVEN
CONSIDERING YOUR OWN THINKING
ONE IS THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ENABLE DRUG USE --
THERE IS A BELIEF THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE THINGS REALLY REALLY
DIFFICULT AND WE NEED.
TO IMPOSE A CRIMINAL SANCTIONS
AND BRING A GREAT DEAL OF MISERY
TO PEOPLE SO THAT THEY STOP
USING DRUGS AND THAT'S HOW THEY
COME TO RECOVERY WHEN IN FACT
HAVING DONE THIS WORK FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME.
THAT IS ACTUALLY NOT THE PATH
FOR PEOPLE TO RECOVERY IT IS
THROUGH RELATIONSHIP AND
CONNECTION AND IT'S TO HOPE THAT
PEOPLE MOVE TO RECOVERY THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SEE.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT WE WOULD
FOCUS THIS PROJECT ON IT IS NO
MORE DESPAIR THAT WE CAN BRING
TO BEAR ON THEIR LIVES THERE'S
ONLY DEATH THAT'S REALLY THE
ONLY.
OTHER OPTION LEFT SO SO THIS
ISN'T ENABLE IT THIS JUST MAKES
US HELPS US CONTACT PEOPLE WHO
ARE THE HARDEST TO REACH.
I THINK THE SECOND MATTHEW HERE
IS THAT THESE ATTRACT THANK YOU
BUT THIS ATTRACTS CRIME --
AND THIS IS NOT BEEN PROVEN TRUE
IN ANY SITE WHERE THEY'VE
EXISTED OVER A HUNDRED OF THEM
AROUND THE WORLD AND ACTUALLY WE
ARE YOU KNOW IN HARM REDUCTION
SITES THAT OPERATE CURRENTLY AND
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT'S NOT TRUE THERE IS WELL
PEOPLE ARE DRUG DEALERS ARE NOT
ATTRACTED TO COME TO NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE DRUG
USERS ARE THAT HAS NOT BEEN
PROVEN TO BE TRUE.
IN HARM REDUCTION SITES AS WELL
IN THE FINAL MYTH IS THAT THERE
WERE WERE GIVEN A FALSE CHOICE
THAT SAYS IT'S EITHER THIS OR
TREATMENT.
AND NOT NOTHING IN THIS BILL
SAYS THAT WE DON'T SUPPORT
TREATMENT THERE'S NOTHING IN
HERE THAT SAYS WE'RE GONNA TAKE
MONEY AWAY OR RESOURCES AWAY.
FROM TREATMENT.
IN FACT WE THINK THIS IS
ACTUALLY A PART OF TREATMENT AND
ALL I CAN SAY IS.
IF A PERSON OVERDOSES THEY
REALLY DO HAVE INADVERTENT THEY
OVERDOSING DIE THEY NEVER HAVE
ANOTHER CHANCE OF RECOVERY SO I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RENTAL HANG OVER THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND WE COMMITTED TO
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LIZZY BEACON OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
KATHY MUST FOR SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION A CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOING BACK A CELL BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
SAVANNAH O'NEILL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNA HEY WOULD HARM REDUCTION
COALITION COSPONSORED STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS HALLS WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS STRONG SUPPORT OF EGGMAN
STILL.
CODY BOILS IN HALF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM ADDICTION
PROGRAMS PROFESSIONALS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAT TO BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK WINDOWS
WITH US HERE YOU CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS PAUL YEUTTER
SCHNEIDER AND TO IN BEHALF OF
SAN FRANCISCO'S MARYLAND BREED
THANK YOU SOMEONE EGGMAN.
THANK YOU.
SO IS THERE A TEST THE SECOND.
A TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY PLEASE.
OUR TIME IS WITH THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE CHORUS ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WE'RE OPPOSED --
TO AB ONE EIGHTY SIX WHICH WAS
VETOED LAST YEAR AND A REMAIN
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WE JUST FRANKLY HAVE A
HARD TIME RECONCILING THE NOTION
THAT PROTECTING AND ENCOURAGING
DRUG USE --
WILL HELP WITH OUR STATES MANY%
DRUG PROBLEMS --
I THINK THAT WAS EMBLEMATIC OF
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE LAST
YEAR I DON'T SPEAK FOR HIM
OBVIOUSLY BUT HE HE MADE SOME
PRETTY --
COGENT ARGUMENTS AGAINST --
THIS BILL FRANKLY MOST IF NOT
ALL OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
ABSOLVED FROM CRIMINAL LIABILITY
UNDER THIS BILL.
REMAIN ILLEGAL UNDER FEDERAL LAW
SO WE'RE SETTING UP THE CITY AND
COUNTY --
AND MAYBE THEY DON'T MIND ABOUT
THIS BUT YOU'RE SETTING UP THE
CITY AND COUNTY --
FOR INSTEAD FIGHT BETWEEN STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW --
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT WILL
COME FROM THAT AND FRANKLY
DESPITE THE BILL'S ATTEMPT TO
PROTECT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
LIABILITY.
WE FEAR IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF
TIME BEFORE PERSON WHO UTILIZES
ONE OF THESE PLACES --
WILL LEAVE THE FACILITY THERE IS
NO REQUIREMENT THAT A PERSON WHO
UTILIZES A SAFE INJECTION SITE
OR AN OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAM --
WILL STAY UNTIL THEY ARE NO
LONGER UNDER THE INFLUENCE AND
SO -- THIS
DOES NOT ABSOLVE A PERSON FROM
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
ILLEGALLY BUT IT CERTAINLY
CREATES A SITUATION WHERE WE
THINK IT'S LIKELY THAT SOMEONE
WILL COME TO THE ONE OF THESE
FACILITIES --
USED THEIR SUBSTANCES AND LEAVE
WHILE STILL UNDER THE INFLUENCE
PUTTING THE REST THE MOTORING
PUBLIC AT RISK NECK THAT'S JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF OUR CONCERN IN
THAT REGARD SO --
FOR THOSE REASONS WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE THANK YOU.
SO MY TWO WITNESSES AS YOU KNOW
SO.
WELL MY NAME IS FRANKLY I AM
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
OVER THE BAY AREA DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST TWO
THAT'S WHY WE GOT A WHOLE BUNCH
OF RESIDENTS FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA. TO COME HERE ALL THE
WAY TO SAY NO TO THIS BILL NO
DATE THE MAIN REASON OF THE
PROPONENT IS THAT THE WE WE DO
USE.
DRUG OVERDOSE DEATH CASES BUT
ACTUALLY IS CERTAINLY WRONG YOU
KNOW ACCORDING TO BRITISH
COLUMBIA CORONERS SERVICES.
THE OVERDOSE THE TRUCK OVERDOSE
DEATH CASES ACTUALLY.
INCREASE OUR HUNT THE HOUSE IN
PERCENT OR ACTUALLY A TEN TIMES
YOU KNOW IN THE TEN YEARS SELF
OPERATIONS ALL OF THE INJECTION
CENTER AND BE A MAKEOVER.
THAT MEANS IS A BIG FAILURE AND
ALSO THIS BILL DOES NOT BE
CLAUDIA --
THE ANY DRUG ADDICTS TO GOAL FOR
TRUCK WE HABITATION RIGHT AFTER
DOING INJECTION SO THAT MEANS IT
JUST ENCOURAGES THEM --
TO TO DO MORE INJECTION TO USE
MY THE CAKE IT THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY TAILOR MADE FOR DRUG
TRAFFICKING --
GANGSTERS AND ALSO FOR DRUG
ADDICTS SO WE STRONGLY OPPOSED --
TO AB THREE SIXTY TWO AND
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNOR OF OF
OF THE LAST --
GOVERNOR BROWN WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AT BOTH
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL AND
THE DISADVANTAGES OF THIS BIãU
FAR AWAY AND THE POSSIBLE
BENEFITS.
THANK YOU.
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE WOULD COMMAND EVERYONE. TO A
CLOSE EXAMINATION OF GOVERNOR
BROWN'S VERY THOUGHTFUL VETO OF
THIS BILL LAST YEAR.
THE ISSUE WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
IT DOES NOT PROVIDE A COG NICE
SYBIL ROUTE TO TREATMENT.
MISSING FROM THE BILL IS ANY
DISCUSSION FOR EXAMPLE OF
METHADONE ALTERNATIVES.
MISSING FROM THE BILL IS SKINNY
DIRECTIVE TO THE OPERATORS OF
THE INJECTION CENTER. TO EXAMINE
SOMEONE AFTER THEY SHOOTS UP
SHOOT UP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT SO IMPAIRED THAT
THEY MIGHT DO HARM TO THEMSELVES
OR OTHERS.
WHEN THEY DEPART?
MISSING FROM THE BILL IS HE ANY
SIRIUS LOOK AT THE IN A AT THE
LOW CITING AND LOCATION PROBLEMS.
OF WHERE THE SITES THE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE INSIGHT IN
VANCOUVER.
YOU WILL FIND A COUPLE OF THINGS
YES THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO USE THE
INJECTION SITE.
BUT MOST OF THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS IS.
INSIGHT HAS BECOME A MAGNET. FOR
OF A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN STREET
DRUG ACTIVITY AND IN FACT IS
MISTER LEE INDICATED.
THE NUMBER OF OVERDOSE DEATHS
SINCE INSIDE HAS BEEN IN PLACE
OF ACTUALLY GONE UP --
IN THAT REGION GOVERNOR BROWN
HAD IT RIGHT YOU CANNOT SIMPLY
BE ENABLE.
OF ADDICTIVE BEHAVIOR AND EXPECT
TO GET A A A GOOD RESULT I
PERMISSION TO SAY WHAT I'M ABOUT
TO SAY.
MY WIFE IS A RECOVERING
ALCOHOLIC WITH SHE WILL HAVE
THIRTY THREE YEARS OF SOBRIETY
ON APRIL FOURTH.
AND AND SHE IS A REAL EXPERT NOT
AN ACADEMIC ON THIS WOULD SHE
HAS SAID TO ME IS THAT YOU DON'T
GET PEOPLE.
CLEAN BY ENABLING THEM TO
CONTINUE --
TO USE THE DRUGS YOU HAVE TO
HAVE ROBUST INTERVENTIONS TO GET
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT TO HELP
GET PEOPLE SOBRE.
THOSE ELEMENTS AS WELL
INTENTIONED AS THIS BILL IS ARE
MISSING --
FROM FROM THE BILL AND THAT WAS
THE GRAVEL MEN OF GOVERNOR
BROWN'S EXCELLENT AND FOUGHT
FULL VETO MESSAGE LAST YEAR
WHICH WE WOULD STRONGLY COMMAND
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A LOT OF
THE FACT THAT YOU THREE
WITNESSES SPOKE --
AND WE WERE STILL ABOUT A MINUTE
LEFT AND WENT ALLOW IF MISS
LAURA THOMAS IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAVE
ALLOW YOU TO TESTIFY. FOR A
MINUTE.
THANK YOU CHAIR WOULD.
I THINK --
AS BOTH OF THE THE EXPERT
WITNESSES HERE HAVE STATED.
THERE'S NOT ONLY A VERY STRONG
RESEARCH BASIS FOR THESE
PROGRAMS WITH A BàN EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE IN ESSENTIALLY ANY
DEMAND THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS
WHETHER IT'S AROUND.
AND NEIGHBORHOOD CRIME OR
CONNECTING PEOPLE TO TREATMENT
OR JUST PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH
SOME DIGNITY AND RESPECT --
THAT THEY MAY NOT EASILY FIND --
IN THEIR LIVES GIVEN THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE WHO FIND THEMSELVES
INJECTING ON THE STREETS IN SAN
FRANCISCO VERY MUCH WANT THEY DO
NOT WANT TO BE INJECTING ON THE
STREETS THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE.
AN INDOOR PLACE --
THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE THEY WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES IN THEIR LIVES THIS IS A
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED AND
DEBATED IN SAN FRANCISCO FOR
OVER A DECADE.
AT THIS POINT AND THE MOST
RECENT POLLING FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
FOUND THAT 77% OF PEOPLE POLLED
SUPPORTED THIS IN SAN FRANCISCO
SO ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW SAN
FRANCISCO RESIDENTS --
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO OTHERS IN OPPOSITION JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS LISA SAYING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I UP POLLS.
AB THREE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I'M SHERRY FROM SAN FRANCISCO I
OPPOSE THIS AB.
THREE SIX TWO THANK YOU.
I'M CHERRY FROM SAN FRANCISCO I
OPPOSE AB THREE SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS TWENTY ONE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO COALITION FOR GOOD
NEIGHBORHOODS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE AB SIXTY TWO ILLEGAL TRUCK
INJECTION I AM NOT ONE OF THE
77%.
JUST YOUR NAME IN JUST YOUR NAME
AND YOUR POSITION PLEASE I'M
DOCTOR EVELYN LEAD --
INTERNIST CARDIOLOGISTS I AM A
PRESIDENT OF THE COALITION OF
PATIENT ADVOCATE I AM A
LEGISLATIVE.
REPRESENTATIVE FOR ALAMEDA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE. FOR
FOR AMERICAN CARDIOLOGY.
COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY.
AND I'M OPPOSING TO THIS AB
THREE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
I AM JENNY FIRST OFFICE FROM UPS
I'M STRONG.
OPPOSE THIS BILL AB THREE SIXTY
TWO WELL WORK [inaudible]
REMEMBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THE HOLDEN --
BROWN --
MERE PETERS --
BAY AREA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
OPPOSE ABC SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
WILSON LATE PRONG SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
THREE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
CHRISTY BROWN I'VE REPRESENT MOM
STRONG PARENTS OF KIDS WHO.
HAVE BEEN HARMED BY DRUGS MOTHER
OF INJECTING HEROIN ADDICT IN
RECOVERY FOR FIVE YEARS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I AM SO LONG AND I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
TWO THANK YOU --
YOU WALL ABSENCE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED TO SPILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THEIR BEADY ARM FROM
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. FIVE MAKE SURE YOU.
AND US OF CISCO PROBABLY ORDER I
SAW THAT POST AB SIXTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I'M WEARING ISSUE A TEACHER A
MOTHER --
ELFISH --
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY I OPPOSE.
A. B. THREE SIXTY TWO IT
PROFESSIONAL FROM AMONG TO BE
EVERY AND STRONGLY OPPOSED TO IT
THANK YOU.
A PHOTO SHOOT FROM.
FREE LONG THE PASTOR AGAINST
THESE FAKE KEY HUMANITARIAN
EFFORTS WHICH READ DOES NOT LOOK
GOOD THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN A BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MASON --
SEGMENT YEAH.
WE'VE GOT A CAUCUS
RECOMMENDATION OF OF OPPOSING
I'VE GOT STAFF --
RECOMMENDATION OF OPPOSING --
BECAUSE I'VE SERVED WITH YOU THE
LAST FOUR YEARS AND YOU'VE TAKEN
ON SOME VERY HEAVY ISSUES --
THAT OTHERS WOULD NOT WANT TO
TAKE ON A BECAUSE OF THE
POLITICAL WEIGHT.
AND THAT COMES ALONG WITH THEM I
HAVE A IN A DEEP REGARD BECAUSE
OF YOUR OF YOUR WORK I WANT TO
TAKE A LOOK.
AT THIS A LITTLE A LITTLE DEEPER
THE THAT I WOULD OPPOSE AS WELL --
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE BROUGHT SOMETHING FORD IF
YOU DIDN'T HAVE COMPASSION --
FOR FOR INDIVIDUALS AND WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
OF TRYING TO SAVE THEIR LIVES
INSIDE THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD BUT
THERE THERE WAS A QUESTION THAT
I DID HAVE A IN REGARDS --
TO THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
IF IT'S OKAY FOR ME JUST TO READ
THEM ONE QUICK LINE HERE HE HE
SAID IN HIS VETO MESSAGE LAST
YEAR AFTER GREAT REFLECTION I
CONCLUDED THE DISADVANTAGES OF
THIS BILL.
FAR OUTWEIGH THE POSSIBLE
BENEFITS FUNDAMENTALLY I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT ENABLING ILLEGAL
DRUG USE AND GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED OBJECTION CENTERS.
WITH NO CORRESPONDING
REQUIREMENT THAT THE USER UNDER
GROW TREATMENT WILL REDUCE DRUG
ADDICTION AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S REALLY THE CRUX OF THE
MATTER -- IF
I WAS THE VOTE HI TO MOVE THIS
BILL ALONG --
I WOULD WANT SOME LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY THAT THIS BILL WAS
GOING TO PROVIDE THE GREATEST --
POSSIBILITY FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO TO REGAIN THEIR LIVES
FROM THE DRUG ADDICTION.
BUT DO WE DOES THERE NEED TO BE
MORE CONSTRAINTS LIKE THE
GOVERNOR BROUGHT UP LAST YEAR TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE FOLKS ARE
GOING TO MAKE SURE TO GET SOME
HELP.
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS AND AND AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING AN OPEN
MIND -- I
THINK I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IS COMPELLING AND I YOU
KNOW WE CERTAINLY DISAPPOINTED
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
LAST YEAR AND AND CERTAINLY --
THAT THE OPPOSITION YOU KNOW
THOSE WAS THERE THAT WAS THEIR
MESSAGE TO HIM --
BUT I THINK YOU HEARD FROM EVERY
ADDICTION SPECIALIST IN THE
STATE YOU'VE HEARD FROM
EVERYBODY WHO WORKS IN THIS AREA
YOU'VE HEARD FROM.
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
THAT THEY SUPPORT THIS APPROACH
TO TREATMENT.
AGAIN WE SEE THIS AS TREATMENT
KEEPING SOMEBODY ALIVE ANOTHER
DAY IS A FORM OF TREATMENT IF
SOMEBODY OVERDOSES AND GO TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM WE DON'T SAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO REVIVE YOU.
IN LESS YOU PROMISE RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE GOING TO TREATMENT IF
SOMEBODY GOES IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM AND THEY BEEN A VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE DON'T SAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HELP YOU
UNLESS YOU AGREE RIGHT NOW.
THAT YOU'RE GONNA LEAVE LUKE
LEAVE YOUR USER WE DON'T DO
THINGS LIKE THAT BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT --
THAT KIND OF COERCION AND THAT
KIND OF HOLDING SOMEBODY'S LIFE
IN THE PALM OF YOUR HAND FOR YOU
TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO.
IS NOT AFFECTED TO GET PEOPLE
INTO TREATMENT.
WITH THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN US
IS THAT PEOPLE WHO USUALLY
CENTERS GOING TO TREATMENT MORE
FREQUENTLY THAN PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST USING ON THE STREETS.
AND THIS IS A PILOT PROJECT JUST
IN THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IS THAT IS CORRECT AND
IT IS LIKE AND THE CITY AND
COUNTY --
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS DID
THEY TAKE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THIS WAS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
I'M FROM ANY OF THE THE THE BUT
THE BOARD MEMBERS NOT TO NOT TO
MY KNOWLEDGE IT WAS IT WAS IT
WAS -- THEY
THINK UNANIMOUS STATE THEY HAVE
BEEN AT YOU KNOWS ANYBODY WHO'S
CLOSE A SAN FRANCISCO RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY HAVE AN
INCREASE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW AND
AND YOU.
KNOW I THINK 77% --
I'VE HAD LATELY AND I'VE HEARD
FROM YOU NURSES DOCTORS PEOPLE
WHO SAY IT IS A DIFFICULT TO
WALK OUTSIDE NOW WITHOUT
STEPPING OVER A NEEDLE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE THAT
WERE THAT WERE FACING WITH SO
NOT ONLY HOPEFULLY ARE WE
PROVIDING COMPASSION AND A PATH
TO TREATMENT A PATH TO DIGNITY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE USING.
BUT WE'RE ALSO PROVIDING SOME
RELIEF HOPEFULLY TO
NEIGHBORHOODS TO THE OVERWHELMED
OFTENTIMES POLICE AND FIRE AND
EMERGENCY ROOMS THAT ARE TAKING
UP WAY TOO MUCH OF THEIR TIME.
BEING CALLED TO OVERDOSE ON
STREETS VERSUS BEING ABLE TO TO
DO THE WORK THAT WE WANTED TO DO
IT IN FIGHTING CRIME AND SAVING
LIVES.
IS THERE ANY FEAR AT ALL THAT
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE ANY
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES IT'LL
ACTUALLY DO MORE HARM.
THAN IT WOULD THEN IT WOULD GOOD.
WHAT WE HAVE DECADES OF RESEARCH
FROM AROUND THE WORLD THAT HAS
SHOWN THAT THAT NOT THAT NOT TO
BE TRUE --
THAT PUBLIC USE TENDS TO GO DOWN
THAT --
POLICE OFFICERS OFTENTIMES
PUBLIC SAFETY WILL ENGAGE IN
RELATIONSHIP THEY SEE SOMEONE
USING IT'LL SAY YOU KNOW THIS IS
A SAFE PLACE OVER HERE THAT YOU
CAN USE --
YOU KNOW WHEN WE SAY IT'S
ENABLING LETTING SOMEONE CHEWED
UP IN A GUTTER OR IN A
PLAYGROUND --
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S NOT AN
OPTION I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
ANYBODY WOULD WANT TO SAY THAT
IS WHAT YOU NEED TO DO VERSUS
GOING SOMEPLACE THAT IS
MEDICALLY SUPERVISED WE CAN BE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY.
AND BEING REFERRED TO SERVICES
REFER TO AGAIN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
YOU HAVE AN ABSCESS YOU KNOW A
AN ABSCESS ON A ON A TOWER
PEOPLE OFTEN TIMES USING THEY
CAN'T FIND ANY OTHER VANS.
THAT CAN LEAD TO A LOSS OF A
FOOT.
AND THEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY IN A
WHEELCHAIR ON THE STREETS
STOPPING TRAFFIC I MEAN THE
AMOUNT OF COMORBIDITY THAT GOES
ALONG WITH IV DRUG USE AND AN
ABJECT POVERTY AND LIVING THEY
ARE ALREADY AT THE HIGHEST RISK
FOR ALL KINDS.
OF COMMUNICABLE DISEASES --
AND JUSTICE DID COMORBIDITY THAT
GOES ALONG WITH THAT SO AGAIN TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
TO BE ABLE TO GET REFER TO A
TREATMENT TO BE ABLE TO FIX AN
ABSCESS ALL OF THOSE THINGS WE
SEE AS POSITIVE.
AND AGAIN YOU START THAT
RELATIONSHIP PEOPLE ARE MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO GET IN HE GOT THE
DIRECTOR OF ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROGRAMS --
IN SAN FRANCISCO IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS SAYING THIS IS
GOOD THIS IS THE KIND A
WRAPAROUND SERVICE THAT WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO REACH THE VERY
HARDEST TO REACH.
I MEAN MAYBE JUST TELLING
SOMEBODY JUST SAY NO MIGHT HAVE
WORKED WHEN SOMEBODY'S A
TEENAGER SMOKING A LITTLE WEED.
BUT I THINK WHEN PEOPLE HAVE --
GOT TO THE POINT WHERE THEY ARE
LIVING ON THE STREETS USING ON
THE STREETS --
SELLING THEIR BODIES --
TO BE ABLE TO TO GET THEIR NEXT
FIX THAT IS SOMETHING I THINK AS
IF WE'RE HUMANITARIANS WE WANT
TO ENGAGE WITH THAT WE WANT TO
SAY WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
NOT NOT ON OUR CITIES NOT ON OUR
STREETS.
WHEN THERE'S WHEN THERE ARE
RESEARCH --
DRIVEN OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO USE AND IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY WILL PROVIDE
SUPERVISION IS THAT IS THAT
CORRECTAND THEY'RE READY FOR
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO FUND IT
THEY'RE GONNA.
THAT'S CORRECT AND AS IT WILL
SEE THIS AS SAVINGS TURNING
ANOTHER THEY'RE ALL OF THE SING
THAT THEY THIS PILOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THAT I'M HAVING THE
COURAGE OF YOUR CONVICTIONS TO
BRING THIS BILL AGAIN CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG LAST YEAR THIS WAS
A STATEWIDE BILL.
THAT WAS NARROWED DOWN TO THE
COUNTY AND CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
LAST YEAR WE STARTED WITH A WITH
A TRIAL OF WE'D NOT TO EXCEED
TEN COUNTIES WHO WOULD OPT INTO
AGAIN IT WAS NEVER TOP DOWN IT
WAS ALWAYS SAYING.
IF YOUR ISSUE FEELS LIKE THIS
WOULD BE A GOOD OPTION FOR YOU
THEN WITH YOUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH YOUR PUBLIC HEALTH WITH
YOUR TREATMENT PROVIDERS YOU CAN
ASSESS.
IF THIS IS SOMETHING WE NARROWED
IT DOWN EVEN FURTHER TO JUST THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE GOVERNOR HER **** I MEAN CAN
WE JUST DO IT SOME PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE.
OPPOSED TO IT WHICH IS WHICH IS
WHERE WE GOT AND WHITE NOW WE'RE
HERE AGAIN WITH JUST A SIX YEAR
SUNSET AND WITH THE ANNUAL
REPORT BACK.
THANK YOU I I ASK BECAUSE IT'S A
QUESTION THAT CAME UP --
ONCE THE GOVERNOR HAD VETOED.
LAST YEAR'S BILL THERE ARE SOME
FOLKS IN AN ALLEY COUNTY THAT
SAID WE ACTUALLY COULD REALLY
USE A PILOT PROJECT JUST LIKE
THIS BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW LA
COUNTY SKID ROW.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES OF
HOMELESSNESS AND YOUNG PEOPLE
AND IF AND AND HAVING
CONVERSATION WITH FOLKS INSANE I
NEED HELP AND I CAN'T.
DO THIS ON MY OWN I NEED A PLACE
WHERE I CAN GET A FIX BUT ALSO
HAVE SOMEBODY READILY AVAILABLE
TO ME TO HELP ME GET THROUGH
THIS PROCESS.
AND I THINK THAT'S LOOKING AT
THIS ISSUE FROM A VERY FULL WELL
THAT WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE
PAST HAS NOT WORKED.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS AGAIN UP
TO US AND IT'S IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE SUMMATION OF THE QUESTION
YEAH JUST TO MAKE SURE SO WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY CHRIS WHO GOT THE
NARCOTICS OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
IS TEACHERS ASSOCIATION --
IS THERE IS THERE SOME WAY TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEM --
IT THAT BECAUSE IT IS A PILOT
PROJECT TO JUSTIN --
ONE CITY AND COUNTY AND IF THIS
IS GONNA HAVE BENEFITS WHY
WOULDN'T --
BUT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ORGANIZATIONS BE BE SUPPORTIVE.
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES OLD IDEAS ARE
HARD TO CHANGE AND OLD WAYS OF
THINKING ABOUT THINGS ARE HARD
TO CHANGE BUT CERTAINLY I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
THAT WE THAT WE SEE THAT WE HAVE
EVIDENCE OF IS WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING.
IS NOT REACHING EVERYBODY --
SO WE DID TAKE AMENDMENTS INTO
THE BILL OR WE DID DO THE BILL
THIS YEAR THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS TO BE AT THE TABLE.
AND SO AND AND TO MISS CORREOS
POINT --
BLESS ANGEL CERTAINLY HAS ASKED
ABOUT IT BUT THERE WAS STILL
SOME RESISTANCE AND WE AGAIN WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT IMPOSES ON
ANYBODY IF ANOTHER COUNTY OR
CITY WANTS TO COME FORWARD.
AFTER THEY SEE WHAT SAN
FRANCISCO'S DONE BECAUSE WE DO
KNOW THAT THE LA COUNTY HAS
SUBSISTENCE SEVERE --
ISSUES THAT THEY'RE DEALING WITH
ALSO THEY WOULD HAVE TO TO OPT
INTO SOMETHING LIKE THIS SO WE
FEEL LIKE WE'VE DONE.
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO BE
ABLE -- TO
GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT A SEAT AT
THE TABLE --
AND AND SO SAN FRANCISCO FEELS
LIKE THEY'RE THEY'VE HAD A SEAT
AT THE TABLE NEVER TO GO FORWARD.
THANK YOU IF YOU HAVE HEARD --
YOU'VE CONVINCED ME AT TODAY TO
MOVE THIS BILL THE FORD --
I DO THINK BECAUSE IT'S A
LIMITED A PILOT PROJECT THE
SUPPORT OF LOCAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND WITH THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT BEING HAVING A
SEAT AT THE TABLE --
I THINK IT'S A WHERE THE IDEA TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
CAN I TAKE THAT AS A MOTION
MISTER MISTRESS OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MESA SECOND
FIVE IS CARILLO.
WHICH I CLOSER SEGMENT --
JUST THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE FOB
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION THE THE
DEDICATION OF THE ACTIVISTS IN
THE ADVOCATES --
AND JUST JUST FOR YOU TO KNOW I
MEAN THE THE CARDS AND LETTERS
THAT I GET THAT JUST PEOPLE
SAYING THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING
FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE NO
VOICE -- AND
I'D CERTAINLY NOT AS ALIGNING
MYSELF --
FOR COMPARING MYSELF AT ALL --
TO MOTHER TERESA BUT IF WE THINK
SHOULDN'T JUST SAY I JUST WANT
TO GO WORK WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
YOU KNOW AT JUST READY TO PULL
THEMSELVES UP BY THEIR
BOOTSTRAPS AND GET ON YOU HAVE
TO GO OUT INTO THE STREET YOU
HAVE TO MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY
ARE.
IN ORDER TO AND TREAT THEM WITH
LOVE AND COMPASSION AND THAT'S
HOW WE CHANGE LIVES AND THAT'S
HOW WE MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES
BETTER I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SEGMENT
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR IT I KNOW
HOW HARD YOU WORKED ON THIS THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS --
I'D YOU KNOW AS YOU SAID SO SO
ELOQUENTLY --
WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO TO DO THE
SAME THING AND EXPECT DIFFERENT
RESULTS RIGHT I'M FREEZING MY
OWN PRISON OF MY OWN WAY BUT THE
CLEARLY WHAT WE'RE DOING IS NOT
REACHING EVERYONE.
AND IF THIS REACHES A FEW PEOPLE
AND IT SAVE SOME LIVES THAN THAN
I HAVE TO CONSIDER IT IS IT IS
AS MORE THAN WORTHWHILE SO IF
THIS BELIEVES A COMMITTEE TODAY
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AND I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU TALK TO IT.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO MADAM SECRETARY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
I MISS MAGICALLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
I BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
THE LOAN.
AMOUNT AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
RAMOS.
FROM OF SNOW. TO TO AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON NO. TWO SIX VOTES --
WE SO WE HAVE MANY MEMBERS
MISSING SO WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
YEAH ONE MORE.
I DO HAVE ONE MORE.
AB.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN IS A BILL
WHICH WOULD EXTEND MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY FOR WOMEN POST
PREGNANCY DEALING WITH PREGNANCY
RELATED.
OR POST PARTUM MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSIS IF THE BILL.
THANK YOU CURRENTLY EIGHT STATE
AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS --
WOMEN WHO ARE PREGNANT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE --
BUT OFTENTIMES THE CARE THAT
THEY REQUIRE EXCEEDS THE AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT THEY ARE ELIGIBLE
AND WE CERTAINLY KNOW IT IS
OBVIOUS THAT MATERNAL HEALTH IS
AN IMPORTANT PART OF RAISING
HEALTHY CHILDREN.
AND A KEY ASPECT TO OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NET.
THIS EGGMAN FORCE EXPANDED
COVERAGE ONLY LAST MAKE ANYBODY
CHOOSE MEDI CAL BUT THIS
CERTAINLY SAYS THAT IF YOU'RE
FOR DEALING WITH ISSUES THAT THE
MEDIC HELP PERIOD SHOULD BE
EXTENDED SO THAT YOU CAN TAKE
CARE OF YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
SO THAT YOU CAN.
BE THE BEST YOU CAN BE FOR YOUR
YOUNG CHILD --
AND WITH ME TODAY --
I HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU MY NAME IS DR
CHRISTOPHER BEATTY.
I AM AN OBGYN IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA I AM THE DEPARTMENT
CHAIR OF SPECIALLY MEDICINE FOR
CALIFORNIA HEALTH SCIENCES
UNIVERSITY.
COLLEGE OF OSTEOPATHIC MEDICINE --
I AM HERE --
REPRESENTING A COG DISTRICT --
NINE WE ARE SPONSORING THIS BILL.
AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE SOME --
INSIGHT TO WHAT OPG LANDS ARE
SEEING ON A DAILY BASIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
ESTIMATES THAT OVER HALF A
MILLION --
PREGNANCIES --
IN THIS COUNTRY EVERY YEAR ARE
AFFECTED BY A PSYCHIATRIC
ILLNESS --
AND AS YOU ABOUT HALF OF ALL
DELIVERIES IN CALIFORNIA EACH
YEAR ARE TWO WOMEN WHO ARE
COVERED BY MEDICARE.
SO WITH THIS --
LARGE NUMBER OF SITE CHECK
PSYCHIATRIC ILLNESSES THAT WE'RE
SEEING AS PHYSICIANS AND A LARGE
NUMBER OF WOMEN ON MEDI CAL --
THESE PATIENTS ARE COMING INTO
OUR OFFICES WHO EITHER HAVE A
PSYCHIATRIC.
ILLNESS PRIOR TO PREGNANCY OR
OFTENTIMES DEVELOPED IN
PREGNANCY OR AFTER PREGNANCY AS
YOU MAY KNOW POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION IS A A PROBLEM THAT
WE SEE QUITE OFTEN --
WITH THESE ILLNESSES THESE
PATIENTS ARE USUALLY TREATED IN
JUST ONE VISIT TO THE POSITION I
CAN'T PRESCRIBE A MEDICATION.
AND GIVEN THE PANEL AND SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO BE FINE AND NOT
SEE HIM AGAIN.
CURRENTLY THESE MEDICAL PATIENTS
LOSE THEIR COVERAGE AFTER SIXTY
DAYS AFTER DELIVERY.
THESE WOMEN HAVE NOT ONLY ISSUES
OF CARING FOR THEMSELVES AND
TREATING THEIR THEIR ILLNESSES
BUT THOSE THOSE SAME WOMEN GO
HOME AND THEIR CHILDREN SUFFER.
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO CARE FOR
THEIR OWN CHILDREN.
THE CURRENT BABY THAT THEY HAD
THEIR OTHER CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THEIR JOBS SUFFER --
SO WITH THIS BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE HEALTH CARE
FOR A YEAR THEY CAN COME BACK TO
OUR OFFICE BECAUSE THESE WOMEN
DO NOT COME BACK IN OUR OFFICES --
THEY CAN COME BACK WE CAN GET
THEM THE TREATMENT THEY NEED WE
CAN FOLLOW UP MAKE SURE WE CAN
ADJUST OUR MEDICATIONS AS NEEDED
WE GET THEM COUNSELING --
AND SO --
AND AS WELL THERE'S INCREASE IN
SUICIDE AS WELL AND I WANTED TO
HIT ON THAT POINT QUICKLY AS
WELL.
THECDC DID A STUDY IN FROM
NINETEEN NINETY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA AN INCREASE IN THE
SUICIDE RATE BY FOURTEEN POINT
9%.
AND ABOUT HALF OF THOSE SUICIDES
ARE TWO WOMEN WHO ARE AFFECTED
BY MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SO -- IF WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR REQUEST
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON ARLENE
CALLUM DIRECTOR OF WOMEN'S AND
CHILDREN'S AMBULATORY SERVICES
FOR CENTER MEDICAL CENTER
SACRAMENTO.
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE MARCH OF
DIMES IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN ALTHOUGH THE
AFFAIR AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
EXPANDED THE AVAILABILITY OF
MATERNITY MATERNITY CARE
COVERAGE FOR WOMEN BOTH THROUGH
EXCHANGE PLANS AND MEDICAID
EXPANSION.
THERE REMAIN SIGNIFICANT
LIMITATIONS ON COVERAGE FOR POST
PARTUM CARE.
TRADITIONALLY WOMEN RECEIVE ONLY
ONE POST PARTUM CHECK UP AT FOUR
TO SIX WEEKS POST DELIVERY AND
THESE ROUTINE VISITS TYPICALLY
PROVIDE A LIMITED ARRAY OF
SERVICES AND LIMITED COUNSELING
ON YOUR CONCEPTION CARE.
HOWEVER ADEQUATE POSTPARTUM
COVERAGE SHOULD ENABLE NEW
MOTHERS TO OBTAIN THE SERVICES
THEY NEED TO ENSURE A FULL
RECOVERY AND TO ENSURE THEIR
NEXT PREGNANCY IF ANY CAN BE
HEALTHY.
THIS INCLUDES POSTPARTUM VISITS
WHERE THEIR PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
AND PSYCHOSOCIAL WELL BEING CAN
BE EVALUATED.
UNFORTUNATELY POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION AND MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
CONCERNS.
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
INCLUDE A RANGE OF CONDITIONS
SUCH AS DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
DISORDERS AND THEY CAN CAUSE
SERIOUS COMPLICATIONS DURING AND
AFTER PREGNANCY THAT CAN IMPACT
THE HEALTH.
OF MOTHERS AND THEIR NEWBORNS.
MATERNAL SOME WOMEN INFANTS AND
FAMILIES INCLUDING PERPETUATING
ADVERSE BIRTH OUTCOMES.
IN CALIFORNIA THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH MATERNAL AND
INFANT HEALTH ASSESSMENT OR ME
HIGH DOCUMENTS THE PREVALENCE OF
THESE CONDITIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE 200-013-2152 ME
HOW DATA SNAPSHOT WHICH WAS
RELEASED IN JULY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN POINT 1% OF
PREGNANT WOMEN EXPERIENCE
PRENATAL DEPRESSIVE SYMPTOMS AND
13% EXPERIENCE POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSIVE SYMPTOMS.
PREVALENCE RATES ARE HIGHER
AMONG BLACK WOMEN NINETEEN POINT
FOR PRENATAL FOURTEEN POINT SIX
POST PARTUM HISPANIC WOMEN
SEVENTEEN POINT NINE PRENATAL
FIFTEEN POINT ONE POST PARTUM
AND WOMEN UTILIZING MEDI CAL.
NINETEEN PRENATAL AND SIXTEEN
POINT SEVEN POST PARTUM WELL
THESE CONDITIONS ARE COMMON ONLY
ABOUT 15% OF WOMEN WITH POST
PARTUM DEPRESSION RECEIVE
TREATMENT I MEAN TO SAY THAT
OVER AGAIN.
WELL THESE CONDITIONS ARE COMMON
ONLY ABOUT 15% OF WOMEN WITH
POST PARTUM DEPRESSION RECEIVE
TREATMENT EVEN THOUGH ABOUT 90%
OF WOMEN CAN BE SUCCESSFULLY
TREATED.
MORE WORK IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT THE WOMEN ARE SUCCESSFULLY
SCREEN PREFERRED AND TREATED FOR
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS.
CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE SEVERAL
STEPS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BY
ADOPTING AB FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
TO EXPAND MEDICAL COVERAGE OF
POST PARTUM CARE. TO A FULL YEAR
AFTER GIVING BIRTH RATHER THAN
THE CURRENT LIMIT OF SIXTY DAYS
FROM THE END OF PREGNANCY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT PROPOSAL.
VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER AGAIN
FOR THE PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION
WERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. EIGHTY
ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
IN A SCAN ON BEHALF WINTERS
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP PARENTS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JERRY WANTED
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISS BURKE.
MY DOCTOR CAN I JUST WHAT I WANT
TO THANK YOU THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL AND WHEN THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE LIKE TO BE OUT OF
THIS CALL CERTAINLY.
ANYONE ELSE MISS WALDRON --
THANK YOU ALSO FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD YOU KNOW WE'VE
LEARNED QUITE A BIT OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS ABOUT MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND THE STIGMA OR THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE IT.
A LOT OF TIMES MOMS ARE KIND OF
ON THEIR OWN TRYING TO FIGURE IT
OUT SO AND WE SEE THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF THAT ON
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE CHILDREN
SO --
DEFINITELY A GOOD BILL THANK
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
SO. TO HEAR MOTION ANYWHERE --
TO WE HAVE A WE DID MUCH I'M
SORRY OKAY MISTAKE WHEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A JUST A TO
SAY I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS.
AND AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
IN IMPROVING.
THE HEALTH OF NEW MOTHERS AND
THEIR GROWING FAMILIES.
AND IN ON THE PREVIOUS BILL YOU
EXCEPT.
I DIDN'T MISS AS WELL THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND I LOST TRACK OF MADE
MOTION.
AND MISS MISS MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
MISS OF MOTION MY MISTAKE YOUR
CURRENT SECOND BY MISS CARILLO
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
MAYES I THANK YOUR CURRY.
CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE.
BURKE AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LIMON I LIMóN I MCCARTY
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RUMORS ARE. TO TO AYE
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. TO GET [inaudible]
FOR FLORA I'D.
THAT HAS TEN VOTES SO THAT'S OUT
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
WITH AGUIAR-CURRY
.
THIS WAS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU HAVE
AB [inaudible]
TWO TWO EIGHT MR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWO
TWO EIGHT CLARIFIES THAT A FOOD
BEVERAGE OR COSMETIC THE
CONTAINS CB DE.
DERIVE FROM INDUSTRIAL HELP HIM
IS NOT ADULTERATED.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS RESTRICTIONS
ON THESE PRODUCTS BASED SOLELY
ON THE FACT THAT THEY CAN DATE
CONTAIN CB DE THAT IS DERIVED
FROM HIM.
NOW HOW DID WE GET HERE WELL.
BILL REMOVED HIM FROM ALL FTA
SCHEDULES EVERY CLASSIFIED HIM
AS AN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT.
THIS IS OPEN THE DOORS FOR
FARMERS TO CULTIVATE HIM AND AS
PRESENTED CONSUMERS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IT X. ACCESS.
CBD THAT WILL NOT RESULT IN A
HIGH.
LET ME CLARIFY HIM IS NOT
MARIJUANA.
DOES CBD CAN BE EXTRACTED FROM
BOTH WHEN IS PRODUCED FROM HEMP
THERE ARE NO PSYCHO.
EFFECTS.
THIS IS BECAUSE BY DEFINITION
INDUSTRIAL HEMP ONLY CONTAINS.
POINT 003% THC WHICH IS A PSYCHO
ACTIVE COMPONENT IN MARIJUANA
PRODUCTS.
SO WE HAVE FOUND OURSELVES IN A
CONUNDRUM.
CALIFORNIA LEGALIZE CANNABIS
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S POSITION THAT
CANNABIS IS ILLEGAL BUT
IRONICALLY WHILE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS REMOVED BARRIERS
TO THE LEGAL SALE AND USE OF HIM.
DRIVE PRODUCTS CALIFORNIA LAGS
BEHIND.
THE MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF CB
DID DERIVED FROM HIM IS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
WITH OVER A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
ECONOMIC PRODUCTIVITY.
SHOULD THE STATE CHOOSE NOT TO
CLARIFY THAT HIM SEE BEAUTY
PRODUCTS ARE LEGAL FOR SALE AND
CONSUMPTION.
THESE JOBS AND BUSINESSES WILL
BE LOST.
FURTHER THE MANY CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS ALEX WILL FACE A NEW
BEAR IN OBTAINING THE PRODUCT.
I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND I'M ALSO ADDING
IT URGENCY CLAUSE TO THIS BILL.
WE CANNOT LEAVE OUR SAID US
CITIZENS FARMERS AND BUSINESSES
WITH UNCERTAINTY TO THE WEATHER
HIM BASED CBT MAY CONTINUE TO BE
SOLD IN PURCHASING CALIFORNIA.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR AB
TWO TWO EIGHT AND I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES WITH ME ON BEHALF OF
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JIM GROSS ON BEHALF OF THE US
HEMP ROUNDTABLE FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR.
NOT ONLY ISSUE MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD BUT SHE HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT.
ACTIVITIES OF THE STATE WITH
RESPECT TO HOW THEY VIEW THE
LEGALITY OF C. B. D. U. S. HEMP
ROUNDTABLE REPRESENTS --
HUNDREDS OF ORGANIZATIONS THERE
IN ALL LEVELS OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN -- AS
MS AGUIAR-CURRY INDICATED --
HAMP IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING INDUSTRIES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND CBT OR CANNABIS OIL IS ONE
OF THE PRODUCTS THAT --
CONSUMERS ARE MOST INTERESTED IN --
WE MAKE NO HEALTH CLAIMS WITH
RESPECT TO THESE PRODUCTS
HOWEVER CONSUMERS HAVE SAID THAT
FROM A WELLNESS STANDPOINT --
THEY BELIEVE CB DE SPEWED
OVERREACH LOCALITY IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW A SIMILAR DISPUTE
EXISTED IN OTHER STATES EXISTING
OF THE STATE SOME STATES HAVE
CLARIFIED THAT INCLUDING.
COLORADO AND OREGON THAT IS WHAT
WE SEEK TO DO HERE IS TO CLARIFY
THAT SIMPLY BECAUSE OF AN FDA
DETERMINATION ABOUT ONE DRUG
HAVING CBD.
ARE YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE THE
RESULT THAT THE PRODUCT IS
OTHERWISE ILLEGAL IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THESE CHANGES WE WILL
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED BRANDS
AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO JOIN THE
HEMP INDUSTRY IN SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AND WE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP --
THIS PROVIDES A VERY SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY IN FACT FOR THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AS WELL THEY
HAVE ALREADY BEEN.
CULTIVATING MANUFACTURING AND
SELLING THESE PRODUCTS --
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO SOME OF THE
THE LACK OF CLARITY IN EXISTING
LAW -- THERE
HAVE BEEN RECENT EFFORTS TO
PRECLUDE THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY
AND I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT AT A
TIME WHEN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
IS STRUGGLING. TO TO GROW
ACCUSTOMED TO AND ADJUST TO OUR
NEW REGULATORY REALITY --
THESE PRODUCTS ARE --
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE WIDELY
UTILIZED BY OUR CUSTOMERS AND SO
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT WHEN I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK.
AND I WOULD NOTE APPROXIMATELY
TWELVE OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY
DEVELOPED REGULATIONS AROUND THE
PRODUCTION AND SALE OF HIM AND
HIM TO RIGHT PRODUCTS AND AS THE
AUTHOR NOTED ARE MOVING
AGGRESSIVELY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS NEW AND EMERGING
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
IT'S REALLY TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
TO DO THE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER SUPPORT.
AIR MARIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
INSTRUCTOR FOR THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
NICCOLO DELUCA HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF EMERYVILLE THE
COUNTY OF IMPERIAL MOXIE
EXTRACTS INTERESTS ALEUTIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN
YOUR OFFICE FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK IN THOSE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS BRETT BEAR WITH A
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL VOTE HIM
AND ALL HIGH ENERGETICS HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR KATHY VAN AUSTIN
REPRESENTING KHALIFA
HEADQUARTERED OUT OF SAN JOSE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LEAH SO REFORM CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELANIE CUEVAS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CAN OF
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THREE ONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ON THIS THIS WOMAN.
THANK YOU A AS A MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT'S AN
ISSUE THINK SEVERAL OF OUR
OFFICE HEARD OF A PARTICULARLY
DURING.
THIS PROCESS FOR THIS YEAR WHERE
ARE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH HAS
BEEN TRYING TO DETERMINE WHAT TO
DO AND TARGETING SOME OF THESE --
ENTITIES WITH A BILL IN PLACE.
THAT HAS AN URGENCY CLAUSE I
HAVE THERE BEEN CONVERSATIONS OF
WITH -- OUR
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ON PERHAPS
PAUSING OR RE THINKING THEIR
STRATEGY AT THE MOMENT --
I JUST DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
COMMUNITY.
I'M WE HAVE MET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE REGARDING
THIS THEM.
OBVIOUSLY THERE WAS SOME --
RATES IF YOU WILL HAVE IT --
AT SOME LOCATIONS --
THEY WERE QUITE SURPRISED ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
NECESSARILY DEEMED OKAY TO DO
THAT.
SO -- IT'S
BEEN BROUGHT A LOT OF THIRTY TO
ALL OF US I'M TRYING TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD SO AGAIN --
THEY SUPPORT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO.
JUST ADDITIONALLY BUT OBVIOUSLY
WE DO HAVE OTHER THINGS TO DO IN
THE FUTURE --
ALONG THIS ON ALONG THESE LINES
WE'RE NOT HERE TO UNDERMINE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH ABSOLUTELY
GREAT THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT I'M OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SIX BEEN MOVED A
COUPLE TIMES WITH THAT'S OKAY WE
CAN PLEDGE ON THEIR THIS WALDRON.
I SUPPORT THE BILL AND I JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION.
RIGHT NOW IF YOU WILL GROWING OR
INTERESTED IN GROWING INDUSTRIAL
HEMP OR CV CVD --
YOU WOULD STILL BE GETTING A
LICENSE TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
WITH ANYTHING CHANGE WITH THAT
SINCE.
STILL AFFECTED WITH RESPECT --
TO THE ROLE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TO NAG.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
TINA BRING BACK TO YOU MISTER
YORKER WHICH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISTER
CHU I BELIEVE THAT CORRECT.
OKAY -- AND
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS WITH
THE ADDITION OF AN URGENCY COSTS
YES VERY GOOD THANK YOU MA'AM
SECTOR.
AS THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION BY THE CHAIR
THANK YOU SO --
MA'AM SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY?
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
NO I FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMOS.
MON I MCCARTY [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
RAMOS RAMOS I TO TO AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
GET TEN VOTES IT'S ENOUGH TO
MOVE FROM THE COMMITTEE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PROVISIONS [inaudible]
MISTER MOM
.
THANK YOU SHERYL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AT THE IN CALIFORNIA ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE IS THE THIRD LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IMPACTING
MILLIONS OF LIFE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
TODAY AT THIS BILL IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO ME AS
I LOST MY GRANDMOTHER FOUR DAYS
AGO -- WHO
SUFFERED FROM ALZHEIMER'S
DIMENSION FOR OVER A DECADE?
AT WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE BOB YOUR FEET AT WHO IS A
RETIRED CHIEF OF THE US SIMILAR
PENINSULA FIRE DISTRICT AND
SUSAN TO ROSS.
FROM THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
REMOTE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
POPULAR THING [inaudible]
AND I'VE WORKED.
A FEW MINUTES.
I AM VERY TIRED.
MY NAME IS BOB THEY'RE FREE AND
I AM A RETIRED FIRE CHIEF.
AND I HAVE ALZHEIMER'S AWARENESS
UNIFORM TODAY. TO LET YOU KNOW
THIS DISEASE CAN STRIKE ANYBODY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY SPENT
THEIR WHOLE LIFE.
PUTTING UP PEOPLE'S FIRES.
AND ANYBODY ELSE CAN AND SO THIS
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
I REFUSE TO BE A VICTIM IN THIS
IS TO SEE IF.
I AM HERE TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD.
ADD TO FUND THE REQUEST FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH TO BE INCLUDED IN
EL TIME A SCREENING AND
EDUCATION. TO OUR MEDICAL
COMMUNITIES. TOO FEW WANT TO
DISCUSS EL TIMERS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO CURE.
IT MAY SEEM EASIER TO CURL UP IN
A BALL.
AND WAIT FOR THE INEVITABLE BUT
WITHOUT DISCUSSION ON QUALITY OF
LIFE FAILS.
WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND BE ABLE. FOR AS LONG AS WE
ARE ABLE.
IN THAT WAY THAT WE ARE ALL
WORKING TOWARD A CURE.
I'VE SPENT.
ALMOST FIFTY YEARS IN THE FIRE
SERVICE IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY
CALIFORNIA.
I WAS A CAREER FIREFIGHTER FOR
ALMOST TWENTY OF THOSE YEARS.
AND ARE. FOR THE REST I WAS A
VOLUNTEER.
AFTER ALL THE VOLUNTEER HUMBOLDT
COUNTY.
AFTER ALL.
VOLUNTEERING IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY
IS PRETTY COMMON.
ALL.
WE HAVE ARE.
WE ARE NOT RICH.
COUNTY IN MONEY BUT WE ARE RICH
IN CARING FOR EACH OTHER.
THERE ARE ALWAYS EMERGENCIES
THAT.
BRING IN MANY DOLLARS.
AND VOLUNTEERS FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AS WELL AS OUR USUAL SUPPORT FOR
THE REGULAR.
REGULARLY FUNDING CHARITY EVENTS.
BECAUSE OF HOW MORE COUNTIES
CARING FOR OTHERS ATTITUDE WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DESIGNATE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH. ONE OF THE PILOT
PROGRAMS.
ON HOW THIS WORK IN RURAL AREAS.
AND WHAT CITIES.
PLEASE HELP US LEARN HOW TO
EXTINGUISH THIS FIRESTORM OF A
DISEASE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR A
LISTENING.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE NOBODY KNOWS
WHEN IT'S GOING TO CALL ON THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHIEF.
GOOD AFTERMATHS OF MORRIS
REPRESENTING THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK.
THE AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP
AND MY CONDOLENCES ON THE LOSS
OF YOUR GRANDMOTHER AND TO THE
THREE CO AUTHORS WHO SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE WE THANK YOU AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
YES MY NAME IS MARK QUITE AN
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
VOLUNTEER MY WIFE DIED TWO DAYS.
BEFORE BEFORE THANKSGIVING. ONE
OF THE IMPORTANT CONCEPTS IN
THIS BILL IS EARLY DIAGNOSIS.
TURNS OUT THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY IN YOUR FAMILY THAT HAD
ALZHEIMER'S YOU STILL COULD GET
IT.
IF YOU HAD SOMEBODY IN YOUR
FAMILY THAT HAD IT ONE PERSON
YOU MUCH GREATER CHANCE OF
GETTING IT.
IF YOU HAD MORE THAN ONE IT'S
EVEN GREATER CHANCE SO ALL YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND YOUR FAMILY'S
VERY WELL COULD BENEFIT DIRECTLY
FROM THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST ASK
YOUR NAME AN ORGANIZATION OR
HIGH TIME HOWARD POSENER I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION --
I'VE LOST THREE IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS TO THIS DISEASE AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU.
GOTTEN SHARE MEMBERS ALL OF IRAQ
ROY CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS REPRESENTING BY A COMMON
SUPPORT.
KIM MORE UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI AND JACQUI COLEMAN.
I DO HAVE DEMENTIA.
AND I AM A VOLUNTEER OF A. A. R.
P..
AND WE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIVENS
OF THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FARADAY TING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH A
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM GROSS ABOUT THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF I'LL SEE
I CALIFORNIA ON OUR SEVEN AND
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH SANTOS I'M A STATE AND
CONGRESSIONAL ADVOCATE FOR
DULCIMERS ASSOCIATION I AGE I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE WHO IS
AFFECTED AND WHO CANNOT SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WITH I GUESS --
I'M HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL AS WE KNOW --
I DO TO HAVE A VERY GOOD FRIEND
I'VE HAD A FRIEND PASSED AWAY
FROM THE SAME DISEASE BEING VERY
YOUNG -- AND
IT'S ALL ABOUT AWARENESS IT'S
ALL ABOUT CATCHING IT EARLY IT'S
ALL ABOUT HAVING THE COME TO
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS AND
NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE.
AND BY YOU BRING THIS FOR FOR
ALL OF US THAT ARE IN THIS ROOM.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE
IF WE CAN THAT THEY CAN GO
THROUGH.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT --
MY FRIEND PAM WAS NOT HERE BUT
SHE WOULD BE THE FIRST ONE TO
SAY IF I WOULD HAVE CAUGHT IT
EARLY.
THEY COULD HAVE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS IF I COULD HAVE
HAD DIRECTION HOW MUCH THAT
WOULD HAVE HELPED ME.
AND SHE'S DOING WELL.
BUT YOU KNOW BLESS YOUR HEART
SHE'S LIKE A PHENOMENAL ADVOCATE
SO I'M GLAD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
YOUR BILL.
AND AGAIN I'M SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS.
WHEN I'M STRESSED CARE?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS --
TO THIS COMMITTEE AND I'M ALSO
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR.
OF THIS BILL.
I I OFFER MY CONDOLENCES TO YOU
I KNOW THAT WHAT WHAT THAT'S
LIKE FIRST HAND LOST MY
GRANDMOTHER IN MARCH OF LAST
YEAR. TO DEMENTIA AND TO EARLY
ALZHEIMER'S AND MY FAMILY AND I
ALWAYS THINK.
IF ONLY WE WOULD HAVE CAUGHT IT
EARLY.
IF ONLY WE WOULD HAVE KNOWN THE
SIGN.
AND THAT SPEAKS VOLUMES NOT ONLY
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC AWARENESS BUT
ALSO AWARENESS WITHIN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IN.
LANGUAGE AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
ON WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE THE
DISEASE AND WHAT WE CAN DO EARLY
ON FOR THE LOVE ONE SO GRATEFUL
TO YOU THANK YOU.
SERVICE.
I JUST WANNA A THING THIS LOAN
FOR FOR AUTHORING THIS --
AND IF YOU'D BE SO INCLINED I
WOULD LOVE TO COOPERATE --
IT IS WELL --
BOTH THAT I'VE HAD --
TO GRANDMOTHERS --
NOT FUN NOT FUN FOR ANYONE I
JUST WANTED TO SAY AT TO THE
CHIEF --
THAT'S AMAZING TO SEE.
HOW STRONG --
AND PROUD THAT YOU ARE IN
CONFRONTING CONFRONTING THIS
SUMMER THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AS WELL AND AGAIN THANK YOU --
FOR TO THE AUTHOR FOR ABOUT THE
FOR A THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR LISTENING ARE IN IT THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED.
THANK YOU.
SIR inaudible]
MR.
FOR THANK YOU SUMMER AT CHIEF
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
I CAME OUT THE FIRE SERVICES
WELL.
AND IT'S IT'S REMARKABLE FIFTY
YEARS IN THE SERVICE BATTLING
THIS BATTLE THAT YOU'RE FIGHTING
NOW I'M SURE IT'S PROBABLY ONE
OF TOUGHEST BITES YOU HAD IN
YOUR CAREER.
BUT WE APPLAUD YOUR COURAGE AND
WE LOVE YOU FOR IT THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CNN -- I
WOULD LIKE TO FIRST OF ALL THE
THE BILL --
DOES.
THE BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL.
AS WAS A THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE
CHIEF FOR COME FROM HUMBLE
COUNTY I KNOW I KNOW THAT DRIVE
WELL AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
ELIZABETH I SAW YOU OUT THERE
AND AND TESTIMONY FOR COMING
DOWN -- WITH
TO SUPPORT AS WELL --
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOU
CONSIDER AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
SPECIFYING THAT THAT COUNTIES
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS SERVER LIKE
RURAL COUNTIES --
AND PROTECT AND AND THERE IS
ELIGIBILITY AND AND COASTAL
COUNTY AS WELL --
THAT WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED
HE WOULD CONSIDER THAT GOING.
FOR YES AND I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES A AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE NO
PRESSURE I MEAN SORRY JUST YOU
KNOW.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MA'AM SECRETARY WE HAVE A MOTION --
MODE AT FIVE BY MR MAYES WE HAVE
WE NEED A SECOND.
WE HAVE SECOND WE HAD A SECOND
BUT WELL THAT'S WE HAD A SECOND
ME OKAY --
DID YOU MAKE A MOTION MISTER.
FOR I THINK I DO.
ALL TOGETHER NOW THIS IS A WELL
OILED MACHINE HERE TODAY FOR
SYRIAN SO OKAY I'M THAT I'M
REALLY WELL IT WILL GO THE OF MR
MAYES AS THE MOTION MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY AS THE SECOND.
MAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AYE GEAR CURRY?
CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA ISLA MON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE. TO TO AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. ELEVEN
VOTES MORE THAN ENOUGH TO TO
LEAVE LEAVE THIS OPEN FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ONTO A THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU TEAR WITNESSES
SPECIALLY. FOR THE LONG TRIP
CHIEF THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO WE HAVE TO BILLS REMAINING --
THEIR MIND SO I WILL --
I WILL TAKE --
TAKE OF AN ICE MISTER MAYES TO
TAKE OVER OF TO ADOPT SO --
GROUP COMMITTEE RULES.
AS IT MOVED BY MISS CARILLO
SECOND BY MISTAKE YEAR CURRY.
A MAN SEXUALLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE RULES.
AVOID HI.
WHEN I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY?
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE HI CARILLO
[inaudible]
CARILLO.
HI.
I FLORA FLOOR AYE LIMóN.
I LIVE ON AYE MCCARTY.
THE VARIANT.
RAMOS ROTH IRA RICK I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
TO CHIU I'D [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
IN THE PAST.
I THE RULES OF THE RULES PASSED
CURRENT OPTED FOR ADOPTED.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE --
TO BILLS THAT BEFORE US AB TO A
FOREIGN AB TWO NINETY WHAT'S
YOUR PLEASURE AND TAKE TO A FOR
FIRST OR AT THE PERFECT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
COMMUNITY BENEFITS ARE THE
SERVICES NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
PROVIDE TO TO ADDRESS COMMUNITY
NEEDS AND CAN INCLUDE SERVICES --
PROVIDED TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS CHARITY CARE SUPPORT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
DONATIONS OF FUNDS A RESOURCES
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO A COMMUNITY
PRIORITY.
SUCH AS HOUSING.
CURRENTLY HOSPITAL SUBMIT THE
PLANS ARE SPENT AND I SPENT
REVIEWS THE PLANS TO ENSURE THE
HOSPITALS ARE REPORTING DATA
CONSISTENTLY.
HOWEVER HOSPITAL CHARGES VARY
FROM REGION TO REGION SO THERE
IS NO TRULY STANDARDIZED
REQUIREMENT FOR CALCULATING AND
RECORDING THE VALUE OF COMMUNITY
BENEFITS.
THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
COMMUNITIES TO KNOW THE VALUE OF
THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS BEING
PROVIDED BY THE HOSPITAL IN
EXCHANGE FOR ITS TAX EXEMPT
STATUS.
AB TWO OH FOUR REQUIRES ARE
SPREAD TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS
STANDARDIZING THE CALCULATION
AND REPORTING OF COMMUNITY
BENEFITS. TO REPORT THE AMOUNT
EACH HOSPITAL SINCE THE SPENDS
ON COMMUNITY BENEFITS.
AND AUTHORIZES ARE SPREAD TO
FIND HOSPITALS IT FAILED TO FILE
THEIR COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS.
THE BILL REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO
REPORT THE KEY TO THEIR
COMMUNITY RATHER THAN US A
HOSPITAL SYSTEM.
IS THERE COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS
ON THEIR WEBSITE.
AND APPLY COMMUNITY BENEFIT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO ALL
HOSPITALS THAT ARE A PART OF THE
SYSTEM INCLUDING SMALL AND RURAL
HOSPITALS.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO ASSURE
THAT AS A HOSPITAL SYSTEM MAY
GROW IN SIZE THE INDIVIDUAL
HOSPITALS IN THE SYSTEM REMAIN
MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
I'M WORKING WITH CH A TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS THE ANALYSIS
DESCRIBES AMENDMENTS WELL TAKEN
APPROPRIATIONS TO ADDRESS A
PORTION OF THOSE CONCERNS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH
ME HERE MOVE THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND JDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION
WORKING ON AFFORDABLE AND
QUALITY HEALTHCARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB --
TWO OH FOR JUST REAL FAST HELP
ACCESS CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
SUPPORTED THE STANDARDIZATION OF
COMMUNITY BENEFIT REPORTING --
BUT SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
CALIFORNIA HAS PROHIBITED THIS
PRACTICE AND AB TOOL FOR WHICH
FIX THAT PROBLEM.
WHAT COMMUNITY BENEFITS MAY BE
EXPRESSIONS OF THE HOSPITAL'S
CHARITABLE MISSIONS AND GOAL IT
IS ALSO USED AS JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE HOSPITALS NOW --
TAX EXEMPT STATUS.
AB TOOL FOR ISN'T IMPORTANT
MEASURED THAT INSURERS TAX
EXEMPT PRIVATE NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS ARE PROVING THEIR
WORTH.
AND ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDING
MEASURABLE COMMUNITY BENEFITS TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
SERVE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
AFTER THE ACA WORD THERE ARE
STILL THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WHO REMAIN UNINSURED AND MANY
MORE CALIFORNIANS WERE UNDER
INSURED AND CANNOT AFFORD THEIR
COVERAGE.
THROUGH PREMIUMS AND COST
SHARING FOR THESE REASONS WE
SUPPORT THE BILL AND WE REQUEST
ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK WINDOWS
WITH US HERE YOU CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT GIVEN LAST YEAR'S
TREND OF HOSPITALS REQUESTING
WAIVERS FROM AG BESET US OFFICE
FOR CHECK A CHARITY CARE
CONDITIONS PLACED ON NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL TRANSACTIONS --
BY FORMER AT AG DUE TO A DROP IN
THE UNINSURED RATES THESE WAIVER
REQUEST COME FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CITING LAST NEED.
DUE TO GREATER NUMBERS OF
INSURED THINGS TAKE IN A LOT TO
IMPROVE AND SAVE LIVES THROUGH
NEW AFFORDABLE COVERAGE
OPPORTUNITY SIGNIFICANT NEEDS
CONTINUE TO EXIST. FOR
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS
PARTICULARLY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
SEIU BELIEVES THIS THIS REPORT
ALIGNMENT AND GUIDANCE THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED UNDER EIGHTY
TWO OH FOUR IS LONG OVERDUE FOR
THESE REASONS WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTIE WE SAW
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS IN THE BILL WHICH
ARE REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS --
WE HAVE BEEN HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND STAFF THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND WE ARE OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
OUR CONCERNS.
ARE WE APPRECIATE YOUR DRESSING
ONE OF THOSE WITH ONE OF THE
AMENDMENT TO BE TAKING TING
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ERICA BROWN I AM A
DOCTORAL STUDENT AT THE BERKELEY
SCHOOL PUBLIC HEALTH STUDIES
HOSPITAL COMMUNITY BENEFITS I'M
A FORMER COMMUNITY BENEFIT
MANAGER ALAMEDA.
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
OPPOSITION WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
I JUST WOULD WOULD NOTE THAT --
THIS ACTUALLY CAME TO ME FROM MY
DISTRICT --
AND JUST HOSPITAL ABOUT FOLKS IN
THE COMMUNITY WANTED TO KNOW
ABOUT A HOSPITAL PART OF A LARGE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS.
AND THEY HEAR ALL THE TIME THAT
WE'RE BENEFITING YOUR COMMUTE
THEY JUST WANT TO KNOW AT WHAT
LEVEL YOU BENEFITING OUR
COMMUNITY SO --
IT'S A SIMPLE AS THAT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE MOTION
FROM THE AGAR OCCURRING AND A
SECOND BY CHIU THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE AGAR CURRY?
I CARE CREE AYE BIGELOW.
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LOVE MON.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I TO TO AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
WE HAVE THIRTEEN VOTES --
I BELIEVE BELIEVE IT OPEN. TWO
TWO I'M SORRY STIRS TWELVE
POLITICAL LEAVE IT OPEN AND THEN
ON YOUR NEXT BILL GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAYOR MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB.
TWO NINETY THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU IS NOT A NEW.
ONE AB TWO NINETY IS SIMILAR TO
SB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX OF LAST YEAR
CARRIED BY SENATOR LEYVA.
SENATOR LABORS BILL MADE IT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BUT WAS
VETOED.
IN MY BILL I'VE INCLUDED
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS THE VERY
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THEN
GOVERNOR BROWN.
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS ARE ALREADY
TOO EXPENSIVE FOR MANY PEOPLE
AND WHEN GIMMICKS BY PROVIDERS
ARE USED TO ENSURE THAT
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE HIGHER
THAN THEY SHOULD BE.
IT'S TIME TO DO SOMETHING.
THIS BILL WILL PREVENT PROVIDERS
FROM GAMING THE SYSTEM AS A
MECHANISM TO ARTIFICIALLY
GENERATES THREE TO FOUR TIMES
THE MEDICARE RATE FOR PROVIDING
THE EXACT SAME CARE.
WELL YOU PROBABLY HEARD
ARGUMENTS AND HE EVEN ADDS A%
SCARE PATIENTS ABOUT HOW THE
SYSTEM OF CARE WILL COLLAPSE OR
CLINICS WILL CLOSE.
THE COMMERCIAL MARKET MOVES TO A
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT LEVEL.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT OF A LOOK AT
THIS CAREFULLY AND I QUESTIONED
IT.
I REMAIN UNCONVINCED THAT THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF PATIENTS
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE UNDER THIS
PROGRAM WILL FUNDAMENTALLY
DISRUPT THE CARE THAT PATIENTS
RECEIVE.
THE GAMING OF THE SYSTEM IS
HARMFUL IN MANY WAYS BUT OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN IS HOW IT DRIVES
UP THE COST FOR EVERYONE BY
SHIFTING RISK TO A FRAGILE AND
COSTLY INDIVIDUAL MARKET.
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS IN THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET ARE
INCREASINGLY COSTLY AND THAT
MUST CHANGE THAT'S WHY AUTHORED
A A. B. TWO TO NINETY AS WELL AS
MY OTHER BILL AB ONE SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH PROPOSES SUBSIDIES TO
PROVIDE.
A BROADER NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
MAKE --
PROVIDED SUBSIDIES TO A BROADER
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO MAKE ACA
COVERAGE MORE AFFORDABLE.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT HELPING ABOUT
MAKING THE HEALTHCARE MARKET
WORK WITHOUT UNDUE DISTORTIONS
DRIVEN STRICTLY BY PROFIT
MOTIVATED COMPANIES.
WHY YOU MAY HAVE HEARD ARGUMENTS
IS THIS ISN'T ABOUT PART IT'S IT
IS NOT?
THEIR PROFITS ARE ALREADY HIGHLY
REGULATED AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
LIMITS REIMBURSEMENT FOR ONE
ASPECT OF COVERAGE.
IT DOESN'T RELIEVE INSURANCE
COMPANIES OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO COST --
TO COVER COSTLY DRUG MATT
REGIMENS OR OTHER RELATED
TREATMENT.
AB TWO NINETY PROTECT LEGITIMATE
THIRD PARTY PAYMENT MECHANISMS.
REMOVES THE INCENTIVE PROVIDERS
TO GAME THE SYSTEM AND ESTABLISH
THE SAFEGUARDS TO WHOLE PATIENTS
WHO MAY HAVE INADVERTENTLY BEEN
CAUGHT UP IN ONE OF THESE
PAYMENT SCHEMES HARMLESS.
THE BILL DOES NOT PRECLUDE ANY
ENTITY FROM CONTRIBUTING TO A
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF HELPING A PATIENT TO
PAY FOR THEIR CARE WERE THERE
COVERAGE.
IT ONLY PREVENTS THE ENTITY FROM
INCREASING THEIR PROFITS BY
MAKING THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS.
WHETHER THEY CONTINUE TO MAKE
THESE CONTRIBUTIONS MAYBE THE
REAL INDICATION OF WHETHER THE
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE ABOUT PATIENTS.
OR ABOUT PROFITS.
HERE IN SUPPORT WITH ME TODAY
STEPHANIE WATKINS OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LIFE AND
INSURANCE COMPANIES.
AND SERRA FLOCKS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION --
OUR AFFILIATES NEGOTIATE FOR AND
PURCHASE HEALTH BENEFITS ON
BEHALF OF TWO MILLION UNIVERSE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE FEELING THE IMPACTS
OF THE SCHEME THAT DOCTOR WOULD
DESCRIBED --
WHICH IS UNNECESSARY THERE'S A
FEW PROVIDERS IN THE STATE THAT
ARE EXPLOITING THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT. TO CHARGE HIGHER
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FEELING IT --
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE WAS A
LEADING DIALYSIS COMPANY THAT
HAD A DISCLOSURE THAT FOUR
THOUSAND OF THEIR PATIENTS WE'RE
GETTING CHARITABLE PREMIUM MAKE --
ASSISTANCE FROM THE A. K. F. TO
COVER THEIR GROUP COVERAGE THEIR
COBRA OR THE THE PLAN THAT THEIR
EMPLOYER PROVIDE IT.
THAT MEANS THAT THERE ARE FOUR
THOUSAND PATIENTS WHOSE
EMPLOYERS ARE PAYING AN
ARTIFICIALLY INFLATED RATE FOR
THEIR DIALYSIS CARE.
THAT MEANS THERE ARE FOUR
THOUSAND WORKERS WHO ARE ALSO
HAVING TO COVER THE COST OF THAT
CARE UNNECESSARILY.
WHEN THAT GETS BUILT INTO THEIR
PREMIUMS THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
DRIVES UP THE COST OF CARE IT
TAKES MONEY OUT OF THE POCKETS
OF WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IS UNNECESSARY?
AB TWO NINETY IS A BILL THAT WE
CAN USE THAT WILL PROTECT
PATIENTS AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET THE CARE THEY NEED.
BUT A LIMóN EIGHT WHAT IS
BASICALLY WASTE IN THE SYSTEM.
AND SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE FOUR THOUSAND PATIENTS ARE
STILL GETTING THE CARE THEY NEED
BUT THEY'RE NOT TAKING MONEY OUT
OF THE POCKETS OF WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ANY WALK INS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
FIRST WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND FOR THE MEMBERS AND ALL THE
TIME THAT WE SPENT WITH A LOT OF
YOU TRYING TO EXPLAIN --
WHAT THIS DOES TO THE SYSTEM AND
HOW IT REALLY HARMS PREMIUM
PAYERS AND I'D I'D FIRST LIKE TO
START UP WITH SAYING THAT AND NO
WAY -- IS
THIS BILL INTENDED TO DISPARAGE
THE GOOD WORKS OF NON PROFITS I
THINK WE ALL SEE A ROLE FOR THEM
TO PLAY IN IT CERTAINLY.
ONE THAT WE SUPPORT
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
A SMALL SUBSET OF PROVIDERS.
USING THE GUARANTEED ISSUE --
PROVISIONS THAT WERE ESTABLISHED
IN THE A. C. THE SHIFT PEOPLE
FROM OTHERWISE BE MEDICARE
MEDICAID ELIGIBLE INTO
COMMERCIAL ALLIANCE OF COVERAGE.
AND WHAT THAT REALLY DOES IS IT
NOT ONLY PUTS THAT PATIENT AT
RISK IN SOME SENSES BECAUSE TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU'RE
ON A COMMERCIAL PLAN EVEN A PPO
PLATINUM PLAN YOU MAY BE --
HAVE TO PAY OTHER COPAYS
COINSURANCE MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE INCREDIBLY SICK THEY HAVE
COMORBIDITIES THEY OFTEN END UP
IN THE HOSPITAL WITH THAT COMES
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF EXTRA
COSTS THAT THEY MAY NOT
NECESSARILY UNDERSTAND OR EXPECT.
I THINK THE OTHER THING IS IS
THAT WE'VE TRIED REALLY HARD
WITH THIS BILL TO THREAD A
NEEDLE OF PROTECTING THOSE
FORMAL PATIENTS AND ALLOWING
THESE NONPROFIT.
IF IF IT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE PATIENT TO ACTUALLY PAY
THEIR PREMIUMS BUT WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE ON THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE PATIENT AND
NOT BASED ON THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE PROVIDER.
AND SO WE'VE WE'VE TRIED TO DO
IS TAKE OUT THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE OF THAT AND LIKE
DOCTOR WOULD MENTIONED WE ALSO
PUT IN PROVISIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THIS IS NO WAY TO DO UNDER
WRITING THIS IS IN A WAY TO
SHIFT PEOPLE OFF OF OUR ROLES.
THIS IS SIMPLY A WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE BEING SUPPORTED WHO ARE
BEING SPONSORED TRULY UNDERSTAND
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THE PRODUCT
THEY'RE ON THEY THEY ARE COVERED
FOR A FULL TWELVE MONTHS OF THE
PLAN YEAR.
THAT THE PLANS ARE NOTIFIED WHEN
THIS HAPPENS WHEN THERE IS A
THIRD OF FINANCIALLY INTERESTED
THIRD PARTY PAYER.
AND ALSO LASTLY THAT WE DO YOU
ADDRESS THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
TO ENSURE THAT.
THOSE WHO WERE WHO WERE ADVISING
CONSULTING AND HELPING THESE
PATIENTS ARE DOING IT OUT OF THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE PATIENT AND
NOT BECAUSE THERE'S A FINANCIAL
INTEREST TO THEM.
AND A PERFECT EXAMPLE AS MANY OF
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR IS
HIGHLIGHTED THAT.
BECAUSE THEY ARE COMMISSION BASE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE ADVISING PEOPLE
IN THE BEST INTEREST IF SOMEONE
WAS OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDIC
HOW THAT CHOSE TO BE IN A
COMMERCIAL PLAN.
THAT AGENT OR BROKER DIDN'T
RECEIVE A COMMISSION BASED ON
THAT TO ENSURE THAT THEY WERE
REALLY ADVISING PEOPLE BASED ON
THEIR OWN PERSONAL AND BEST
INTERESTS.
AND REALLY WE'VE TRIED REALLY
HARD TO WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS
AND WITH THE WITH THE DOCTOR
WOULD TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL STRIKE THAT BALANCE AND
PROTECTS WONDERFUL PATIENTS
WHILE ALSO.
ENSURING THE INTEGRITY OF THE
SYSTEM GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU THINK WE GOT ABOUT A
MILLION HALF LEFT.
HI JOAN ALLEN WITH US YEAH YOU
UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS HERE
TO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM VALDERRAMA
WITH THE WHITEMAN GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THIS YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
M. JDS ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SHARIF ALI DIALYSIS PATIENT I'M
A SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
NICK LOUISA'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CARL SUPPORT OF A BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
JOANNE CAMPBELL ON BEHALF OF LA
KAREN SUPPORT.
THE AND CHECK ON THE OFF THE
HELP THAT CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
WELLNESS IN SUPPORT.
ADRIAN GARCIA FROM FRESNO THREE
YEAR DIALYSIS PATIENT IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME COULD SOLO EXIA.
AND SOBER IN.
I BE TWO NINE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EMAIL GONZALEZ --
FATHER'S BEEN ANALYSIS TWENTY
ONE YEARS I'VE BEEN A DOUBTS IS
WORKING FOR FIVE YEARS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI.
MALINA IN --
BEING HERE AND THANK ROOM.
NASA BEACH IN FORT [inaudible]
EIGHT YEARS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS MAGELLAN
HANFORD I'M A DIALYSIS NURSE
I'VE BEEN A DALLAS NURSE FOR
NINETEEN YEARS AND I'VE SEEN
THIS.
I'VE SEEN THIS SCAM --
FULLY IN FULL EFFECT ON THE
DALLAS IS FLOOR AND IT IS A SCAM
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE --
THAT WE STOP THIS THANK YOU THIS
JUST AS A REMINDER INITIATIVE
SAID THIS JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION AND THEN
YOUR POSITION WITH YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION YES MY NAME IS AND
I'M MORE ITEM FOR VENTURA AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND IS A BILL.
TO NINETY THANKS.
MY NAME IS WHAT I LOOK AT DAIS
I'M A DIALYSIS NURSE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS ROBERT BEEN WAIVER
DALLAS IS PATIENT AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE LAW AB.
TWO NINETY THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS AS
ROBUST SEE I'M OF THE HOUSES
WORKER IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA BRADY --
OUT DIALYSIS WORKER FROM
INTERRUPT COUNTY AND I'M THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GIVEN PLANET DIALYSIS NURSE OR
STOCKTON HAMMOND SUPPORT.
PATRICIA HERRERA FROM LOS GATOS
I'M IN A HUMAN TECH AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SHUTTLE CHAO'S IMPATIENT
DIALYSIS.
SENATORS APPROVED BILL.
THE ONE THAT IS HE HAVING LITTLE
LIKE CALIFORNIA.
THE SURPLUS INTO THE LIST.
WHAT IS THE WHAT THE PAULA HI
THERE [inaudible]
THOSE CRESCENTA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA THE MAIN
GUESS -- THE
I AM THAT I'M FRESNO.
AND A BILLION HAVE BOTH MOM AND
ELIZABETH MAN AND I'M FOR FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPOSE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MONEY JOSE VEDA
I'M A DAUGHTER OF A DIALYSIS
PATIENT AS SHE ATTENDS THE B.
DOWN LOS ANGELES AND I IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO NINETY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LORRAINE LEWIS AND
I AM SUPPORT IN APPROVED THIS
BILL I AM A DIALYSIS PATIENT I
HAVE BEEN ONE FOR SEVEN YEARS
WITH THE BEAT IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL.
A GENTLE TO LOCAL FOR PARAMOUNT
CALIFORNIA I'M A PATIENT I
SUPPORT AB.
TWO NINETY MY NAME IS TO SET THE
MEN ARE AMONG OUR GUESTS THIS
PATIENT HAVE FROM POP IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I SUPPORT AB --
SIXTY TO NINETY THE NUMBER IF IT
WORKED JUST FIVE ASKING FOR US
INTO THE ALLEY SIZZLING LITTLE
SCIENTISTS.
BUT UP WE ASK.
THAT IS Vì TOTALING. SIX SEVEN
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHARON BROOKS BOYD
AND I SUPPORT CENTER AB.
TWO NINETY MY NAME IS TOM MAYES
I'M FROM --
LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
YOLANDA VILLANUEVA I SUPPORT AB.
TWO NINETY I LOST A LOVED ONE
DUE TO IT SO.
WE NEED WE NEED TO GET CONTROL.
YOU CAN HELP US WITH THAT PASSED
THE TWO NINETY WE CAN.
GET THIS HEALTHCARE UNDER
CONTROL.
THE BUT IN THE END THE FIFTH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS RELENTLESS MINE
WHICH THEY SAY ARE YOU WE WHICH
ARE YOU I AM IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW BUT THERE'S CRISTINA
CASTELL --
SO IF I MEDIA THEY IT WILL PASS
INTO THE ALLEY SEES THAT THERE
SAID THAT IF THE ANNUAL EAT UP
ALL YOUR LACK OF THE THE
SCANDALS NO IN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE ANY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE.
I'M SORRY OF SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE --
AND BRING UP THOSE --
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR WILL HAVE THREE
WITNESSES THE DAY BUT WE WILL
STAY WITHIN THE SIX MINUTES HAVE
A GREAT
.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME'S
MICHAEL ARNOLD I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DIALYSIS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWO NINETY I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
SAY HOW MUCH RESPECT WE HAVE FOR
CHAIRMAN WOULD.
HE HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL TO THE
DIALYSIS COMMUNITY ON MANY PAST
OCCASIONS --
AND WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
FACT.
HOWEVER.
WE FEAR THAT THERE WILL BE MANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
ARISING FOR PATIENTS FROM THE
ENACTMENT OF AB.
TWO NINETY ON BEHALF OF OF BOTH.
NOT FOR PROFIT AND FOR PROFIT
DIALYSIS PROVIDERS THAT OPERATES
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY CLINICS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SEE SEVENTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO AB.
TWO NINETY I WILL SUMMARIZE OUR
OUR OBJECTIONS AND WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST AB TWO NINETY
COULD JEOPARDIZE.
THE VARIABILITY.
OF VULNERABLE LOW INCOME
PATIENTS TO RECEIVE TERRIBLE
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE.
ACCORDING TO THE LETTER FILED
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
BY THE AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND AND
I QUOTE IF AB TWO NINETY IS
PASSED IT WILL QUICKLY FORCE IT
QUE OF TO STOP HELPING LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
KIDNEY FAILURE.
ACCORDING TO THE A. K. F. A. B.
TWO NINETY WOULD PUT THE A. K.
F. OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
GUIDANCE.
RATHER THAN RISK THE ENTIRE
NATION WIDE PATIENT BASE THAT
THEY SERVE.
THEY WERE CLEAR THAT THEY'D
LIKELY STOP PROVIDING ASSISTANCE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT MEANS AB TWO NIGHT
IMMEDIATELY PUTS AT RISK PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE FOR NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND PATIENTS THE MAJORITY
OF THESE PATIENTS ARE MINORITY.
AND ALMOST ALL OF THEM ARE LOW
INCOME.
AB TWO NINETY AS A GIFT TO THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
WITH NO REQUIREMENTS THAT
INSURERS PASS ON ANY OF THE
SAVINGS.
IT ALLOWS INSURERS TO ME THE
MEDICARE RATE. FOR PATIENTS ON
JOURNAL PREMIUM ASSISTANCE.
WHICH IS BELOW THE COST OF CARE.
AB TWO NINETY COULD JEOPARDIZE
ACCESS FOR ALL PATIENTS. 90% OF
THE PATIENTS.
ON DIALYSIS.
HAVE INSURANCE FUNDED BY THE
GOVERNMENT THAT DOES NOT PAY THE
COST OF CARE.
IF WE START REDUCING PAYMENTS
FOR A PORTION OF THE REMAINING
10% PATIENTS ON PRIVATE PAY.
IT DISRUPTS THE ENTIRE ECO
SYSTEM JEOPARDIZING THE
FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF CLINICS.
WELL PROVIDERS WOULD WORK HARD
TO PREVENT CLINIC CLOSURES AND
CUTBACKS.
DIALYSIS PROVIDERS ARE ALREADY
SLOWING FUTURE EXPANSION PLANS
IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE
CONSTANT ATTACK BY INSURERS AND
OTHER SPECIAL INTERESTS.
IT TAKES ABOUT FIVE YEARS.
FROM THE IDEA TO GET A DIALYSIS
CLINIC ON LINE AND OPERATING.
THE DEMAND FOR DIALYSIS IS
GROWING IN CALIFORNIA AT 5% PER
YEAR OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
WE WILL NEED AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DIALYSIS
CLINICS.
IF AB TWO AND IDEAS PASSED
PATIENTS IN THE FUTURE WILL HAVE
A HARDER TIME GETTING CONVENIENT
ACCESS TO THE TREATMENT THEY
NEED. THREE DAYS A WEEK FOUR
HOURS OF TIME. FOR THESE AND
OTHER REASONS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL.
KELLY BEING HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING MORE
THAN FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
PHYSICIAN MEMBERS INCLUDING
HUNDREDS OF MEDICAL DIRECTORS
THAT OVERSEE PATIENT KEREN
DIALYSIS CLINICS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
OUR MEMBERS HAVE EXPRESSED
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH AB.
TWO NINE ZERO AB TWO NINE ZERO
IS FUNDAMENTALLY A RATE SETTING
BILL FOR PRIVATE INSURANCE
PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS.
IT SETS REIMBURSEMENTS THAT THE
MEDICARE RATE WHICH MICHAEL
MENTIONED THIS BLOW THE COST OF
CARE.
WE ARE CONCERNED THE BILL WILL
CREATE LONG TERM ACCESS ISSUES
FOR PATIENTS LIKE RENEE HERE.
NEW CLINIC GROWTH HAS ALREADY
SLOWED BY AS MUCH AS ONE THIRD
DEPENDING ON THE PROVIDER.
WITHOUT RELIABLE ACCESS TO LIFE
SAVING TREATMENT DIALYSIS
PATIENTS WILL END UP IN IMPACT
OF HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOMS
LIKELY WITH ADDITIONAL HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS.
THIS WILL BE A MUCH HIGHER COST
TO THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAN
THE SAVINGS THIS BILL REALIZE
FOR EVERYONE. FOR THESE REASONS
CMA'S IN OPPOSITION TO AB
[inaudible]
TWO NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
THE WE GOT JUST ABOUT TWO
MINUTES GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS RENEE BLUE I CAME HERE TODAY
FROM AUBURN.
I AM A DAYLIGHT DIALYSIS PATIENT
AND I GET HELP FROM THE AMERICAN
KIDNEY FUND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON AB.
TWO NINETY I CRASHED INTO
DIALYSIS IN JULY.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
HOSPITAL IMMEDIATELY ME STARTED
ME ON DIALYSIS AND THEN TWO
WEEKS LATER I LEFT THE HOSPITAL
AND STARTED OUTPATIENT DIALYSIS.
I HOPE TO EVENTUALLY GO BACK TO
WORK BUT AS OF NOW I AM UNABLE
TO DO SO.
I WAS AN HR DIRECTOR OF MY
EMPLOYER.
TO AND THE PHYSICAL MENTAL
EMOTIONAL CHALLENGES THAT COME
WITH DIALYSIS TREATMENTS BUT
THEY HAD TO LET ME GO BECAUSE I
COULD ONLY WORK TWO DAYS A WEEK.
AND THEY NEEDED SOMEBODY FULL
TIME I WAS ON COBRA BUT IT RAN
OUT.
I NEED TO CONTINUE WITH MY
CURRENT HEALTH PLAN BECAUSE I
WANTED TO KEEP THE SPECIALISTS.
WHO ARE TREATING A BLOOD DISEASE
THAT I HAVE I WAS ALSO EXPOSED
TO HEPATITIS C.?
I HAVE FIVE OTHER DOCTORS
BESIDES MY NOW FOR ALL AGES AND
EVERY WEEK I HAVE ONE OR TWO
DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS.
IN ADDITION TO MY THREE TIMES A
WEEK DIALYSIS TREATMENTS.
WITH CHARITABLE PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE I AM ABLE TO KEEP MY
INSURANCE AND MY PREMIUM IS PAID.
FOR THE BEST THING IS PEACE OF
MIND KNOWING I CAN KEEP MY
HEALTH COVERAGE.
AND THE DOCTORS WHO ARE TREATING
MY OTHER HEALTH ISSUES.
WITHOUT THE AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WOULD HAVE
DONE.
I AM NOW ABLE TO PAY MY BILLS
AND HOUSING.
I READ THE LETTER FROM THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND OPPOSING
THIS BILL THEY SAID IF THIS
PASSES THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA.
HERE'S A QUOTE FROM THEIR LETTER
IF IN LOW INCOME DIALYSIS AND
TRANSPLANT PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA NO MATTER WHAT KIND
OF INSURANCE THEY HAVE.
MEDICARE OR PRIVATE THAT SCARES
ME.
AND I'M SURE IT WILL SCARE
OTHERS WHEN THEY HEAR THIS THE
WAY I SEE IT.
AB TWO NINETY HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES BUT HURTS PATIENTS
LIKE ME.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY INSURANCE
COMPANY PROFITS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT TO THE WELL.
THEN THE WELFARE OF DIALYSIS
PATIENTS.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB.
TWO NINETY THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND WILL GO TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATION THAT POSITION.
ALSO SHE ASIAN CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
BELIEVE IF ONE DOES HERE ON
BEHALF OF PERCENT AS MEDICAL
CARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN FANS ALL
ON BEHALF OF DEFEAT --
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ERIN LEAVE I AM I HAVE A
SATELLITE HEALTHCARE POST.
PETER TELL US ON BEHALF OF THE
U. S. RENAL CARE WHICH IS
CONSIDERED A MODERATE SIZED
FACILITY IN THE STATE HAS --
FORTY THREE FACILITIES ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SUZANNE DOLAN REGISTERED NURSE --
IN DIALYSIS FOR NINE YEARS
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
HAS SHOWN HOW DUMB FROM ROCKLAND
AND I OPPOSE THIS.
HEY GLORIA FROM SUTTER COUNTY
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SERGIO MORELLI FROM THE SAME
MIGUEL CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
CAROLINE --
RODRIGUEZ MARTINEZ AND RONALD
FOSTER WE OPPOSE THIS BILL ME
QUESTOR NO VOTE.
I HAVE THOUGHT TO LETTER FROM
THEM THANK YOU YEP SERGEANT.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARGARITA SO
YOU TO AND I WORK FOR FOR SYDNEY
AS WOODLAND EIGHTEEN YEARS.
I'M ALSO A PATIENT OF A PASS
KIDNEY PATIENT AND I OPPOSE AB
TWO NINETY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELO WAIT MEN
I'M A DIALYSIS CARE GIVER FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS CURRENTLY
WORKING FOR FOR SENIORS WOODLAND
AND I OPPOSE AB TWO NINETY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL LONG.
SACRAMENTO FOURTEEN YEARS
PATIENT CARE TECHNICIAN AYE
OPPOSED.
TO NINETY JORDAN GROSSMAN
VENTURA COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CHRISTY CAPRI FROM WHAT I
CALIFORNIA --
PATIENT CARE TECHNICIAN FOR OVER
NINETEEN YEARS AND I OPPOSE.
KERRY GREEN FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE AB.
TWO NINETY GREAT ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NOW WILL COME BACK ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
YES I AGREE --
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD --
BRING THIS FORWARD IN SHINING A
LIGHT ON IT THAT I HADN'T
THOUGHT ABOUT BEFORE BUT SO HOW
MUCH MONEY WE'RE TALKING HERE.
I'M HONESTLY NOT QUITE SURE --
I THINK THAT --
THIS IS AN INDUSTRY THAT MAKES
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PATIENTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SEVENTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS GET TREATMENT FOUR
THOUSAND GET SOME ASSISTANCE
THROUGH THE AMERICAN KIDNEY FINE
FOR THE YEAH A CALF --
HALF OF THOSE --
HELPING WITH THEIR MEDICARE --
MEDICARE ADVANTAGE --
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THE OTHER
HALF GET THE THE PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE SO IN ESSENCE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE HERE --
WHICH HOW MUCH MONEY IS GOING TO
SAVE DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA.
SHE SHE MIGHT THANK YOU I DON'T
HAVE IT SORRY I KNOW IT'S A GOOD --
IN THE MOST RECENT QUARTERLY
ANALYST CALL DIVVIED UP WHICH
REPRESENTS HALF OF THE MARKET
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR DIALYSIS
CLINICS.
INFORM SHAREHOLDERS THAT THE
IMPACT OF AB TWO NINETY
SPECIFICALLY WOULD BE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
IN PROFIT FOR DA VIDA SO
EXTRAPOLATING THAT OUT IF THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY WERE TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN AN EQUAL AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE
A HIGH END OF EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN DIALYSIS INDUSTRY
PROFIT.
BY COMPARISON THE DIALYSIS
INDUSTRY MADE MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROFIT IN CALIFORNIA.
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN A ON THE
SAVINGS TO THE ENTIRE MARKET GO
WELL BEYOND THAT EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE THE OTHER
LOSSES FOR ODD THAT INSURANCE
PLANS.
EXPERIENCE WHEN THESE PATIENTS
GO TO HOSPITALS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS THE
DIALYSIS INDUSTRY IS NOT THE
ONLY GROUP PARTICIPATING IN THIS.
WE SEE THIS PRACTICE IN
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER CLINICS
AS WELL FOR THEIR FAN VERY HIGH
LOSSES EXPERIENCED BY PLANS.
SO WILL THE PATIENT SEES SAVINGS
RATE PAYERS WITH REPAIRS EXCUSE
ME THE REPAIR SEE A SAVINGS.
THAT WOULD YES GIVEN THE MEDICAL
LOSS RATIO REQUIREMENTS.
HERE IN IN BOTH NATIONALLY AND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
A SAVINGS EXPERIENCED BY PLANS
WOULD THEN BE.
CONSIDERED LOWER CLAIMS BY --
BY PLANTS AND WITHOUT STEPHANIE
GO FURTHER.
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED VERY ROBUST
RATE REVIEW AND AM ALL OUR
REQUIREMENTS WE ALSO DO
DISCLOSURES SPA AND LARGE GROUP
FILINGS SO WITH THOSE YOU WOULD
SEE.
IF YOU SAW DIRECTORS OLD AND
REDUCTION OF CLAIMS THAT WOULD
BE COOL THEN TO WITHIN OUR RATE
REVIEW PROCESS THE REGULATOR
WOULD LOOK AT THAT WOULD REDUCE
WE BELIEVE PREMIUMS TO BOTH RATE
PAYERS AND CONSUMERS.
AND THEN YOU WOULD ALSO SEE --
AS A PART OF THAT I THINK ONE OF
MY PLANS HAS IDENTIFIED THIS AS
POTENTIALLY A 1% INCREASE IN
PREMIUMS.
I ALSO HAVE ANOTHER PLAN SIMILAR
TO THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE THAT --
WE USE AN EXAMPLE AS OF ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF UNDER WRITTEN PREMIUM
THAT WAS THE TOTAL THAT THEY
COLLECTED TO TO COVER FROM
MATERNITY. TO CANCER TREATMENT
TO PREVENT IT IS FACE IN A
SINGLE YEAR.
SO WITH THAT KIND OF GIVES YOU
THE REASON WHY THIS IS SUCH A
HUGE IMPACT TO THE SYSTEM AND TO
RATE PAYERS.
I THINK OUR GOAL ALL HERE'S WERE
VERY PRICE SENSITIVE AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT TO THE
DEGREE WE CAN IDENTIFY AREAS
WHERE THERE IS MANIPULATION OF
THE SYSTEM --
WE WANT TO BRING IT TO FOCUS
ATTENTION AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
REAL PEOPLE IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
THAT ARE TRYING TO PAY FOR
HEALTH INSURANCE AND ARE
STRUGGLING AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE THOUGHTFUL AND
SENSITIVE TO THAT.
HELLO QUITE SENSITIVE TO THIS
BECAUSE WE RURAL AREAS THE LAST
THING I WANT TO SEE IS AXIS --
DIMINISHED I'VE BEEN TOLD PRETTY
CLEARLY THAT TAXES WOULDN'T BE
DIMINISHED.
AND SO I'M SITTING HERE
WONDERING YOU KNOW THIS COST
SHIFT WHERE WARY REALLY GOING
WITH THIS I MEAN WHO IS IT
REALLY GOING TO BENEFIT --
IT REALLY AT THE LOWER RATES ARE
WE GOING TO MAKE SURE BENEFIT
OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES --
THERE'S SO MANY QUESTIONS STILL
HERE BECAUSE I DO FEEL LIKE
WE'RE KIND OF GOING.
WAS A GAME WE HIT THE BALL IT
OVER HERE.
AND SO -- I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RE HAVE ARE PEOPLE TAKING CARE
OF AND THE CONUNDRUM FOR ME
RIGHT NOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I CAN COMMENT ON
THAT IF YOU WOULD LIKE ME --
TO ONE OF ONE OF THE MAJOR
DRIVING.
FACTORS THAT CREATES THIS
PROBLEM IS THE FINANCING FOR
DIALYSIS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE MEDICARE SYSTEM REIMBURSES
AT A RATE THAT IS LESS THAN.
THE COST OF THE DIALYSIS
TREATMENT. FOR THOSE PATIENTS
WHO ARE MEDI CAL ONLY AND IN
PARTICULAR --
THE THE UNDOCUMENTED PATIENTS
WHO ARE ON EMERGENCY MEDICAL.
THAT REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS ONLY
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
OR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
PER TREATMENT THE MEDICARE RATE
IS TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER.
PER TREATMENT AVERAGE.
SO YOU CAN SEE THAT IF WE HAVE A
MEDI CAL PATIENTS. THREE TIMES A
WEEK WE'RE LOSING SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF DOLLARS TO TREAT THAT PATIENT
AND SO. ONE OR TWO PATIENTS IN A
DIALYSIS CLINIC TO TAKE USUALLY
IN THE RURAL AREAS OR IN THE
URBAN CORE WELL WE HAVE A LOT OF
UNINSURED PATIENTS A LOT OF MEDI
CAL PATIENTS.
CAN MAKE THE DIFFERENCE.
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THAT CLINIC.
HE CAN REMAIN OPEN --
OR WILL NOT REMAIN OPEN OR LET'S
LET'S SAY THEY HAVE REVENUES IN
EXCESS OF THEIR EXPENSES.
UNDER THE CURRENT STRUCTURE.
OUR COMPANIES THE NOT FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES AND THE FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES CAN USE SOME OF THE
MONEY THAT THEY MAKE IN OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE. TO SUPPORT
THE IN THE CLINICS IN YOUR
DISTRICT FRANKLY.
UP UNDER THIS BILL THEY WOULD
LOSE THOSE.
PATIENTS THAT --
BEING REIMBURSED AT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR RATES.
WHICH I THOUGHT I MUST ALSO SAY
ME YOUR BUSINESS PLAN I'M JUST
YEAH I WAS QUESTION NOT.
NONE OF THAT'S FINE YOUR
BUSINESS PLAN PIE TAKES IT INTO
CONSIDERATION DOESN'T IT I MEAN
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE SO MANY
THAT ARE GOING TO BE MAYBE
UNDOCUMENTED SOME YOU CAN BE
MEDICARE I MEAN.
THERE'S A FORMULA THAT YOU.
THERE IS AN EXISTING STRUCTURE.
THAT THAT THIS BILL WOULD TEAR
APART.
CAN WE CHANGE INSTRUCTION.
WELL WE CAN WE CAN INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES UNDER THE
MEDI CAL PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE
ONE IMPORTANT FIRST STEP --
TO TAKE AND IT.
YOU KNOW IT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM
WE THOUGHT A WHOLE LOT ABOUT.
THIS YEAR'S BILL AND AND WE
DON'T WANT TO OPPOSE THE CHAIRS
BILL BUT WE SEEM WE FEEL THAT WE
JUST HAVE NO CHOICE BASED ON THE
PATIENTS AND THE REAL ISSUE IS
THAT.
WE'RE CREATING I MEAN BASED UPON
ALL OF THE DIFFICULTIES WE'VE
HAD OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
THE DIALYSIS PROVIDERS.
OR LOOKING AT BUILDING
FACILITIES NOT IN CALIFORNIA
ANYMORE BUT THEY'RE BUILDING
THEM IN.
OTHER STATES --
AND SO WE REALLY I MEAN I THINK
OR OR ARE --
PROVIDERS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO KEEP CLINICS OPEN I DON'T I
DON'T SEE ANY ANY CLINICS THAT
ARE GONNA CLOSE AUTOMATICALLY
BUT YOU KNOW YOU NEVER KNOW I
CAN NEVER I CAN ASSURE THAT.
BUT WE THINK THEY CAN KEEP THEM
OPEN HOWEVER.
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A TICKING
TIME BOMB WHERE.
COMPANIES ARE NOT GOING TO SPEND
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA SO FIVE
SIX SEVEN YEARS FROM NOW.
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS? FOR
ALL OF THE DIALYSIS PATIENTS AND
BY THE WAY OUR POPULATION
CALIFORNIA IS A MISTRIAL IN A
YEAR I THINK YOU'VE ANSWERED
MISS AYE GARCIA CURRY'S QUESTION
GIVE ANOTHER QUESTION.
DID YOU WANT TO ANSWER AYE AYE
YEAH I'D LIKE I'D LIKE TO DRESS
I'D LIKE TO DRESS UP ON ON A
COUPLE OF LEVELS FIRST OF ALL.
I THINK WE'VE HEARD THAT THE
PROFIT FOR DIALYSIS COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
IF WE USE THE THE NUMBERS THAT
WE HER PROFIT OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE.
SO I DON'T SEE HOW THAT.
STILL PROFITABLE FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS LEADS TO
THE CLOSURE OF OF CLINICS I
DON'T AYE AYE THAT NO ONE HAS
REALLY EXPLAIN THAT TO ME.
AS FAR AS THE EXPANSION PLANS --
FOR THE FUTURE CMS IN IN
WASHINGTON IS LOOKING AT THE
COST OF DIED OF DELIVERING
DIALYSIS CARE IS ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT OTHER WAYS OF
PROVIDING CARE TO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE END STAGE RENAL DISEASE.
THAT MAY NOT INVOLVE --
DIALYSIS AND ALSO I BELIEVE WE
OUGHT TO BE REALLY FOCUSING ON
HOW WE GET MORE PEOPLE TO
TRANSPLANTS.
KIDNEY TRANSPLANTS MAKING SURE
THEY KNOW THEIR OPTIONS UP FRONT
EARLY ON BECAUSE TRANSPLANTS.
SAVE LIVES.
YOU CAN EVEN YOU HAVE TO YOU
COULD GET OUT MUCH HEALTHIER
LIFE FOR FOR TEN OR MORE YEARS --
FROM A KIDNEY TRANSPLANT AT A
READ AT A STATE A SIMILAR COST
OR EVEN LESS THAN WHAT WE WENT
WITH THE WITH DIALYSIS AND THAT
PERSON WOULD NOT HAVE.
TO HAVE TO BE HAVE TREATMENT
THREE TIMES A WEEK SO SO THERE
ARE OTHER THINGS AT PLAY HERE
AND SO AS FAR AS THE FUTURE
EXPANSION PLANS SOME OF THAT I
BELIEVE IS BEING DRIVEN BY THE
FACT THAT CMS IS LOOKING.
AT ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF DOING
TREATMENT --
IN HONG KONG FOR EXAMPLE 70% OF
THE PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE DIALYSIS
RECEIVE IT AT HOME.
NOT IN A CLINIC AND THERE ARE
MANY OTHER EXAMPLES OF WAYS THE
WAY THE TREATMENT OF END STAGE
RENAL DISEASE IS CHANGING AND
AND IN THE UNITED STATES AND
ACROSS THE AND THAT'S AND THAT
SO I BELIEVE THAT HAS A HAS A
FACTOR OF WHY THESE ARE.
THESE THESE PLANS THESE
EXPANSION PLANS MAY BE SLOWING
DOWN.
AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY GOOD
TO SOME MEMBER --
CARILLO AND THEN TO SOME OF OUR
WORK.
FORGET IT TURNED THE SUN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU --
I HAVE TWENTY NINE PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT --
RECEIVE HERBAL PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE FOR THEIR DIALYSIS
TREATMENT WHO EXPRESSED CONCERN
FOR LAST YEAR'S BILL BUT HOPE
FOR A RESOLUTION --
THE BILL PREVIOUS BILL WENT
PASSED BOTH HOUSES THE CAPITAL
BY THE GOVERNOR. TO BE QUITE
FRANK SOME ARE QUITE HAPPY ABOUT
THAT -- SO
MY COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS TO
DATE ARE WITH THEM IN MIND AS
WELL AS THE HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES LOW
INCOME.
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO GENERALLY
LACK ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
AND IN GRATITUDE TOWARDS THE
WORKERS THAT ARE HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE AND THANK
YOU TO THE WITNESS I DID I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T CATCH YOUR NAME.
FOR COMING AND TESTIFYING.
RENEE THANK YOU MY AUNT --
RECEIVES DIALYSIS AND I KNOW HOW
TIRED SHE IS AFTER RECEIVING HER
TREATMENT.
SO -- I WANT
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF A PROFIT.
SO IF DIALYSIS CLINICS CLAIM
THAT 10% OF THEIR PATIENTS
COVERED BY COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS EFFECTIVELY SUBSIDIZE.
THE REMAINING 90% BY MEDICARE
HOW WILL CAPPING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AT A LOWER
COST AND THE SERVICES RENDERED
ARE WORTH OR BENEFIT CONSUMERS
IN GENERAL THAT'S ONE
ADDITIONALLY.
UNDER THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS MOST RECENT TAX
REFUNDS HEALTH CARE SERVICES
CORPORATION WHICH IS THE PARENT
COMPANY TO BLUESHIELD RECEIVED A
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
TAX REFUND.
I'M WONDERING IF WE CAN GET SOME
CLARITY.
AS TO WHAT IS THE PATHWAY THAT
ENSURES THAT THE PROFITS EARNED
BY HEALTH PLANS ARE ACTUALLY
BEING IMPLEMENTED AND BEING
BROUGHT BACK TO CONSUMERS --
YEAH GREAT QUESTION RIGHT AND
YOU KNOW WITH.
I GO BACK TO TOO LONG QUESTIONS
ARE SO --
THE FIRST QUESTION IN TWENTY
NINE PATIENTS --
TO HAVE OR GETTING SOME SOME
COVERAGE FIRST OF ALL --
BACK UP A LITTLE BIT --
IN STAGE RENAL DISEASE IS THE
ONE DISEASE THAT ASSURES THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE --
THAT THAT YOU COULD BE COVERED
BY MEDICARE --
AT ANY AGE.
AT ANY AGE FULL SCOPE MEDICARE
SERVICES AT ANY AGE.
THE SAFETY NET EXIST TO PROTECT
PEOPLE JUST LIKE YOU'RE JUST
LIKE YOUR YOUR CONSTITUENTS --
WHETHER IT'S MEDI CAL OR
MEDICARE NOTHING IN THE BILL
PROHIBITS --
THE AMERICAN KIDNEY FIND FROM
CONTINUING TO CONTRIBUTE TO HELP
PATIENTS --
THEY SAY THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BASED ON AN OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL DECISION THAT WAS MADE
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THAT IS AN
ARGUMENT THAT DID NOT COME UP
LAST YEAR AND WE JUST LEARNED OF
THAT RECENTLY AND I STILL AM TO
THIS DAY DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD
DECISION.
AFFECTS THIS BILL BECAUSE AS FAR
AS I KNOW THE AG IS NOT WEIGHED
IN ON WHAT WE'RE DOING --
I AS FAR AS PROFITS FOR
INSURANCE PLANS INSURANCE PLANS
ARE HIGHLY REGULATED --
THEY HAVE A CAP ON THEIR PROFITS --
AND THE DIALYSIS INDUSTRY HAS A
VERY HIGH PROFIT MARGIN IT'S
ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN MANY MANY
SECTORS OF THE OF THE HEALTH
CARE SPACE RIGHT NOW.
SO THEY ARE MAKING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS --
AND AND AND PARTICULAR INSTANCE.
THEY'RE MAKING A CONTRIBUTION.
TO THE AMERICAN CAN BE FUN FOR
WHICH THEY'RE GETTING A TAX
[inaudible]
DEDUCTION.
AND THEY'RE GETTING THROUGH THE
AMERICAN CAN BE FUN.
PAYING FOR INSURANCE PREMIUMS
THAT REIMBURSE THEM AT THREE OR
FOUR TIMES THE RATE FOR MEDI CAL
SO THEY'RE GETTING TO KIND OF
DOUBLE DIPPING [inaudible]
MY OPINION.
THANK YOU ARE MISSED BURKE.
OKAY SO ON WHAT YOU JUST SAID SO.
CAN THE FUN CAN STILL PAY
WHATEVER THAT 20% THAT MEDICARE
AND THE PHONE WILL STILL BE ABLE
TO DO ABSOLUTELY NOTHING THERE'S
NOTHING PREVENTS THEM FROM DOING
THAT I THINK SO I WON IT FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU BECAUSE YOU
HAVE SPENT.
SOME TIME WITH ME AND ADDRESSED
A LOT OF MY CONCERNS BECAUSE I
DO HAVE OVER HALF MY DISTRICT IS
ON MEDI CAL. 60% OF MY DISTRICT
IS AFRICAN AMERICAN AND WE
SUFFER GREATLY I HAVE THREE
TIMES THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREEL HAS --
IN HER DISTRICT ON THIS PROGRAM
SO THE THOSE FOLKS BUT FOR ME AS
I HAVE EXPRESSED TO YOU AND TO
THE SUPPORTERS AND OPPOSITION --
LISTEN I I KNOW THERE IS SOME I
HATE TO SAY THIS I KNOW THERE IS
SOME DISDAIN FOR THE OWNERS OF
SOME OF THESE CLINICS AND I
DON'T ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT THAT --
AND I DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
BEEN ATTACKS ON SEVERAL LEVELS
ON THE CLINICS I ACTUALLY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THAT EITHER.
WHAT I DO CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT
IS I LIVE IN A DISTRICT WHERE
PEOPLE ARE CHALLENGED AND AS
THIS AS RENEE CAN TELL YOU CHECK
IT'S ONE THING TO BE FISCALLY
CHALLENGED IT'S ANOTHER THING TO
DO THAT AND THEN DO YOUR
DIALYSIS OVERNIGHT?
A BECAUSE YOU CAN'T THAT'S THE
ONLY TIME YOU'RE ABLE TO DO IT
AND THAT'S AND RIGHT NOW MY
FOLKS HAVE ACCESS TO CLINICS.
SO I AM VERY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CONSISTENT ATTACKS ON
THE DIALYSIS CLINICS BECAUSE MY
FOLKS CAN'T GO SOMEWHERE ELSE
THEY CAN'T TAKE THREE BUSES THEY
LOSE THEIR JOB AND QUITE FRANKLY
WITH THE TRANSPLANT THEY LOSE
THEIR JOB.
AND SO I JUST MY CONCERN AND
IT'S MORE OF A STATEMENT THAN
ANYTHING ELSE IS AS WE CONTINUE
I I LOOK FORWARD TO ALTERNATIVE
METHODS OF TREATING.
END STAGE RENAL DISEASE I REALLY
DO BUT UNTIL THAT TIME I JUST
WANT TO BE VERY VERY CLEAR WITH
EVERYBODY OF THE SUPPORTERS AND
THE OPPOSITION THAT. FOR ME I
WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY BUT
I AM I GO TO MY REAL CLINICS
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY AND
BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT HAVE TO USE THEM.
I GO REGULARLY DURING MY BREAK I
GO TO TWO OR THREE AND I I WILL
FIND IT VERY OFFENSIVE THE IF AT
ANY POINT THAT I FIND I BELIEVE
IN THE SHORT TERM THEY'RE
KNOCKING CLOSE.
BUT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LONG TERM AND I A WILL WATCH ALL
OF THESE BILLS CAREFULLY THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH EIGHT AND STAGE
RENAL DISEASE BECAUSE MY
DISTRICTS AWFUL SO BAD FROM IT --
IF I START TO SEE DISTRICTS SEE
RENAL IF I SEARCH SEE SOME OF
THESE PLACES BECAUSE OF MY
DISTRICT I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A VERY SERIOUS
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION --
I APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU HAVE
DONE SO FAR I APPRECIATE THE
TIME YOU'VE SPENT TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH ME AND I KNOW
YOU KNOW I AM I AM VERY SERIOUS
ABOUT THIS.
BUT I STATE ABOUT THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION I JUST TRY I JUST
WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT SOME
PEOPLE LIKE RENE.
WHO WHO REALLY THIS IS THE NEXT
LEVEL OF SUFFERING TO WORK IN
SOME OF THE CONDITIONS THEY WORK
AND AND THEN TO HAVE TO GO? TO
SIT FOR FOUR HOURS OR OVERNIGHT
FOR IT'S EXHAUSTING.
AND I JUST HOPE FOR THINKING
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE FOLKS FAR
BEFORE THE TIME WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT WHETHER --
ANY OF THESE FACILITIES ARE
PROFITABLE OR WHETHER YOU ARE
PROFITABLE INSURANCE AGENCY.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS AT ALL --
MISTER RAMOS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR STILL A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ON ANALYSIS
THAT -- CAME
OUT FROM THE COMMITTEE ON ON ON
HOW.
ON PAGE FIVE THERE'S A A
STATEMENT OF PURPOSE OF THE BILL.
IT SAYS THAT --
MAY BE VERY PATIENTS AWAY FROM
MEDICARE AND THAT STATEMENT MAY
BE HAVE WE SOLIDIFIED OUR
VALIDATED THAT STATEMENT AT ALL
[inaudible]
UGH.
IT'S DIFFICULT IT'S DIFFICULT TO
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CLINICS AND BUT WE N A SOMEBODY
ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK TO THAT BUT
THAT'S PARTIALLY JUST A
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE THAT IN NOT
ALL CASES IS ITS STEERING A
PATIENT.
OFF OF A GOVERNMENT PROGRAM
OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT IF A
PATIENT IS STILL EMPLOYED ONE
THEY START DIALYSIS.
THEN SOMEONE FROM THE CLINIC
WILL GO TO THAT PATIENT.
AND SAY TO THEM YOU CAN APPLY
FOR A GRANT FROM THE FROM THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND TO PAY YOUR
PREMIUMS INSTEAD OF GOING ON TO
A PUBLIC PROGRAM.
AND SO IT'S IT'S HOLDING
PATIENTS ON COMMERCIAL COVERAGE
WHEN OTHERWISE THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN EL ELIGIBLE TO GO ON TO
MEDICARE.
AND AND SO THAT'S WHERE THE LINE
GETS A LITTLE BIT BLURRED BUT WE
HAVE DOCUMENTED CASES.
WHERE PATIENTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN FULL SCOPE MEDIC HAL?
WERE.
ENROLLED IN COMMERCIAL COVERAGE --
WHILE THEY WERE STILL IT IN SO
ADDING A FULL SCOPE COVERAGE
PLAN ON TOP OF THEIR MEDI CAL.
SO WE'VE SEEN BOTH HOLDING
PATIENTS FROM GOING ON TO
GOVERNMENT PLANS.
AS WELL AS MOVING PATIENTS FROM
A GOVERNMENT PLAN ON TO A
COMMERCIAL PLAN.
SO WITH THAT STATEMENT AS FAR AS
MAY BE VERY PATIENT TO SAY IT'S
NOT A 100% SO THERE IS SOME.
SOME.
WAY AS FAR AND PROFIT NUMBERS
THAT WERE JUST QUOTED --
BY THE AUTHOR THEN IF THAT'S THE
CASE OF SOME OF THOSE --
NUMBERS THAT WERE QUOTED WOULD
BE FLUID ALSO BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
100% RIGHT.
IF I'M SEEING IT RIGHT.
I THINK IT THE THE PROFIT NUMBER
CERTAINLY THE THE PROFIT NUMBER
THAT THE COMPANY REPORTS IS --
FOR THE STATE IS IS IS AVAILABLE
TO THEIR SCHOOL THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS.
OUT THERE --
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY POTENTIALLY BE SAVED
HERE IS IS PART OF WHAT IS WE'RE
NOT EXACTLY SURE OF BUT BECAUSE
YOU'RE EXTRAPOLATING THE NUMBERS --
BASED ON WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
ONE COMPANY TALK TO THEIR TALK
TO THEIR SHAREHOLDERS SO SO IT
IS A IT IS DIFFICULT TO GET
EXACT PANEL ON THAT.
BUT BUT IF THAT IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR PLAYERS IN THE INDUSTRY
AND THAT BEING THE CASE IT'S I
THINK IT'S FAIRLY REASONABLE TO
EXTRACT BUT YOU ALSO HAVE.
NONPROFIT CLINICS THAT ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES WELL SO I
THINK BELIEVE THE TWO MAJOR --
COMMERCIAL --
PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES --
ARE -- SAID
OF THE MARKET ROUGHLY
[inaudible]
SO.
HI IF I MIGHT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE QUESTION OF STEERING HAS
BEEN RAISED.
THE DIALYSIS INDUSTRY IS ONE OF
THE MOST HEAVILY REGULATED
INDUSTRIES IN THE NATION.
ERROR HERE ARE THE CONDITIONS
FOR COVERAGE.
THAT WERE ADOPTED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BY CMS.
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY AS A
MEDICARE PROVIDER AND 80% OF OUR
PATIENTS ARE MEDICARE PATIENTS
SO YOU HAVE TO BE A MEDICARE
PROVIDER IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
YOU HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
CONDITIONS FOR COVERAGE THE
CONDITIONS FOR COVERAGE HAVE
MANY MANY --
PROVISIONS RELATING.
TO MANDATES THAT YOU PROVIDE
YOUR PATIENTS WITH INFORMATION
ABOUT INSURANCE OPTIONS.
BUT ALSO PROHIBITING ANY
STEERING ACTIVITY BY THE
DIALYSIS FACILITIES SO WE FLATLY
REJECT THE IDEA THAT WE'RE
STEERING PATIENTS AND AND IN
PARTICULAR WE WOULD NEVER STEER
PATIENT OFF OF A MEDICARE
PROGRAM BECAUSE THE COST OF
MONEY IF THEY EVER GET BACK ON
IT'S IT'S ONE OF THE PROBLEMS.
WE FACE IS A VERY COMPLICATED
REGULATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS AND
SO YOU SORT OF TO SORT THROUGH
THE MALL BUT WHEN YOU TAKE WHEN
YOU TAKE.
WHEN YOU PULL THE PIECES STRING
AND AND TAKE ALL THIS MONEY AWAY
FROM PROVIDERS AND PUT IT IN THE
HANDS OF THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY?
YOU HAVE TO ASSUME THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME KIND OF ADVERSE
AFFECT ON PATIENTS AND THAT'S
OUR CONCERN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MORE QUESTIONS WAS ROSS
YEAH I HAVE A RATHER MISTER
CHAIR -- AND
ALSO IN THE BACK OF MATERIAL IT
TALKS ABOUT --
CMS AND AND A RULING --
THERE WAS MOVING FORWARD BUT
THEN --
ENDED UP BEING --
CHALLENGED --
AND IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER CMX
WILL MOVE FOR WITH THIS RULE IS
THERE AN UPDATE ON THAT AND
THAT'S ON PAGE SIX THE SECOND
PARAGRAPH.
YES THAT SAID THE IT APPEARS
THAT THE THE THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION FUHRMAN'S RATIONS
ACTUALLY MOVING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION AWAY FROM.
AWAY FROM THAT.
BUT THOSE THAT BROUGHT THAT IN
THE INDUSTRY THAT'S THERE IS OUR
WILLINGNESS TO BE ABLE TO TALK
OR EVEN DISCUSS EVEN OF THOSE
PARAMETERS THAT WERE THERE.
POSSIBLY AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY WELL THE THE
THERE'S NOW A MYSTERY AUTHOR AS
FAR AS TRYING TO SEE OF THE
INDUSTRY.
IS LOOKING AT SOME OF THOSE --
AREAS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED UNDER
THIS RULE --
GET OUT I DON'T I'M NOT REALLY
PREPARED TO I I I HAVE I HAVEN'T
SPOKE WITH ANYBODY AT CMS ON
THAT HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT WAY YOU TO DO MORE RESEARCH
ON THAT.
THANK YOU AND GET INTO THE THE
THE AVAILABILITY.
OF AS FAR AS THOSE THAT THAT ARE
IN THIS PROCESS YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
THAT WITH A MEMBER OF MY FAMILY.
WHO FIRST IT WAS DIAGNOSED LIFE
CHANGES RIGHT NOW AND YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE WHOLE FAMILY
COMES IN AND AND TO GET SOME?
THE CONSULTATION THAT'S THERE
AND HE GOES THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT --
ASPECTS THE EFFECTS ON LIFE THE
EATING THE THE DIETARY ALL THOSE
THINGS --
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO HAS TO GO
TO ONE OF THESE CLINICS --
THREE TIMES A WEEK.
AND IF YOU MISS THAT APPOINTMENT.
YOU HAVE TO EITHER MAKE IT UP
ANOTHER DAY OR THIS OR SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO GO FROM ONE PLACE TO
ANOTHER.
RIGHT SO THAT THE THE QUESTION
THAT HAS BEEN RAISED AS FAR AS
WILL THIS AFFECT --
THOSE FACILITIES THAT PEOPLE ARE
BEING ABLE TO GO TO DURING THAT
TIME.
IS SOMETHING OF A CONCERN --
ALSO TO MYSELF.
GOING THROUGH THAT AND MAKING
SURE THAT AND IF YOU MISS THE
APPOINTMENT YOU GOTTA GO AND TRY
TO FIND ANOTHER PLACE.
OR BECAUSE LIFE IS ON THE LINE.
THEN AFTER THAT MOVES FOR IF
YOU'RE LUCKY ENOUGH YOU'RE ABLE
TO GET THE EQUIPMENT AND START
TO HAVE THE PROCESS DONE AT HOME.
OVER NIGHT OR SOMETIME DURING
THE DAY.
AND YOUR HONOR A LIST --
FOR KIDNEY TRANSPLANT THINGS ARE
BEING WAITED IN MY MIND AS FAR
AS WHICH DIRECTION I WILL GO ON
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THAT WHEN WE
START TALKING ABOUT THE AFFECT
OF POSSIBLY CLOSING.
ANY OF THE AREAS THAT SERVICES --
BECOMES A CONCERN FOR ME AND SEE
THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING MOVING
FORWARD --
BUT THEN SITTING BACK DOWN WITH
THE INDUSTRY TO TRY TO SEE IF
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
LOOKED AT AS FAR AS MOVING
FORWARD --
TO WEAR THIS BILL COULD OFF
ULTIMATELY BE.
ALSO -- WAY
STRONG AND IN MY POSITION SO I
CONTINUE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHERS
THAT ARE OUT THERE BUT I'M STILL.
THINKING PRETTY HARD ABOUT THIS
BILL.
THE US ROMANCE --
SOME MEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU --
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS THAT
SERIOUSLY WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME
ON BECAUSE THERE'S PROS THERE'S
CONS.
I MEAN BACK AND FORTH YOU CAN'T
REALLY COME TO A SOLID DECISION
A LOT OF TIMES BECAUSE ONE PART
ONE GROUP SAYS ONE THING AND
SOMEONE ELSE'S ANOTHER.
AND I'VE I'VE GOT KIND OF A LIST
OF THINGS AND I WON'T GO THROUGH
ALL OF THEM BECAUSE WE OFFER
PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH THEM BUT
YOU KNOW. ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS
WAS DIALYSIS ON THE PRO SIDE
DIALYSIS PROVIDERS A STEERING
PEOPLE AWAY FROM MEDICARE AND
ALL TO PRIVATE PLANS. TO
BASICALLY BENEFIT PROCESS.
ON THE OPPOSITION SIDE --
THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE NOT
STEERING WHEEL WORKING WITH
PATIENTS TO IDENTIFY THE BEST
PATH FOR THE PATIENT GOING
FORWARD.
ON THE PRO SIDE YOU KNOW ONCE A
PATIENT RUNS OUT OF THEIR THIRTY
MONTHS OF PRIVATE INSURANCE.
THE CLINIC WILL KICK THEM OUT ON
THE STREET WITH NO TREATMENT.
THE OTHER SIDE SAYS NO BECAUSE
THEY GET ON TO MEDICARE WITH
THEM THAT'S A PROMISE SO WE'RE
YOU KNOW.
I'M THINKING OKAY WELL THEY
WOULD BE ON MEDICARE --
AT SOME POINT --
THE PRO SIDE SAYS THAT OF THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FUNDS IS ABUSING
ITS AUTHORITY.
SHOULD ONLY BE PAYING COPAYS NOW
PREMIUMS.
AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND HAS THE
AUTHORITY ON THE OPPOSITION SIDE
TO PAY PREMIUMS UNDER FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
AND I'M LISTENING TO TESTIMONY
TODAY.
AND SAYING THAT --
YOU KNOW MEDICAL LOSS RATIO
WOULD BE LOWER.
POSSIBLY YOU KNOW 1% INCREASE IN
PREMIUMS.
UP THERE'S NOT A COMMITMENT THAT
PATIENT PREMIUMS WOULD BE
LOWERED WHICH IS A CONCERN --
ANY SAVINGS ACHIEVED BY PAYING
MEDICARE RATES IS BUILT INTO
FUTURE PREMIUM MODELS ON THE PRO
SIDE.
HEALTH PLANS WILL CO A WINDFALL
OF SAVINGS.
NOT REDUCING THE COST OF
TREATMENT.
ONE FOUR THOUSAND ENROLLEES ARE
OFF SO IT'S LIKE.
BACK AND FORTH BUT LIKE TENNIS I
MEAN LITERALLY YOU CAN SEE BOTH
SIDES OF THE ARGUMENT.
AND THE CONCERN OBVIOUSLY FROM
ALL OF US IS FOR THE PATIENT AND
FOR THEIR ACCESS.
SO THE WAY I'M LOOKING AT IT --
AND ONE OF THE POINTS YOU KNOW
I'VE RUN A BUSINESS I UNDERSTAND.
PROFIT AND ISSUES WITH THAT.
LOTS OF TIMES WE RUN A BUSINESS
GET A PROFIT BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THE OWNERS OF
POCKETING IT.
BECAUSE IT REALLY GOES INTO THE
COST OF RUNNING THE BUSINESS
EXPANDING THE BUSINESS --
YOU KNOW.
IT CAME UP IN THE HEARING THAT --
FOR THE 10% THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED.
THE LOSE AROUND TWENTY FIVE TO
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN PROFIT.
OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THAT WAS
REPORTED.
BUT SINCE MEDICARE'S ONLY
COVERING 6280% OF THE COST OF
THE TREATMENT.
THAT LEAVES 2240% OF TREATMENT
490% OF THE PATIENTS NOT BEING
COVERED.
IF I'M UNDERSTANDING IT RIGHT.
SO WHAT IS THE COST OF THAT
DIFFERENCE.
AND THE MONEY MUST COME OUT OF
THE PROFITS.
WHERE ELSE WOULD IT BE COMING
FROM?
SO I MEAN I'M LOOKING AT THIS
WALL LOOKED AT IT.
THE SITUATION BASICALLY IS AN
INDIVIDUAL ON EMPLOYER INSURANCE.
THEY END UP YOU KNOW OVER TIME
GETTING END STAGE RENAL DISEASE
THEY LOSE THEIR JOB BECAUSE OF
THE TIME COMMITMENT IT TAKES. TO
TREAT.
THE DISEASE GOING INTO DIALYSIS
THREE TIMES A WEEK OR MORE.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR
INSURANCE THEY WANT TO KEEP THE
CONTINUITY.
THE KIDNEY FUND PAYS PREMIUMS
FOR UP TO THIRTY MONTHS.
AT THE END OF THIRTY MONTHS THEY
CAN AUTOMATICALLY BE ENROLLED IN
MEDICARE.
MEDICARE PAYS 6280% OF THE COST
OF DIALYSIS TREATMENT FOR THE
90%.
OF PATIENTS.
PRIVATE INSURANCE IS ABOUT
FAVORITE TAKE TIM --
PAYS A HIGHER COST WHICH
BASICALLY SUBSIDIZES.
THE OTHER PATIENTS.
WHO ARE GETTING THE TILES SO
THAT'S THE MODEL AT LEAST THE
WAY THAT I'M SEEING IT SO?
IF THE PATIENT IS WEALTHY AND
COMPARE THEIR OWN PREMIUMS THEY
DON'T NEED PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
THIS BILL DOESN'T AFFECT THEM.
SO WE'RE ONLY REALLY TALKING
ABOUT THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE LOW
INCOME.
WHICH IS KIND OF AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE --
I HAVE THREE DIALYSIS CLINICS IN
MY DISTRICT.
IF THIS BILL PASSES YOU KNOW THE
CONCERN IS ABOUT THEM POSSIBLY
CLOSING EVEN IF ONE OF THE THREE
CLOSE.
YEAH THEY'RE SPREAD ALL OVER OF
A LARGE DISTRICT AS YOU KNOW YOU
DO AND OTHERS --
THAT MEANS SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO
TRAVEL OVER FIFTY MILES TO GET
TO A DIALYSIS CLINIC.
THAT'S A CONCERN --
ACCESS TO THE HOSPITAL'S KNOW
THAT THAT'S WHERE EVERYONE'S
GOING TO GO BECAUSE OF WHERE
ELSE SOMETHING AND GO --
SO AT THIS POINT I DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH CONTROLLING THE
COSTS OF BASICALLY RATE SETTING
BECAUSE EVERY TIME WE BRING UP
THESE RATE SETTING NO MATTER IF
IT'S PHARMACEUTICALS OR OTHER
THINGS.
WHICH COULD PUT LIVES AND HEALTH
OF PEOPLE IN JEOPARDY BY
REDUCING ACCESS SO I'M GOING TO
BE LAYING OFF THE BILL.
TODAY BECAUSE THIS DISCUSSION IS
VERY DEEP.
AND I JUST WANNA SEE WORK GOALS
FOR US FOR OUR PATIENTS.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
I JUST --
MAYBE QUICK COMMENT AND THEN --
I DON'T KNOW YOUR QUESTION WILL
POP UP --
POP UP AS I'M THINKING HERE --
LAST YEAR --
WHEN THIS BILL CAME UP THEN IT
WAS SENATOR LEYVA AS A BILL?
AND I HAD I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
THIS LAST YEAR AND AND STARTING
OFF WITH THIS I WAS --
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THAT AND MOVE FORWARD AND I GOT
TO MAYBE MY SEVENTH OR EIGHTH
MEETING --
ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THE CRUX FOR ME WHERE I
BEGAN TO TURN --
WAS WHEN SOMEONE WAS SITTING IN
MY OFFICE AND THEY SAID THAT
THEY WOULD NOT THE AMERICAN
KIDNEY FUND WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THEIR PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
IF THEY WERE NOT GETTING
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE TWO MAJOR --
BUT ASK DASS SOME COMPANIES.
AND IS AT THAT MOMENT THAT I
THOUGHT.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE THAT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AT ALL.
IF THERE IS --
SIXTY THOUSAND CONTRIBUTORS TO
THE AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND WHY.
CAN'T THEY PROVIDE THIS PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE WITH THOSE SIXTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS THAT THEY HAVE
WHY DO THEY NEED.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS FROM JUST A
COUPLE OF OF DIFFERENT DIALYSIS
CLINICS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM WORK AND THAT'S WHEN I
WENT -- I
NEED TO DIG IN A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THAT WE HEARD TODAY --
FROM PHùIT'S ARE BAD I
ACTUALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
PROFITS ARE BAD --
WE LIVE NOT IN A PROFIT SYSTEM --
CAPITALISM IS NOT A PROFIT
SYSTEM DOES A PROFIT AND LOSS
SYSTEM AND WHEN YOU HAVE.
A FEW UNDERSTAND ECONOMICS
PROFITS MEAN THAT YOU'RE
PROVIDING VALUE --
TO TO FOLKS IF YOU HAVE A LOSS
THAT MEANS THAT YOU GOT TO RUN
YOUR COMPANY A LITTLE BIT BETTER
TO TRY TO GET TO BE ABLE TO GET
TO A PROFIT.
WHICH ARE TO TALK ABOUT HEALTH
CARE HEALTHCARE IS NOT A PURE
PROFIT LOSS SYSTEM YOU DON'T
HAVE -- A A
A PURE MARKET THERE ARE FOLKS
THAT ARE GAMING THE SYSTEM WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS.
A LITTLE BIT A LITTLE BIT LAST
YEAR.
I AM ALSO CONCERNED BECAUSE I
WAS MADE AWARE TODAY THAT I HAVE --
SIXTY INDIVIDUALS IN MY DISTRICT --
THAT ARE --
ON THIS PREMIUM ASSISTANCE PLAN
AND I I'M SURE THAT THOSE FOLKS
WANT TO CONTINUE --
ON ON THAT PLAN WE HAVE A MAN A
MUCH BIGGER PROBLEM WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THAT DOUBLE WE KNOW.
THAT UP AS A PERCENTAGE OF OUR
GDP IN THE UNITED STATES AND IN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WE SPEND MORE PER GDP PER CAPITA
THAN VIRTUALLY EVERYWHERE ELSE
WHY IS THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A A PURE --
BUT COMPETITIVE OF HEALTH CARE A
MARKET SO WE'VE GOT FOLKS THAT
ARE COMING TO US IN THEIRS THE
TERM OF RENT SEEKING FOLKS ARE
COMING TO US ASKING US TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE DECISIONS.
AND IT IS IT OESN'T IT JUST AT
ITS CORE IT DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT
THAT FOR A COMPANY TO SAY FOR
THEM TO CONTINUE TO BE
PROFITABLE THERE HAS TO BE A
SCHEME IN WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION ON THE SIDE THAT
THEY HAVE TO MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS.
TO TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR
SYSTEM WORK THAT'S NOT DEFEAT AS
FAULT THAT'S NOT FOR SINISE'S
FAULT THAT'S THE FACT THAT OUR
SYSTEM ISN'T BUILT PROPERLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE.
TO OPERATE AND THEN WITH THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WHEN THEY
CAME IN WITH MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S GUARANTEED ISSUE THAT
THROUGH ANOTHER WRENCH IN INTO
THE SYSTEM.
AND SO I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON US AS LEGISLATORS TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP DOING THIS WORK
THIS ISN'T GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
COMPREHENSIVELY AND WHEN WE SEE
THESE INEFFICIENCIES BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS IT IS
INEFFICIENT.
IT'S NOT WRONG IT'S NOT
NEFARIOUS IT'S NOT EVIL IT'S NOT
OF ALL ABOUT PROFIT MONGERING
BUT WHAT IT IS ABOUT IS APT IS
INEFFICIENCY THE WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SOLVE.
AND SO FOR TODAY I KNOW THIS
ISN'T THIS ISN'T IT THIS IS IN
THE THE SOLUTION FOR ALL BUT IT
IS A PART OF THE SOLUTION THAT
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO KEEP.
TALKING ABOUT I GUESS I DON'T
HAVE A QUESTION THERE --
Là MISTER CHAIR --
IN THE IN SO WITH THAT I WOULD
AND FOR THE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION LOOK THIS BILL IS NOT
INCONSISTENT WITH ALL THE WORK
I'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
BUT YEAR WE DO WE WORK ON A BILL
RELATED TO DRUG COUPONS.
WHAT ARE THAT BILL DO
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES FOR
USING COUPONS AS A WAY TO KEEP
PEOPLE ON THEIR HIGHER PRICED
MEDICATIONS FOR LONGER WHEN
THERE WAS A GENERIC AVAILABLE?
INTERESTING WE WE ASK THE
COUPONS TO GO AWAY WHAT HAVE WE
ASK FOR THAT TO NOT HAPPEN --
THE COUPONS DISAPPEARED EVEN
FROM IN THOSE CASES WHERE THEY
COULD BE LEGITIMATELY USED IN
MANY CASES.
WE LOOK AT PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGERS AND TRANSPARENCY AROUND
A MIDDLE MAN.
THAT GENERATES TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
PROFIT --
WITH THREE COME THIS SENSUALLY
THREE COMPANIES 80% OF THE
MARKET -- TO
THE TWENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
AS A MIDDLE MAN.
WE HEARD SOME REALLY INTERESTING
STORIES ABOUT HOW THEY GENERATE
THAT THROUGH P. THROUGH REBATES
AND SO ON AND WE GOT A
TRANSPARENCY BILL PASSED WE HAD
SB SEVENTEEN LOOKED AT
TRANSPARENCY FOR DRUG PRICE
INCREASES.
AND THAT BILL AFTER MUCH DEBATE
MUCH DISCUSSION OVER TWO YEARS
PAST LOOKING AT HOW DO WEEK
WE'RE TRYING TO SAVE CONSUMERS.
MONEY HERE TRYING TO SAVE THE
SYSTEM MONEY WE HAD A BILL LAST
YEAR THAT LOOKED AT HEALTH PLAN
MERGERS AND OVERSIGHT OVER
HEALTH PLAN MERGERS BECAUSE I
DON'T NECESSARILY BELIEVE THAT
BIGGER IS GOING TO RESULT
POSITIVE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO WITH REGARDS TO THIS WITH
RELATED TO DIALYSIS THE ONE
CONDITION THAT I'M AWARE OF
THEIR MAYBE OTHERS IF I'M WRONG
I'LL I'LL I'LL DO MORE STUDY.
WHERE THERE IS PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR MEDICARE
[inaudible]
IMMEDIATELY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WAIT THIRTY
MONTHS TO GET ON MEDICARE
[inaudible]
AND SO.
THIS THIS PAIN FOR A PLAN TO
KEEP SOMEBODY ON COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE FOR UP TO THIRTY
MONTHS --
WHEN THEY COULD BE ON SOMETHING
ELSE DOESN'T PROHIBIT SOMEONE
WHO WANTS TO STAY ON THEIR PLAN --
DOESN'T PROHIBIT THAT AT ALL BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MY
CONVERSATIONS LAST YEAR WITH THE
AMERICAN KINNEY FIND WORK THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE ACTUALLY
GETTING THIS ASSISTANCE WERE
MAKING TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR OR LAST.
NOW HELP ME TO UNDERSTAND AND IF
AND AS I HEARD TODAY AND I WANT
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THAT ABOUT
THIS.
HELP ME TO UNDERSTAND HOW
SOMEONE WHO IS WHO'S MAKING
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
OR LESS.
CAN PAY FOR ALL OF THE
COMPLICATIONS THAT MIGHT ARISE
FROM FROM THEIR PLANT FROM FROM
THEIR DISEASE.
WITH THEIR PRIVATE PLAN.
ALL THE CO PAYS FOR
HOSPITALIZATION --
FOR OTHER SPECIALISTS THAT MIGHT
BE RELATED HOW DO THEY PAY FOR
THAT.
AND IS IS THE AMERICAN CAN YOU
FIND PAY ALL THEIR COPAYS AS
WELL. FOR THESE FOR THIS.
I'M NOT AWARE THAT THEY DO.
HALF OF THE PATIENTS IN CUTTER
HERE TWO THOUSAND ARE GETTING
HELP WITH MEDICARE ADVANTAGE
WHICH WHICH BECOMES AN ALL
INCLUSIVE PLAN AT THAT POINT.
BUT TWO THOUSAND OR NOT HOW DO
THOSE TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE PAY
THEIR COPAYS FOR OTHER
CONDITIONS THAT ARE UNRELATED TO
THEIR DIALYSIS.
WHAT WHEN THEY COULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDICARE OR MEDIC CAL?
AT THE END OF THE DAY IF WE'RE
RELYING ON ONE OR TWO ENTITIES
TO FUND THE AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND --
IS THIS AND AND AND AND WE'RE
BEING TOLD THAT THAT WILL GO
AWAY IF THIS BILL PASSES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IS THAT IS
THAT IS THAT TRULY IT WHEN I
GIVE MONEY TO A FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE AS A CHARITABLE DONATION I
CONSIDERED A TERRIBLE DONATION?
IS IT NO LONGER CHARITABLE
ANYMORE IF BY MAKING THAT
CONTRIBUTION I'M NOT MAKING
MONEY ON THE OTHER END.
THAT'S THE POINT THAT'S THE
POINT IT'S ABOUT THE BIGGER
SYSTEM AND WHAT IT'S GOING TO
COST US ALL.
IT'S CONSIST WITH EVERYTHING
I'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AS CAN BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE OTHER THINGS
I LOOK AT IN THE FUTURE.
WHAT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I. BUT?
THANK YOU --
DOCTOR WOULD HAVE AND WITH THAT
I AM WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
UGH IT IS A MOTION BY BONTA
SECOND BY MCCARTY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THE OF THE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS OUR PREPARATIONS WHAT.
WHAT I'D MAYES AYE MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW?
BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA [inaudible]
LOW MOAN.
MCCARTY BY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
BROWN'S LOW. TO TO AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING.
TEND.
TO THE MOTION PASSES ARE
INTENDED TO AND WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE --
BILLS.
TO GO THROUGH AND AND WE SAW
SOME THAT OURS ON ON CALL
[inaudible]
THE CALL OKAY.
FROM THE START.
START AT THE TOP THAT SAYS YES.
OKAY.
SO WE JUST VOTED ON AB --
TWO OH FOR ITEM NUMBER ONE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B..
TWO TWO EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN THE ROLE AN ADD ON AS
TRADITIONAL.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE.
FIFTEEN THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO I'M
SORRY SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO AB TWO SIXTY TWO
WOULD LIKE TO LIFT THE CALL AND
ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE AYE FLORA.
HOW FAR IS NOT PUTTING THE MON?
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN AYE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I'D.
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN AND WHILE OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AB TWO NINETY
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY CAME AND
LARA WILL WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
AT AND AND AT ADDITIONAL VOTES.
NO OKAY WE WON'T DO THAT THEN.
AB.
HE P. THREE EIGHTEEN WILL LIFT
THE CALL AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I
FLOOR -- Là
MON.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I TWENTY TWO THAT'S
TWELVE TO TO HAVE BILLS OUT --
ITEM NUMBER.
SIX WILL LOW OPEN THE ROLE IN AT
AND AT THE CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BIGELOW AYE.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
HI Là M<c.cyan>.</c>
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI FOURTEEN ZERO THAT'S
FOURTEEN ZERO ON ITEM NUMBER --
SEVEN AB THREE SIXTY TWO WILL
LIFT THE CALL AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
LOOKING.
AT ITEM SEVEN AB.
THREE SIXTY TWO BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE HI
[inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I THREE THAT'S ELEVEN
TO THREE THAT BILL WAS OUT.
ON THE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WE'RE
GONNA LIVE THEY ACTUALLY OPEN
THE ROLE AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE MCCARTY.
AYE.
PARTY I WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
NINE A. B. --
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
ON TIME MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
HI.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO AND SO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO BILLS FOR
THE NEXT. FIVE MINUTES
[inaudible] TWO ONE TO FOR WE
DID A WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
EITHER ON TO THAT WAS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY SO WE'RE OPEN THE ROLE ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO OH FOUR
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
ZERO OKAY.
MISS LOAN IS HERE SO WITH WHAT I
MR FLOOR IS HERE SO.
LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE LARA [inaudible]
LIMóN I AS THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER.
FOUR OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS IN MARIN.
NINETY WHAT WAS THAT.
AB TWO NINETY I REMEMBER
[inaudible]
FOR NO.
I'M SORRY NOT REALLY SOLDIERS
FOR NOT VOTING.
LOW MOAN.
Là M<c.cyan> ÁI. ELEVEN TO</c>
ELEVEN TO AND ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB THREE EIGHTEEN WILL OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
LIMON I'M NOT I THAT'S THIRTEEN
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB THREE
NINETEEN OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AMONG.
THEM I FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER --
SEVEN OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS LARA [inaudible]
LARA NOW [inaudible] ELEVEN FOR
ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT FIFTEEN
FIFTEENS ARE ALREADY AND ITEM
NUMBER NINE FIFTEEN ZERO OKAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THAT'S THANK.
DOES PRESENT VOTING.
DOESN'T RECORDING SO YOU COULD.
IS.
THAT RIGHT.
IT DOESN'T GET.
YES YES.
SIR.
BUT THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE THE MEETING THANK YOU